Imagine having a mobile that doesn't have the ability to talk to computers on the Internet. You couldn't send and receive mail. As time has gone on, more and more devices have shown up on the net. So the Internet was designed in 1973 and launched in 1983. In that timeframe, we thought it was an experiment. So we allocated address space, sort of like telephone numbers, sufficient to define 4.3 billion termination points in the Internet. Now I can tell you in 1983 that seemed like it would last forever, but remember, it was an experiment. The thing is that the experiment never.
Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch hier zu 197. Ausgabe, in der es mal wieder um Technik gehen soll. Wurde ja mal wieder Zeit. Ich misch das hier immer ganz gerne und hab auch immer gerne wechselnde Gesprächspartner, aber heute bin ich mir in der Hinsicht ein bisschen untreu geworden und hab nochmal jemanden eingeladen, den wir vor kurzem schon mal hatten, nämlich Clemens. Ja, wir haben ja, da ist ja eine Menge Staub aufgewirbelt mit der 191, Internet im Festnetz. Definitiv die Sendung, die am meisten Kommentare nach sich gezogen hat.
Die Bierkollegen, der Andreas folgt mir dicht auf, glaube ich, oder?
Ja, das Bierthema hat auf jeden Fall auch eine Menge bewirkt, aber ich glaube, der Leidensdruck war da nicht so groß. Das ist definitiv der Unterschied, weil gutes Internet haben, das ist ja, sagen wir mal, ein noch verkanntes Menschenrecht. Und da tut die Aufklärung auf jeden Fall bitter Not.
Es gibt ja auch einige Leute, wenn man die Kommentare gelesen hat, die da wirklich Erfolg mit hatten, einfach mal bei ihrem Provider nochmal anzurufen und die zu fragen, ob sie noch alle Tassen im Schrank haben und ob sie das wirklich ernst zu meinen und ein paar von denen.
Machen sie mir nichts vor, ich hab CRE gehört. Schock and awe in den Support-Abteilungen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Aber das freut mich ein wenig, du hörst das. Ich bin da nicht ganz, nicht ganz unglücklich drüber.
Kann ich mir vorstellen. Genau, so. Aber heute soll es um etwas anderes, wenn auch verwandtes, gehen. Und fragt es ja hier vorhin noch so, warum eigentlich jetzt? Eigentlich steht dieses Thema schon seit Ewigkeiten auf der Liste und du wirst lachen. Ich selber hab mal einen Vortrag auf dem Kongress über IPv6 gehalten. Aber frag mich jetzt bitte nicht mehr genau, wann das war. Das war, das war noch, da war noch der Kongress noch in Hamburg. Also als sich das alles abzeichnet, wo er jetzt wieder hingeht. Damals hat sich das irgendwie abgezeichnet schon, so ja, mit dem V4, das geht nicht ewig so weiter und im Wesentlichen wollen wir das irgendwie die und die Richtung treiben. Und ich hab dann irgendwann mal nur so die Informationen zusammengetragen und so ein bisschen vorgestellt, also Vortrags in gewisser Hinsicht. Fast schon übertrieben.
War bestimmt noch IPNG damals. Noch gar nicht V6.
Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch. Der Begriff kursierte schon. Aber daran merkt man jetzt auch schon, also die Rede ist jetzt von IPv6. Das ist der neuen Version des Internetprotokolls. Das IP quasi so der, ja, so das Blut im Netzwerk der Welt. Und das, was halt alles irgendwie von A nach B und von B nach C bringt. Und das Internet wurde geboren mit V4. Und das Thema selbst, V4, ist ja hier auch schon mal behandelt worden. CRE 141 war das, wo ich schon mal versucht habe, zusammenzufassen, was man sich eigentlich konkret darunter vorstellen muss. In gewisser Hinsicht ist das jetzt also hier so ein Anschluss-Podcast. Andererseits denke ich, muss man aber auch hier noch mal so ein bisschen von vorne anfangen. Ich habe damals mit Fabian Yamaguchi mich halt extrem auf V4 und so auch dieses ganze Zusammenspiel des Protokoll-Stacks etc. Also TCP, UDP, wie das alles zusammenarbeitet. Das soll jetzt hier nicht so sehr der Fokus sein, sondern wir wollen jetzt ganz konkret reden über das Warum und Wie der technischen Umstellung des Austausches eben dieses Schicht 3 Protokolls und auch auf diese Schichten, glaube ich, müssen wir noch mal zu sprechen kommen. Also eine Herausforderung. Ja, Tim, du beschäftigst dich ja, fragten sich so einige Leute, warum du überhaupt berechtigt bist, für das Internet zu sprechen?
Für das Internet? Ich kann dir mal eine Pressemitteilung herausgeben, das Internet.
Du hast ja hier und da erwähnt, dass du auch schon mal ein Modem besessen hast, aber dass du so ein richtiger Internet-Eingeborener bist, das kam, glaube ich, gar nicht so richtig zur Sprache.
Ja, ich habe mich ja sehr früh mit diesen Themen befasst. Ich fand das ja, habe ich auf einem letzten CRE 191 schon mal mit angefangen, diese Kommunikation überhaupt über Weitverkehr hinweg. Da kann man natürlich alte Telefonnetze benutzen, mit Modem rüberpfeifen. Man kann aber halt eben auch richtig Paketvermittelnde Netze benutzen. Und ich glaube, ich habe meine ersten IP-Pakete Mitte der 80er Jahre in Hand gehabt. Das muss so 1985 gewesen sein, 84, 85. Damals gab es von einem Phil Kahn, hieß der, eine lustige kleine Software namens Ka9Q. Man merkt schon, das war auch so ein Amateurfunk-Ding. Und der war einer der ersten, der sozusagen mal eine öffentliche Implementation von IP mal rausgetan hat. Und die habe ich damals schon in Deutschland betrieben über Datex P mit einem 4800 Bit.
Also Ka9Q, das war eine DOS?
Ja, das ist ein Stückchen C-Code, das gab es aber auch fertig kompiliert für DOS. Und da war auch alles in einem Paket drin. Das war jetzt nicht ein IP-Stack für DOS oder sonst was. Das war alles im User-Land sozusagen, in dem Programm drin. Da gab es dann einen kleinen Telnet-Server, der war Mitbestandteil oder einen kleinen FTP-Server, der war Mitbestandteil dieser Software. Also IP, TCP und FTP in einer Software drin. Und wie gesagt, die habe ich dann mal angeworfen und mich dann mit Leuten verbunden. Mit, weiß ich noch, Uni Dortmund. Da saßen die anderen Leute, die schon damals was am Hut hatten. Die hatten 9600 Bit nach Amsterdam. Und ich hatte 4800 Bit von Berlin nach Dortmund. Und damit haben wir ein bisschen mit IP mal gespielt. Das war schon IPv4, so wie du das kennst heute, ne? Damals gab es noch überhaupt nix von HTTP oder Webseiten oder diesem ganzen anderen Quatsch, der darauf war. War so richtig basic, ne? IP, TCP, Syndicate. Internetprotokoll. Aber von v4 redete da keiner, aber war halt das einzige Bekannte. Das war die Version Nummer 4, war im Header drin, aber das hat keinen interessiert. Weil das war halt das Einzige, was da war.
1, 2, 3 waren sozusagen nur Tests.
Da gab es noch nicht mal DNS. Du hast richtig schön brav IP-Adressen von Hand eingeklopft oder ITC-Hosts-Dateien befüllt damit. In diesen Informationen so eine verteilte Infrastruktur wie DNS gab es da gar nicht. Da gab es auch wenig Organisationen. Ich habe aus dieser Zeit damals, oder vielleicht so ein, zwei Jahre später, habe ich mir IP-Adressraum zuteilen lassen. Damals noch direkt von irgendeinem, könnte sogar sein, dass das noch, also noch bevor diese ganzen Sachen wie Raipe gab, die jetzt in Europa IP-Adressen verteilen, so war das. Aus der Zeit habe ich noch Adressraum. Nicht wenig.
Das ist ja heutzutage schon eher so Goldstaub, ne?
Ein bisschen, ja. Ein Freund von mir hat doch behauptet, der hat sich das mal angeguckt, weil der meinte, die Volksrepublik China hätte vor 8 oder 9 Jahren weniger Adressraum gehabt als ich. Aber das hat sich inzwischen doch schon noch ein bisschen geändert. Ja, aus der Zeit stammt das. Da hab ich mich halt schon damit befasst und seitdem halt die ganze Geschichte mitverfolgt. Ich hab schon sehr früh, Anfang der 90er, war ich Mitglied des Interopnet. Interop war also Networld plus Interop. Das war so eine Messe, die um die Welt zog. Mit einem Show-Netz. Also da ist ein Netz, was zu dieser Ausstellung oder Messe mit dazu gehört. Die waren überall. Die waren auch, glaube ich, 1994 in Berlin und in Frankfurt und in Tokyo, in London, in Sydney und überall in den USA gibt es das immer noch, findet immer noch einmal statt.
Das war dann weniger so Internet als vielmehr so Netzwerke überhaupt.
Damals dann, also mit FIDI haben wir angefangen, FDDI oder dann später 100 Megabit Ethernet und Gigabit Ethernet und ATM gab es damals auch noch viel. Und da musste man ja irgendwas drauf machen. Wir haben natürlich darauf einen IP-Netz betrieben auch, unter anderem, aber wesentlich mit Internetanbindungen und so. Das habe ich auch so 10 Jahre, fast 10 Jahre lang gemacht. Ich habe in dem Zusammenhang auch häufiger an ITF-Meetings teilgenommen. Da kommen wir sicherlich noch drauf, was ITF ist und was da so passiert. Die Internet Engineering Task Force.
Genau, aber du hast ja dann auch selber Internet nach Berlin geholt.
Auch mit, ja. War auch mitbeteiligt an einer kleinen Firma als erster ISP. Als einer der wenigen kleinen ISPs haben wir dann angefangen aus einer bestehenden Mailbox-Szene mal so ein bisschen so einen Internet-Service-Provider zu machen. Oder einen Internet-Service-Provider zu etablieren aus einem Unternehmen heraus, was so ein bisschen aus dieser Mailbox-Szene stammte. Damals noch mit einer standard, nee, mit einer semipermanenten ISDN-Verbindung auf dem alten nationalen ISDN. 64 Kilobit nach Dortmund.
Semipermanente ISDN-Verbindung.
Musst du mal vorstellen, wir haben damals die Berliner Internet-Szene mit 64 Kilobit versorgt. Nicht ein einzelnen, sondern die Berliner Internet-Szene mit 64 Kilobit aus Dortmund. Das ging noch. Heute hast du 64 Kilobit im GPS und die Leute schreien Edge-Land, Edge-Land, weil ihr Twitter-Klein nicht geht. Oder so, ja.
Aber das Twitter-Klein ist das einzige, das noch geht.
Der Twitter-Klein ist das einzige, was in Edge-Land noch geht. Die Webseiten laden schon nicht mehr. Und damals war das alles noch ein bisschen ziviler.
Genau, aber da kriegt man natürlich einen ganz guten Eindruck dafür, wie sich das so weiterentwickelt hat. Also ich will jetzt nicht groß drauf rumreiten, aber nur, dass man es mal gesagt hat. Du bist ja dann auch weiterhin in der Branche geblieben und hast eigentlich im Wesentlichen immer in irgendwelchen Firmen gearbeitet, in denen es im weiteren Sinne um Internet ging.
Ja, Vernetzung, haben auch eigene Router gebaut, ISDN-Router gebaut, programmiert und so.
Gut, kommen wir mal auf das eigentliche Thema, also IP. Das ist halt so ein weites Feld, das...
Entschuldigung, ab jetzt ist es nicht mehr irrelevant, ob es V4 oder V6 ist. Also sagen wir jetzt bitte nicht mehr IP, sondern wir sagen jetzt immer V4 oder V6 oder IP V4 oder V6, dass wir da die Terminologie gerade kriegen.
Gut, also dann sollten wir vielleicht erst mal kurz sagen, für die, die es noch nicht mitbekommen haben, das Internet wurde irgendwann mal geboren, dann gab es IP und das ist sozusagen der relevante Teil, an dem der Datenaustausch, über den der Datenaustausch im Wesentlichen abgewickelt wird. Darüber gibt es dann diverse andere draufgeschachtete Protokolle, die wir heute jeden Tag so benutzen. TCP, UDP und dadrüber halt alles, was man sonst noch so im Browser eingibt. HTTP, FTP, etc., Wichtig ist bloß dieser Bereich, wo halt wirklich der Paketaustausch stattfindet. Das war, worin man die Daten ins Netz schickt. Und V4 war lange Zeit das einzige Protokoll und das hat ja soweit auch erstmal ganz gut getan. Also ich meine bis heute funktioniert, genau tut auch heute noch so 99,9 Prozent des Treffes glaube ich in diesem Internet dürften V4 sein und ich weiß nicht, ob V6 schon auf 0,01 Prozent wirklich kommt.
Oh, die sind schon ein bisschen, haben sie schon. Seit IPv6 Day, es gibt ja schon durchaus ein paar Provider oder größere Institutionen, wo V6 schon länger am Start ist. Und mit diesem IPv6 Day, der jetzt gerade irgendwie war, im Juni oder so, wartet mal wieder, haben halt eben auch größere Content-Anbieter sich dazu committed, das jetzt auch mal auf der Content-Seite anzubieten. Also die Facebooks dieser Welt, die Googles und so weiter und so fort. Und dann sind natürlich die Leute, die jetzt schon zum Beispiel in den Uni-Netzen oder so was, die ja schon seit vielen Jahren auch V6 teilweise anbieten, haben jetzt mal wieder auf ihren blöden Facebook-Account geklickt und tada, plötzlich war es dann mal per V6 geschehen oder so. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob Facebook, aber die ganzen anderen großen Mitspieler haben da mal ihre Infrastruktur auch nicht nur beta, sondern jetzt dauerhaft mal angeknipst. Und dadurch ist durchaus ein bisschen Treffik entstanden. Das ist immer noch marginal, also immer noch einstellige Prozentzahlen oder manchmal auch drunter. Da gibt es auch so schöne Statistiken von den jeweiligen Leuten, aber man sieht es jetzt, man da bumpt jetzt ein bisschen, wat. Man hat jetzt echte User, einen echten User, also nicht nur Nerds auf irgendwelchen Kongressen oder an irgendwelchen Unis, sondern echte User, die halt echte User-Dienste benutzen, wie Facebook oder so.
Gut, aber wenn wir so weit gekommen sind, wie wir jetzt eben sind mit IPv4, dann ist natürlich die Frage, die sich alle erst mal stellen so, warum muss es denn ersetzt oder ergänzt werden? Warum gibt es v6? Warum heißt es nicht v5? Warum?
Was ist das Problem? Zu letzter Frage, die kann man mal zuerst beantworten, niemand weiß das so genau. Es gab irgendwelche experimentellen Dinge, wo Leute irgendwie was rumgebastelt haben, nie was Offizielles. Jedenfalls haben die sich damals, als sie sagten, wir wollen v4 weiterentwickeln, geguckt, die sehen aha, okay, diese Bitte ist schon benutzt. Na ja, okay, wir müssen halt dann auf v6 gehen. Es gab nie ein v5. Jedenfalls nie, dass es öffentlich bekannt wäre. Man wusste nur irgendwo, ist da ein bisschen Smoke. Also, um da gleich Sachen zu vermeiden, hüpfen wir mal drumrum. Wir haben irgendwie ein paar Bits für diesen Protokoll-Identifier. Ich glaube, es sind vier Bits oder so weiter. Das heißt, sie haben noch Zeit. Sie können auch bis 15 hochgehen. Also, da sind sie dann von 4 auf 6 gegangen. Es gibt übrigens auch so Gerüchte, dass die Chinesen sich mal basteln, weil die Chinesen aus verschiedenen Gründen unzufrieden sind mit dem Internet, so wie es ist. Weil sie sind halt hängen am Tropf von anderen Leuten, was die Adressvergabe angeht. Und außerdem mit den ganzen Abhören und lalalala. Sie würden gerne was eigenes machen. Und da gibt es so Gerüchte, keine Ahnung, aber irgendwie, dass die mit der Version 7 oder 8 oder so was spielen im Herder und da irgendwie was basteln. Aber nochmal, das ist alles grau. Das ist ein ganz fieses Gerücht, oder das stammt aus der Wikipedia oder auch nicht, keine Ahnung. Ja, das ist also 6. Warum will man V4 ablösen? V4 hat ein paar Design-Schwächen, die lange genug gehalten haben, mit denen man sich auch so mehr schlecht als recht arrangiert hat bis heute. Eine der größten Schwächen, die auch vorrangig immer angeführt wird, für den Grund, warum man V6 überhaupt erdacht hat, oder initial hieß es ja IP Next Generation. Das war damals Anfang der 90er, als man so angefangen hat, so 92, 93 haben sie da drüber nachgedacht, war das so, war immer alles Next Generation. Und die haben sich überlegt, dass einfach der Adressraum zu kurz ist oder zu wenig oder zu klein ist oder zu schlecht verteilt. Dazu muss man mal kurz mal einen Abriss machen, was man überhaupt damit meint. Hauptaufgabe von IP ist ja, Datenpakete von A nach B zu transportieren. Und zwar relativ simpel. Man kann sich das vorstellen wie ein Postkartendienst. Ungefähr so von dieser Qualität ist auch IP. Also man kann eine Postkarte abschicken oder auch nicht. Und jemand kann sie transportieren oder auch nicht. Er kann sie dabei kaputt machen, verlieren. Wenn man mehrere Postkarten schickt, kann er die Reihenfolge vertauschen oder er kann auch mal eine verdoppeln. Das ist jetzt im realen Leben mir noch nicht passiert, dass jemand von der Post meine Karte kopiert hätte und dann zwei ankäme. Aber so was kann halt vorkommen, Datennetzen. Also eine relativ simple Mechanik, die IP dort bietet. Nämlich einfach nur, du gibst mir unten ein Stückchen Daten, so ein Paket und ich versuche die nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen auszuliefern. Damit es so weit klappt, braucht man Adressen. Man braucht auf jeden Fall erstmal eine Zieladresse. Da muss man bei einer Postkarte auch was draufschreiben, sonst kommt die nicht an. Bei einer Postkarte ist der Absender optional, bei IP nicht, unter anderem auch deswegen, weil man will ja in einen Dialog treten. Von daher ist es gut, wenn der angesprochen auch eine Chance hat zu antworten. Also braucht man auch eine Adresse, die man selber hat, wenn man jemanden anspricht. Wenn A und B miteinander kommunizieren wollen über IP, brauchen sie Adressen. Das Ganze natürlich nicht so, wie wir das kennen auf einer Postkarte mit Straße, Hausnummer, Postleitzahlort, Land, sondern maschinenlesbar. Dazu hat man sich überlegt bei IPv4, wir nehmen einfach mal ein paar Zahlen und einen Adressraum, den damals, als man sich v4 erdacht hat in den 60er Jahren, Ende der 60er Jahre und in den 70er, wo man sagt, oh der ist so groß, damit kommen wir ewig hin. Nämlich 32 Bit. Man hat 32 Bit pro Adresse, also sowohl für den Absender als auch für den Empfänger. Und jeder schreibt sozusagen seine Adresse immer auf dem Paket drauf als Absender und die Zieladresse des Empfängers und schmeißt sie sozusagen in den großen Pool rein, in die große Wolke, wenn man das mal an die Wand malt. Und irgendwelche Router, die sich da drin finden, bemühen sich nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen, das Ding anhand der Zieladresse irgendwo dahin zu routen, wo es hingehört und dann dort letztendlich auch an die Kasten zu schmeißen.
32 Bit, 4 Milliarden, das ist damals noch eine Zahl gewesen, die entsprach so in etwa der Weltbevölkerung. Und das, wo jeder mit einem eigenen Computer am Start sein könnte, war einfach nicht die Vorstellung davon.
Damals waren ja eh Computer irgendwie so hausfüllend. Und dass jemand mit so einem Ding in der Tasche rumrennt oder mit 2 oder 3 davon haben die nicht gesehen, war nicht so... Das ist genauso wie, weißte, Anfang der 90er, als die DOS-Leute irgendwie meinten, wie war das, 640 Kilobyte sind mehr, als jemals brauchbar?
Schon viel mehr, was Bill Gates in meinen Mund geschoben wird, obwohl das überhaupt nicht gelingt ist. Aber es ist so schön, dass jeder das glaubt.
Ja, aber es ist auch so eine dramatische Fehlereinschätzung gewesen. Es ist übrigens wichtig, dieser Rückblick darauf, dass sie sich damals verschätzt hat, wenn wir jetzt gleich drauf kommen, warum der Adressraum bei IPv6 so unglaublich groß ist. Der ist exzessiv groß. Gut, also das war, wie gesagt, haben sie sich damals gedacht, doch die 4 Milliarden anrassen, das passt schon, das geht schon. Das Problem ist allerdings dabei, dass, damit man das handhaben kann, muss diese Adressverteilung eine gewisse Struktur haben. Man könnte so ein Netz bauen, dass jeder Mensch seine eigene IPv4-Adresse kriegt, und zwar irgendwie. Dann musst du allerdings dir auch zu jeder Adresse einzeln merken, wo sie denn nun ist, um sie routen zu können. Das heißt, du hättest also nicht nur, dann hättest eben auch Routing-Tabellen mit 4 Milliarden Einträgen, weil du für jede Adresse einzeln wissen musst, wo sie ist.
Das ist eine Art Verzeichnungsdienst. Ich meine, man ist ja mit den Telefonnummern nicht der schlechteste Vergleich.
Auch die haben Struktur.
Ja, die haben Struktur. Trotzdem kann ich ja jetzt in zunehmendem Maße mit meiner Telefonnummer auch den Ort wechseln und auch meinen Anbieter wechseln. Es findet jetzt in zunehmendem Maße schon so ein Look-up statt, wo gesagt wird, was haben wir denn so für Informationen für genau diese eine Telefonnummer, wohin denn das jetzt gehen soll, während es halt früher Landvorwahl, Stadtvorwahl, sogar Ortsbereich... Also man konnte ja an der Telefonnummer in etwa den Stadtteil ausmachen, wo jemand mit seinem Telefonanschluss sagt.
Naja, aber selbst wenn du diesmal wechselst, in Deutschland kannst du nicht nach Hamburg ziehen und deine Berliner Nummer mitgehen. Das geht in der Schweiz. Da machen die so viele, die ich weiß. Ich hab sogar schon mal so eine Nummer gesehen, die irgendwie von Zürich nach Genf gezogen ist und immer noch die eins von hatte.
Aber das ist halt ja ein Modell, was jetzt für so ein Computernetzwerk nicht in Frage kommt, weil wenn man jetzt für jede Adresse erstmal nachschauen müsste, wo sie denn ist, dann wird es halt knifflig.
Damals nicht. Heute hätte man sicherlich auch die Möglichkeit, so was zu machen, aber man macht es trotzdem nicht. Also man braucht halt sehr viel Platz in einem solchen Adress- oder Nummernraum für Struktur. Wo wir gerade bei Telefonen sind, wir können ja mal einen kurzen Abstecher machen. Es gibt ja doch immer die religiösen Kriege zwischen den Leuten, die mit einem Fixed Numbering Plan daherkommen. Weil sie sagen, wir können dann den Nummernraum besser ausnutzen, wenn wir sagen, jede Nummer hier in diesem Land ist 8-stellig oder wie in den USA 10-stellig. Es beißt sie aber hinterher auch. Wir haben halt in Deutschland so einen flexiblen Rufnummernplan, dann gibt es halt lange und kurze Rufnummern. Und Vorwahlen und so weiter und so fort. Gibt es ja zum Beispiel in Ländern wie Norwegen, Dänemark gibt es keine Vorwahlen. Die haben halt einfach nur 8-stellige Rufnummern. But ist fertig. Das ist so ein bisschen so, wir stecken alle in einem Pool. Da war auch mal so eine Struktur drin, aber da kannst du inzwischen auch hin und her ziehen, wie du willst, und deine Rufnummer mitnehmen. Hier in Deutschland haben wir halt eben so ein bisschen noch Struktur. Wie du gerade sagst, es gibt die Ländervorwahl, dann gibt es eine Ortsvorwahl. Und dann kannst du innerhalb deines Ortes kannst du sozusagen geografisch deinen Anschluss wechseln. Aber du kannst nicht nach Hamburg ziehen und deine 030 mitnehmen. Das ist derzeit aus politischen Gründen nicht gewünscht. Technisch ginge das, aber aus politischen Gründen ist das nicht gewünscht. Wollen wir jetzt gar nicht so tief darauf einsteigen. Wichtig ist, dass man sagt, wenn man versucht, man hat einen gewissen Nummernraum, und den möchte man jetzt verteilen auf Leute, die auch geografisch verteilt sind, dass man einen Teil dieses Rufnummern oder dieses Nummernbaums eben dafür benutzen muss, um die Struktur herzustellen. Im Falle von IPv4 sind es halt eben auch, sagen wir mal, Bits. Man sieht die Adresse eigentlich nicht immer als komplette 32-Bit. Die meisten Leute sehen nicht die 32-Bit, sondern das ist immer nur der letzte Router sozusagen, dein DSL-Router zu Hause oder wer auch immer, der sich denn um alle 32-Bit kümmert. Der Rest des Internets schert sich eigentlich immer um sogenannte Präfixe. Das heißt, die gucken sich nur einen Teil dieser 32-Bits an. Die Vorwahl. Ja, genau, das ist ein guter Vergleich. Womit wir dann auch gleich bei einem Thema sind, Terminologie würde ich hier gerne mal vorwegschicken, weil das werde ich wohl häufiger sagen müssen, solche Worte wie slash 24, also was hat es damit auf sich? Bei V4 ist man hingegangen, hat sich gesagt, erst mal als es erfunden wurde, hat man schon gedacht, okay, wir müssen unterschiedlich große Bereiche haben, das heißt wir haben mal lange Vorwahlen mit kurzen Ortsrufnummern und wir haben kurze Vorwahlen mit langen Ortsrufnummern, wie es zum Beispiel in Deutschland auch ist. Vorwahl Berlin 3.0, sind nur zwei Stellen. Dahinter haben wir acht- und neunstellige Rufnummern. Wenn man halt in so einem kleinen Örtchen irgendwo im Brandenburgischen wohnt, zum Beispiel da, wo ich auch eine Hütte habe, das ist 33082, also eine fünfstellige Vorwahl, da haben wir eine fünfstellige Rufnummer in dem Ortsnetz. Ähnliches hat man auch bei V4 damals gemacht. Nämlich man hat sich erst mal überlegt, man fühlt mal so drei Klassen ein. Zum Beispiel die sogenannten Class-A-Netze, also welche mit einer kurzen Vorwahl und einer langen Rufnummer. Wenn man das jetzt mal im übertragenen Sinne sagen wollte, da hat man also von den 32 Bits gesagt, die ersten 8 Bits sind die Vorwahl und die letzten 24 Bits sind die Rufnummer. Dann gibt es die Class-B-Netze, da waren die ersten 16 Bits Vorwahl, die nächsten 16 Bits Rufnummer. Dann gibt es die Class-C-Netze, da waren die ersten 24 Bits Vorwahl und die letzten 8 Bits Rufnummer. Es gibt auch noch D-Netze und E-Netze. Das hat jetzt nichts mit den Funknetzen zu tun, sondern D ist Multicast und E ist nicht benutzt. Das ist Reserved. Kann man noch drauf kommen, wenn ich dich interessiere? Das sind diese unbenutzten Kombinationen. Jenseits aller IP-Adressen, die von 240 bis 254 vorne anfangen. Das ist ja ein nicht unerheblicher Teil des Rufnummernteils.
Das ist ein 3-Klassen-System. Da trifft der Name Klasse auch ganz gut. Entweder man hat 250 verschiedene Adressen zur Verfügung oder man hat gleich so eine Größenordnung von 32.000. Oder man hat dann eben gleich richtig so...
24, 16 Millionen irgendwann. Eine dieser Firmen, auch ein von uns sehr gerne genutzter Supplier, ist die Firma Apple, die sich damals auch schon, obwohl sie dann noch weit entfernt waren von dem ganzen IP, haben sie noch mit Apple Talk rumgespielt.
Die haben sich einfach mal so ein Class-A-Netz buchgespielt.
Die haben sich ein Class-A-Netz zuteilen lassen. Die haben gesagt, wir sind groß genug, wir sind geil genug, wir wollen gerne mal so ein Class-A-Netz. Aber IBM hat auch eins und so. Aber Apple hat die immer noch, alle IP-Adressen, die mit 17 anfangen. 17 sind Apple. Und die letzten 24 Bits kann Apple nach eigenem Gutdünken benutzen. Diese starre Aufteilung in ABC hat man festgestellt, ist halt auch irgendwie blöd, weil es gibt halt das kleinste Netz, was nach dieser Nomenklatur gibt, ist halt das C-Netz, wo man sozusagen 8 Bit hinten hat für seine Durchwahl oder so weiter. Das heißt, wenn man dir zugeteilt hat, hast du gleich 256 Adressen gehabt, auch wenn du so viel gar nicht brauchtest. Und wie gesagt, die Abstände zwischen diesen, was du gerade sagtest, entweder so 16 Millionen Adressen oder 65.000 Adressen oder 256 Adressen, das ist halt eben ein bisschen blöd. Das hat man schon in der Frühzeit des Internets erkannt. Und 1993 hat man auf einen Mechanismus und eine Terminologie umgestellt, die nennt sich CIDR, Classless Interterrain Routing, wo man also jetzt nicht mehr nach A, B, C deklariert hat, wo man die Grenze zieht zwischen Vorwahl und Rufnummer, sondern wo man an beliebige Stelle diesen zwischen 0 und 32 Bits sozusagen, diesen Schieber hinschieben kann. Daher kommt diese Nomenklatur, dass man sagt, ein Netz hat eine Größe von, sagen wir mal, slash 24. Das wäre sozusagen ein Netz mit einer 24-bittigen Vorwahl, um bei der Terminologie zu bleiben, und einer acht-bittigen Rufnummer. Das entspricht sozusagen dem, was früher ein Klassee war.
Also mit dem Schieber, mit dem Slider meinst du, man hat halt die 32-Bit-Adressen. Der vordere Teil ist halt das Netz. Der hintere Teil ist der spezifische Host in diesem Netz. Aber wie groß Netz und Host relativ zueinander sind, da schiebt man quasi einfach von links nach rechts den Bereich und sagt, okay, ich muss jetzt hier, ich brauche nur ein sehr kleines Netz. Das heißt, dass der Netzbereich viel Platz einnimmt, weil ich entsprechend wenig Host unterscheiden muss. Und dieses Slash Zahl sagt einfach aus, wie viele Bits von Anfang an gehören zum Netz. Und der Rest ist dann eben Host.
Genau. Also zum Beispiel, was gerne verteilt wird, wenn man bei einem ISP ist und man ist da Geschäftskunde und möchte gerne feste IP-Adressen haben oder mehrere, was die gerne zuteilen, sind dann zum Beispiel Slash-28-Netz. Kann man jetzt mal schnell nachrechnen. Ich meine, ich mache das seit ein paar Jahren. Da bleiben halt vier Bits übrig für die Durchwahl, wenn du so willst, oder für die Rufnummer. Das heißt, du hast halt 16 IP-Adressen. Den kannst du dich amüsieren als Kunde oder auch mal in Slash29. Dann hast du halt eben nur acht IP-Adressen in der Durchwahl. Es ist genauso, wie wenn man jetzt ein Telefonnummer beantragt, eine durchfallfähige Rufnummer, den möchte die Telekom oder wer auch immer der Anbieter ist, dann auch gerne wissen, wie viel Stellen Durchwahl du da gerne haben möchtest.
Genau, wenn du eine kleine Bude bist, dann kommst du mit zwei locker hin. Nicht sogar nur mit einer. Aber bist du halt jetzt eine große Versicherung mit Tra-la-la und Support und Kundenhotline und Pipapo, dann hast du vielleicht auch mal fünf oder sechs.
Genau. Das wollte ich nur mal erwähnen. Diese Terminologie ist sehr wichtig, weil die brauchen wir, wenn wir uns über V6 unterhalten, auch noch häufiger. Es wird immer noch gerne gesagt, es gibt immer noch Leute, die gerne sagen, ich hab hier ein Klasse-C-Netz oder sowas. Es ist gut zu wissen, dass es ein Slash-24 ist und ein Klasse-B-Netz ist ein Slash-16 und ein Klasse-A-Netz ist ein Slash-8. Aber ich würde da gerne von Abstand nehmen. Das zeigt eben auch schon so ein bisschen das Problem. Man hat es hinterher draufgestrickt. Die ursprünglichen Erfinder von V4 haben sich gedacht, wir strukturieren das Netz so, dass es ganz große, mittlere und kleinere Netze gibt. Und an Kleinstnetze oder an Netze, die vielleicht auch größer sind, als die großen, haben die nicht gedacht.
Vor allem, was man noch erwähnen sollte, ist, diese Klasse-ABC-Terminologie ergab sich quasi aus der Zahl selbst, weil einfach feste Zahlenbereiche reserviert waren.
Ja, stimmt.
Das heißt, einem Klasse-A-Netz hat man angesehen, dass es ein Klasse-A-Netz ist, weil einfach vorne die erste Zahl von dieser typischen Punkt-Punkt-Punkt-Notation hingeschriebenen Adresse eben in einem bestimmten Bereich war.
Zwischen 1 und 126.
Genau, 1 bis 126, dann ist es eben Klasse-A. Wo man es auch schon sieht, die Appa-Klasse, da gibt es halt genau 126 von. Ein paar sind da noch reserviert, die 10 und Pipapo und so. Es gibt einfach im Prinzip so 100, die dürfen halt einen dicken machen. Apple ist dabei, IBM ist dabei, so alle großen Firmen der damaligen Zeit, die noch existieren, haben sowas, weil das hat man mal so mitgenommen und damals hat noch keiner drüber nachgedacht. So große Firma und so weiter passt schon. So, und dann Klasse B ist dann halt ein anderer Bereich und C ist ein anderer Bereich. Wobei dieses CIDA, sagt man CIDA?
Ja, auch Citra oder so.
CIDA ist ja quasi so eine Interpretation der Zahl, die in dieser Zahl selber nicht drin steht. Das heißt, hier braucht man eben diese Information noch zusätzlich.
Richtig. Ja, also seit CIDA muss man sozusagen immer, wenn man von einem Netz redet, nicht nur die eigentlich die Vorwahl erwähnen, sondern muss auch dazu sagen, wie groß das Netz ist. Daher eben so Nomenklaturen wie 192, 42, 23.0, slash 24 oder so.
Die Netzmaske.
Die Netzmaske... Also diese Netzmaske bei V4 hat ein interessantes Leben hinter sich. Es gab nämlich Leute, die sich gedacht haben, ach, pff, warum soll eigentlich die Vorwahl immer, ich sag jetzt immer Vorwahl, ich find das schönes Bild, warum soll eigentlich die Vorwahl immer links stehen? Die Vorwahl könnte ja auch einfach in der Mitte der Rufnummer stehen. Und in der Tat, ich hab sowas gesehen. Ich hab echt Leute gesehen, die hatten eine Netzmaske, die war halt nicht nur alles Einzen auf der einen Seite, Nullen auf der anderen, also sozusagen schon links und rechts.
Also du kannst erwähnen, was die Netzmaske ist.
Ja, die Netzmaske ist sozusagen, ist eine Repräsentation dieser Trennung zwischen Vorwahl und Rufnummer oder zwischen Netz und Host.
In Bits gegossen.
In Bits gegossen. Früher hat man das gerne eingegeben, dass man sozusagen, man hatte eine IP-Adresse, ich sag jetzt nochmal, eine 192.42.23.1 oder sowas. Und dann hat man immer beim Konfigurieren irgendwie noch eine Subnetzmaske mit angeben müssen, die meistens aussah, so wie 255.255.255.0 zum Beispiel.
In dem Fall halt ein Class-C-Netz, weil eben die ersten drei Bits sind eben Netz und das letzte ist eben Host.
Die ersten 24 Bits sind 1 sozusagen, dieser Subnetzmaske auf 1 gesetzt. Und die letzten 8 Bits waren halt Host. Und ich hab wirklich mal Leute gesehen, die haben 255.255.0.255 konfiguriert. Das heißt sozusagen, wo die Vorwahl vorne und hinten war und in der Mitte drin war sozusagen, denn die Hostadresse, keine Ahnung, was das sollte. Hat man aber festgestellt, dass das sozusagen wenig zukunftsträchtig ist und dass diese Schreiberei. Mit diesen langen 255 Punkten ein bisschen nervig ist. Ab dem wievielten Bit fange ich jetzt an, von Vorwahl auf Rufnummer umzuschalten oder von Netz auf Host. Das macht eben diese Slash-Notation, Slash und dahinter eine Zahl. Die kann halt im V4-Bereich von 0 bis 32 gehen.
Aber auch hier, das ist halt eine Information, diese Netzmaske oder eben dieses, wie nennt man denn dieses Slash 24, diesen Bezeichner?
Eine Prefix-Länge.
Okay, die Prefix-Länge oder auch die Netzmaske, was auch immer, ist sozusagen eine separate Information, die nicht in dem Paket steht. Das heißt, man kann jede Paketadresse eigentlich beliebig interpretieren und tatsächlich wird sie an verschiedenen Stellen auch immer anders interpretiert, weil wenn ich hinter einem bestimmten Checkpoint nochmal mehrere Unternetze unterscheiden will, dann ändert sich eben diese Sichtweise darauf, ohne dass sich die Adresse selbst ändert.
Genau. Und so kommen wir jetzt wieder zum Thema Struktur zurück und Vorwahl. Du hast ja vorhin so schön gesagt, Telefonnummer hat eben auch eine Landesvorwahl. Das mit den Ländern hat man sich nicht gegeben, aber was man schon gemacht hat, ist, man hat das Internet schon nach Regionen aufgeteilt. Du kannst zum Beispiel eine IP-Adresse, die mit 193 anfängt, mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit eine europäische Adresse. 193, 194 zum Beispiel. Das liegt daran, dass man Mitte der 90er Jahre hat man angefangen, diese ganze Adress-Vergabe-Infrastruktur, also diese Hierarchie, nach der in Adressen verteilt werden, so ein bisschen zu globalisieren. Es gab nicht mehr nur diesen einen Zentralpunkt, der IP-Adressen vergeben hat, sondern man hat halt regional Dinge gemacht. Aber der erste war auch mit RIP., also die... Oh, jetzt mein französisch. Résor-IP-Europe, oder irgendwie sowas. Also irgendwelche Leute, die sich... Résor-IP-Europe.
Europäen.
Also europäisches Netz.
Europäisches IP-Netz. Die europäischen IP-Netze.
Résor ist gut. Das Sitz in Amsterdam, sehr coole Organisation. Damals auch mitgegründet worden von einem Freund von mir, von Daniel Karrenberg, der damals von der Uni Dortmund kommend gedacht hat, jetzt bringen wir hier auch mal ein bisschen Struktur da rein. Die verteilen seit, keine Ahnung, 93, 94, seit wann die gibt, verteilen die halt eben IP-Adressen an europäische Nutzer. Und das heißt, denen ist jetzt erstmal sozusagen ein Unterbereich des gesamten IP-Adressraums delegiert worden von den damaligen Besitzern, die das sozusagen in der Hand hatten. Die haben gesagt, hier ihr Europäer, hier hast du mal 193, 194, ich glaube 195, 96 auch oder so. Und noch so ein paar andere Adressbereiche und mach mal.
Verteilt ihr das mal, ihr kennt euch ja da eh besser aus.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt eine ganz simple Welt Sicht hätte, ich bin jetzt ein ISP, der irgendwo in New York sitzt und ich hab halt zwei, drei Arme in alle mögliche Richtungen. Ich hab halt einen Arm, der irgendwie nach Osten rübergeht, Richtung Europa, kann ich dort in dem Router einfach sagen, alles, was mit 193 anfängt, bitte über diese Strippe, passt schon irgendwie. So einfach ist die Welt nicht, weil du hast natürlich tausend Arme und so, aber in der Denke war das damals so, dass man den Adressraum ein bisschen strukturiert, dass sich sozusagen ein US-amerikanischer Router gar keine Gedanken darüber machen muss, wie der Rest aussieht hinter der 193. Er weiß einfach, 193 gehört übern Teich, und zwar Richtung Osten. Ja, schön.
So wie die Ländervorwahlen quasi.
So wie die Ländervorwahlen, genau. Europäische Rufnummer ist ja auch das selbe Prinzip. Europäische Rufnummern fangen Ländervorwahlen mit drei und mit vier an. Fertig.
Punkt.
Und sind danach verschieden lang. Auch wieder wie im IP. Aber ist das selbe Prinzip. Und so hat man sich damals gedacht, dass wir sagen, okay, wir strukturieren den Rufnummerraum so ein bisschen oder den Adressraum, um ihn besser handhaben zu können. Das war die Idee dabei. Dass sich in der Zwischenzeit Millionen von nationalen, internationalen, globalen ISPs bilden, die sich alle kreuz und quer vernetzen, sodass man am Ende des Tages trotzdem eine Monster-Routing-Tabelle hat. Okay, aber the intention was good. Also es gibt eine Hierarchie bei der Adressvergabe, womit wir jetzt wieder bei dieser Notation sind. Also ein Router in New York, unser gedachter Simple-Router, der kann halt sagen 193 slash 8. Das ist alles, was mich interessiert. Die restlichen 24 bits jucken mich gar nicht. Hau ich über den Teich fertig.
Das ist ja auch im Prinzip so eine der Kernideen eigentlich im Internet, also in der Idee, wie Routing und Adressen eben funktionieren. Dass man eben diese Entscheidung, wohin schicke ich es denn jetzt, auf möglichst wenig Informationen basieren muss. Dass man nicht ein riesiges Verzeichnis vorhalten muss und das dann eben potentiell auch an tausenden Stellen. Dass man im Idealfall sich nur die Adresse anschaut und von daher schon mal...
Und nur die Vorwahl der Adresse?
Genau, nur die Vorwahl der Adresse oder auch nur ein Teil davon. Und dann schon mal weiß, wer sich dann darum kümmert. Und dass eben diese spezifische Information darüber, wo es denn jetzt wirklich genau hin muss und welches Kabel in welchem Raum, in welcher Straße, in welchem Ort möglichst weit hinten liegt. Dass möglichst viele Router bis dahin einfach immer nur sagen, ah ja, hier andere Richtungen. Das hat man ja hier in Deutschland selten, aber in anderen Ländern muss ich immer wieder schmunzeln. In Holland hat es, glaube ich, häufiger Spanien, dass du so Straßenschilder hast mit nicht hier geht es da lang, hier geht es da lang, hier geht es da lang. In Deutschland hat man gerne so 30 Schilder, die irgendwo hin zeigen. In anderen Ländern hast du häufiger mal so ein Schild andere Richtungen oder alle Richtungen. So die default-Route sozusagen. Du bist jetzt hier so am Flughafen, du willst irgendwo hin, ist mir egal wohin, fahr erst mal da lang.
Hier ist Cargo, hier ist Cargo, da ist Abflug und alles andere da lang. Das ist die default-Route, stimmt, hast du recht. Okay, wie sagt dieses Schema, wenn man mal jetzt die Augen aufmacht, siehst du, überall ist auch dasselbe mit Postleitzahlen. Nicht nur in Deutschland, aber gerade auch in Deutschland. Die ersten zwei Ziffern sagen, die Antwort ist, 10 bis 14 ist Berlin. Die restlichen drei Ziffern interessieren dich erst, wenn du Zusteller in Berlin bist, wenn du wissen willst, wo du jetzt noch hinfährst in welchem Stadtbezirk. Das ist halt das selbe Prinzip, was dahinter steckt. Ja, man hat diese Adressen aufgeteilt. Aufgrund dieser ganzen administrativen Geschichten und hin und her, da brauchen wir noch eine Adresse mehr, da weniger, da haben wir nur ein Bit übrig, wurde es eben auch ein bisschen enger. Das heißt, man verschwendet auch sehr viele Bits bei IPv4. Ein gutes Beispiel zu nennen ist, wenn dir jetzt ein Provider oder wer immer, ein Slash 28 gibt, wo 16 IP-Adressen sind und du legst die auf ein Ethernet bei dir zuhause in deinem Router, äh, doch ein Slash 28, ja, mit 16 Adressen, dann kannst du effektiv davon nur 14 benutzen, weil aufgrund von archaischen Begebenheiten kannst du die erste und die letzte Adresse nicht benutzen. Die erste Adresse ist sozusagen ein, ist nur ein Synonym für das ganze Netz, sozusagen wo man, äh, da kann man keinen Host drauflegen, sozusagen die nuller Adresse, wenn man so sagen will. Und die letzte Adresse ist, ähm, die Boardcaster-Adresse.
Die, wo alle antworten.
Die, wo alle antworten. Ähm, wo man sozusagen keinen einzelnen Host mehr ansprechen kann. Und das wird natürlich nach hinten hin, wird das enger, ne, also zum Beispiel das kleinste Netz, was man überhaupt noch irgendwie, ähm, bauen kann auf dem Ethernet, ist ein Slash 30. Da sind vier Adressen, die da drin sind. Erst und letzte fallen weg, bleiben zwei IP-Adressen übrig. Ein Netz mit nur einem Teilnehmer macht keinen Sinn, ist nämlich kein Netz, aber es ist das kleinste Netz, was du da haben kannst. Das heißt, du verschwindest eigentlich schon wieder ein Bit. Theoretisch würden ja, wenn man zwei Hosts haben will, würde auch ein Slash 31 reichen. Aber sowas kannst du jedenfalls nicht auf dem Ethernet bauen. Slash 31 kann man bauen, dort wo es keine Broadcast-Adressen gibt. Aber es ist immer himmlisch, es ist immer wischiwaschi.
Das ist schonmal so ein 50%-Verlust bei dem 16a. Es ist immerhin noch zwei von 16, die verschwinden etc.
Also das sind halt so diese Flaws, die auch das Design von V4 mit sich bringt.
Aber ich denke, die größeren Verluste entstehen überhaupt schon bei diesen Großverteilungsmaßnahmen, weil dann wird dann halt ein riesiger Adressbereich. Ich meine, Apple wird jetzt von seinen 24 Millionen Adressen sicherlich auch nur einen Bruchteil verwenden.
Klar.
IBM auch.
US Military auch. Und wer auch immer da noch drinsteckt. Übrigens, wenn das interessiert, es gibt immer noch offizielle Listen für sowas. Da gibt es immer noch FTP-Server, wo man sich darunter laden kann, wo dann drin steht so 17 Adress Assignments, 17 Apple, Inc. Und so Apple Computers, Inc. Da kann man sich mal angucken, wer da noch auf den dicken Dingern sitzt. Muss mal gucken. Aaron, Aaron Raib auch. Es gibt so eine traditionelle Infrastruktur, wie man so früher Internet gemacht hat, auch von Zeiten vor DNS, wo es sozusagen so eine Riesen-Host-Datei gab oder sowas. Sowas ähnlich gibt es immer noch, die von irgendwelchen Leuten bei irgendwelchen US-Organisationen noch gepflegt werden. Und die haben auch immer noch einen FTP-Server. Internet hieß es ja damals. Es gibt glaube ich immer noch FTP, Internetnet. Und da kann man mal so ein bisschen drum rum stochern, was da so rumliegt.
Genau.
Wir kommen jetzt ein bisschen ab vom Thema.
Naja, wir nähern uns. Die zu beantwortende Frage, die noch so im Raum steht, ist ja so dieses, warum IPv6? Und jetzt haben wir viel über Adressen geredet, über das Wesen von Adressen und dass die schlecht genutzt werden. Deswegen stehen auch nicht wirklich netto 4 Milliarden zur Verfügung. Gibt es überhaupt eine Schätzung, wie viele Adressen derzeit und auch potenziell im V4-Raum wirklich für angeschlossene Endgeräte zum Einsatz kommen oder zum Einsatz kommen könnten? Also was sozusagen die reale, potenzielle Zahl von verwendbaren Adressen ist, die wirklich zum Einsatz kommen?
Ja, man kann ja mal rechnen. Es gibt eine Menge Leute, die da in den letzten Jahren schon mal nur nachgerechnet haben, aber nur mal, um die immer aufzuzählen. Wir haben ja vorhin gesagt, es gibt diese Class-E-Netze, die reservt sind. Die hat man überlegt, ob man die reaktiviert, hat aber festgestellt, dass es inzwischen 2 Millionen und 5 kaputte IP-Stacks gibt von Crete und Pleti und Microsoft und was weiß ich wem, die alle darauf eingestellt sind, die würden einfach explodieren, die sind nicht darauf eingestellt, dass es so was gibt. Die jetzt alle wieder aus dem Keller zu holen und zu fixen, haben sich gesagt, okay, das brauchen wir nicht. Das macht ein Sechzehntel des Adressraums aus. Dann die ganzen Multicast-Adressen, die werden zwar benutzt, aber nicht im Internet, sondern Multicast wird im V4-Weich eigentlich fast ausschließlich nur lokal in den eigenen Netzen benutzt. Das ist nochmal ein Sechzehntel des Adressraums. Dann kannst du nicht benutzen alle Adressen, die anfangen mit 0 oder mit 127 oder 10. Okay, das sind jetzt vergebene, aber die sind nicht routbar. Dann gibt es noch andere nicht routbare Adressen. 172.16.12 und 10.8, hattest du erwähnt, 192.68.16, 169.254.16 und so weiter. Also es gibt so diverse Löcher da drin.
Reservierte Bereiche für lokale Nutzung. 10 ist ja nie so richtig reserviert gewesen.
10 gehört auch zu dem sogenannten Rf 10, 19, 18 Spektrum. Das sind drei Bereiche, 10.8, 172.16.12 und 192.68.16. Die werden nicht im Internet geroutet, explizit nicht. Die darf es im Internet nicht geben. Deswegen kann man sie zu Hause benutzen ohne einen Adresskonflikt darauf zu beschwören. Für lokale Netze.
Das was der Plasterauter ausspuckt als lokale Adresse.
Es gibt immer Kollateralschäden, wo wir gerade dabei sind. Ich habe eben gesagt 192.168.16. Alle Adressen, die mit 192.168 anfangen, fallen in diese Kategorie. Nun gibt es aber Leute, die sind zu dämlich, selbst diese sechs Ziffern mit ihrem Punkt dazwischen richtig einzutippen. Ich weiß das, weil mir gehört der Adressraum 192.68.0 bis 15 oder so. Und die kann ich faktisch nicht benutzen. Weil in dem Moment, wo ich anfange, die zu ruten kriege, so viel Schwachsinnstreffik aus aller Welt rein, wo irgendwelche Leute zu blöde sind, 192.168 einzutippen und stattdessen 192.68, ein Tipp, das trommelt alles bei mir rein.
Verstehe.
Ja, die sind sozusagen auch, das ist einfach Kollateralschaden.
War ja.
Und naja, also das fällt da ein bisschen was weg. Außerdem gibt es halt eben, bevor sozusagen dieses Regime gegriffen hat mit diesen Regional Internet Registries, die RIRs, wie zum Beispiel RIPE, kann ja der Vollständigkeit halber die nochmal alle erwähnen. Es gibt halt RIPE in Europa, die Adressen verteilen. In Nordamerika ist das ARIN. In Südamerika LACNIC, L-A-C-N-I-C. Dann gibt es noch die in Asien, das ist ABNIC, Asia Pacific, die was verteilen und momentan spaltet sich so ein bisschen ab oder ist da noch dabei oder ist schon am Start, weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau, nach AFRINIC, die eigentlich Afrika verteilen sollen. Bisher war so reibdeckt also nicht nur Kontinentaleuropa ab und britische Inseln, sondern auch so ein bisschen Middle East und westliches Asien und ein bisschen Afrika und so und so. Und da teilt sich gerade so ein bisschen, da ist irgendwie AFRINIC ist da schon am Start, weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie weit die schon sind damit. Das sind so die regionalen Verteilstellen für so Zeugs, die sich da amüsieren mit. Es gab aber wie gesagt schon Adressvergabe aus der Zeit davor. Ich hab wie gesagt auch was davon abbekommen und viele andere Leute auch. Und da ist auch teilweise sehr viel ungenutzt. Ich hab jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen nochmal eine Statistik gelesen, wo Leute sagen, dass ungefähr 30% des möglichen oder nutzbaren Adressraums derzeit nicht genutzt wird. Man sieht ihn nicht in den Routing-Tabellen. Er müsste in den Routing-Tabellen auftauchen, wenn er genutzt würde. Er taucht aber in den Routing-Tabellen nicht auf.
Und wie groß, also was heißt das? Und wie viel Prozent macht jetzt das nicht Nutzbare aus? Auch 30%? Ist dieser ganze Klassee, Broadcast, tralala?
Ein Achtel fehlt ja schon mal durch D- und E-Netze. Ein Achtel sind ja auch schon mal 12, 12,5%.
Aber es ist ja schon noch komplexer. Die Null und alles Eins darf nicht verwendet werden. Also jedes herausgegebene Netz hat ja auch immer wieder ausgeblendete Adressen. Also dadurch ist ja schon eine sehr komplexe Rechnung. Deswegen frag dich gerade, ob es irgendeine Erkenntnis darüber gibt, wie groß der real tote Raum ist. Sind das so etwas wie 30% aller Nummern?
Der technisch tote Raum, weiß ich nicht, das bestimmt irgendwie bei knapp unter 20% oder 20%, müsste ich jetzt schätzen. Und wie gesagt, dann wären von dem anderen, von dem, der technisch jetzt ruhtbar wäre, aber nicht geroutet würde, sind wir ungefähr auch bei 30%. Also eigentlich könnte man sagen, dass sozusagen von diesen 32, von diesen 4 Milliarden Adressendiensten jetzt diese 32 Bits geben, sind irgendwie, wie Pima, Dom, so die Hälfte, werden irgendwie nicht genutzt oder können nicht genutzt werden.
Das heißt, da wäre, ist da schon auch ein bisschen Vergabehub. Also schon jetzt, dass die Neuen hinzustoßen, theoretisch auch die Chance hätten, noch Adressen zu kriegen?
Ja, das Problem ist nur, dass die, dass die RIRs, also diese Regional Internet Registries, die ich vorhin erwähnt habe, die haben jetzt alle ihre Zuteilung gekriegt. Also der gesamte Adressraum, der überhaupt zur Verfügung stand, ist irgendwie auf diese RIRs verteilt. Und die haben jetzt gerade feierlich sozusagen, oder feierlich oder mit großem Entsetzen vieler Leute, haben die jetzt alle so gesagt, so wir brechen jetzt unser letztes Slash-8 an. So, und ist das was zu haben. Und jetzt müssen die, fangen die natürlich Strategien um alte Adressen oder was weiß ich zum Beispiel, wenn so ein ASP-Pleite geht, ist eine wahnsinnige aufwändige Geschichte, deren Adressraum wieder einzusammeln. Weil was einmal zugeteilt ist, ist zugeteilt. Und wenn du keinen mehr da hast, der mit dir redet und der Insolvenzverwalter hinter sich auch schon die Tür zugemacht hat, mit wem redest du denn da noch, um denen die Adressen wieder wegzunehmen. Und also Zeugs, also das ist ein sehr schwerwiegendes Thema. Und das ist auch eine Geschichte. Die Rirrs sperren sich auch so ein bisschen dagegen, weil die sagen, wir müssen jetzt hier wahnsinnig strampeln, um nochmal wieder Adressen zusammen zu kratzen. Wir haben euch seit Jahren gesagt, das kommt. Hier hast du IPv6-Adressraum. Das ist zum Beispiel so reib, vergib dir jetzt nur noch V4-Adressen, wenn du eine V6-Allocation hast. Also wenn du sozusagen sagst, ja, ich mache jetzt V6, ich ehre schwöre, ich mache das demnächst, gib mir mal Adressen dafür. Aber ich hab jetzt noch ein paar Applikationen, da brauch ich unbedingt noch V4 für. Und dann geben sie so kleine Häppchen, geben nur noch slash 24 raus oder nie slash 22. Also das sind 1000 Adressen, 1024 Adressen. Das ist sozusagen den Happen, den sie raustun. Und den kriegst du wie gesagt auch nur dann, wenn du dich schon ernsthaft mit V6 befasst. Weil sie einfach sagen, wir haben keinen Bock mehr, uns hier die einzelnen Dinger da zusammenzukratzen und die wieder einzusammeln und zu machen und zu tun. Das ist ein wahnsinniger Aufwand. Die Verwaltung auch dafür, mach bitte das Neue. Hier hast du Adressen, bis der Arzt kommt, mach, go. Also das ist halt schon das Thema. Die, naja, okay, wie gesagt, wir sind jetzt schon mitten in dem Thema Adressknappheit, ne? Das ist halt, Internet ist halt, weltweit hat einen Boom erlebt. Müssen wir jetzt hier nicht erzählen. Wir benutzen es ja. Also dem geneigten Hörer muss man nicht erklären, wofür Internet gut ist. Und man ist ohnehin schon dabei. Das ist übrigens auch ein wichtiger Unterschied. Man hat sich in der V4-Welt so ein bisschen damit abgefunden, dass man eine Adresse bekommt als Kunde. Du hast halt hier dein lokales Netz. War vor ein paar Jahren auch noch nicht denkbar, dass jeder einen Router zu Hause hat, sondern dann war man direkt mit seinem PC oder mit seinem Modem drin. Dann passt ja auch eine Adresse. Heute hat man das Ich-Kühlschränke-Fernseher mit IP. Und es gibt iPhones sowieso, iPads, Lala, Pipapo. Das heißt, du hast jetzt schon einen ganzen Zoo an Geräten zu Hause, die alle eine Adresse brauchen. Und diese Menge könnte man ohnehin mit dem bestehenden V4-Adressraum selbst, wenn man den komplett ausnutzt, überhaupt gar nicht abdecken. Das sind eh schon viel zu viele. Und deswegen benutzt man dort einen Mechanismus, der wirklich ein Krebsgeschwür, eine Pest ist, in vielerlei Hinsicht, nämlich das sogenannte Nothing. Eine Network-Adress-Translation. Das heißt, man benutzt innerhalb seines eigenen Netzes zu Hause andere Adressen als die, die die Welt von einem sieht. Sozusagen andere Durchwahlen. Man betreibt eine Telefonanlage mit geheimen Durchwahlen. Und das Einzige, was man von außen sieht, ist eine Zentralnummer, eine Null oder so. Ungefähr kann man sich das vorstellen. Und jedes Mal, wenn jemand rausruft aus dem Internen Netz, sieht man nicht seine Durchwahl, sondern man sieht sozusagen die äußere Nummer, man sieht sozusagen die Null. Dahingehend wird einem von seinem ISP immer nur eine Adresse zugeteilt. Ja, eine. Und wenn du dahinter jetzt deine Rechner und Kühlschränke und Fernseher und was nicht alles betreibst, das kann sein 40, 50 Dinger, wie auch immer, dann sind die von außen aus Sicht des Internets nur unter einer Durchwahl zu erreichen. Das hat natürlich jetzt nicht unter einer Durchwahl, sondern eine Rufnummer. Das heißt, die müssen auch alle, um in diesem Bild zu bleiben, wenn jemand von draußen was will, müssen die alle beide Zentrale anrufen. Die müssen alle auf diese eine Adresse drauf. Und dann muss irgendjemand da sitzen, der entscheidet, ach, dieses Paket, ach, das war für den Fernseher und dieses Paket gehört jetzt dem iPhone. Das ist Fräulein vom Amt. Und die muss halt, die muss erstmal das Gespräch annehmen, die muss erstmal nachgucken, die muss rein schauen. Die kann nicht einfach wie ein Postbote von draußen auf den Umschlag draufgucken und sagen, aha, die Adresse iPhone, die Adresse Fernseher, sondern die haben alle die selbe Adresse. Das heißt, jemand muss erstmal den Umschlag aufmachen, drauf schauen, was ist denn das? Ach, das sieht ja so aus wie die Weiterverfolgung einer Konversation, die das iPhone mal angestoßen hat. Also wird wohl das eine Antwort sein, also gebe ich es mal dem iPhone oder so. Ein bisschen kann man mal ansehen. Es ist ein Wunder, dass das überhaupt funktioniert. Es ist auch wirklich die Pest, weil so ein Gerät, so ein IP-Gerät innerhalb eines solch aufgebauten V4-Netzes glaubt ja, es hat ja selber eine Adresse und glaubt ja, dass das auch die Adresse ist, die man nach draußen sieht, schickt also seine IP-Pakete so weg. Dass da am Rand dieses Netzes jetzt irgendeinen Router setzt, der einfach die von dem Gerät draufgeschriebene IP-Adresse in dem Paket durchstreicht und sie durch ein andere übermalt, weiß das Gerät ja nicht. Deswegen gibt es auch zum Beispiel diverse Protokolle, die damit wahnsinnig toll auf die Nase fallen. Nämlich Protokolle, wo sich innerhalb des Protokolls über die Adressen unterhalten wird.
Bei SIPT nicht sogar so?
Bei SIPT ist aber der Klassiker ist FTP. FTP ist das File Transfer Protokoll. Ist so ein Ding, wo man erstmal eine Verbindung aufmacht mit seinem Zielserver. Über den man so ein bisschen einen Dialog führt, was man so machen will. Aber in dem Moment, wo wirklich Daten transferiert werden sollen, dann sagt man so, ach ruf mich doch mal zurück. Mach doch mal eine zweite Verbindung auf, wo du die Daten übermittelst. Meine Rufnummer ist ja 10.1.2.3. Und das geht aber nicht, weil das ist gar nicht deine Rufnummer. Weil inzwischen jemand, wie gesagt, das Vorlein von einem Amt oder wie auch immer, hat halt schon deine ganzen Rufnummer geändert nach außen hin. Und ZIP, IP-Telefonie, große Problem. Macht das genauso. Du registrierst dich halt bei so einem ZIP-Server und sagst, hallo, ich bin der und der, mit dem username, password, das ist meine Rufnummer. Wenn da ein Anruf für mich kommt, ruf mich doch mal zurück unter 10.1.2.3. Und der hat halt keine Chance, dich zu vernünftig zu adressieren. Da muss man halt diese ganzen Protokolle alle entweder umbauen. Bei FDP hat man so genannten Passive Mode gemacht.
Als ob jemand wirklich eine Zentrale anruft mit so Ja, hallo, was wolltest du von mir? Du hast mich doch gerade angerufen. Ja, Zentrale, keine Ahnung. Sie haben mich doch angerufen.
Ja, genau.
Niemand weiß, wer zuständig ist.
Man hat also die ganzen Dinger aufgebaut. Nothing ist, wie gesagt, auch deswegen. Also wenn man sozusagen Adressen umlügt, ist das immer ein schwerwiegende Thema. Da könnten wir alleine eine Sendung drüber machen. Wird da alles für Mord und Totschlag beipassiert. Also Nutt ist eine große Pest. So, aber nochmal, jeder User kriegt sozusagen eine, wenn du dich mit deinem iPhone nochmal per Mobilfunk bei deinem Provider-Inlogs kriegst du auch da wieder nur eine IP-Adresse. Die haben auch schon zu wenig. Also in Deutschland kriegst du, ich kenne keinen Mobilprovider in Deutschland, der dir eine echte, richtige globale IP-Adresse gibt. Die geben dir alle so eine private, so eine 10er-IP-Adresse, die wir vorhin erwähnten, eine RFC-1918-Adresse, und lügen die auch wieder um. Das heißt, wenn du mit deinem iPhone irgendwo hin connectest, siehst du eine IP-Adresse, die aber gar nicht deine IP-Adresse ist. Jedenfalls nicht die, die dein iPhone hat, sondern jemand anderes lügt dir da die Adresse um.
Aber sowas soll dann zuverlässig, sowas wie Push-Notification funktionieren.
Ja, genau. Es hat sich inzwischen so ein bisschen, weil es einen Nebeneffekt hat, hat es auch einen kleinen Segen, sagen wir mal, oder hat einen kleinen positiven Effekt. Weil man kann dich halt eben auch nicht einfach von außen adressieren. Das heißt, diese ganzen Internetviren, Würmer, alles, was von draußen gegen deinen Router gegenhemmert. Da kann der Router immer nur sagen, ja, guten Tag, Herr Wohm, mit wem wollen Sie verbunden? Er kann das halt nicht einfach weiterreichen. Das ist halt etwas, die gerne möchten. Die möchten ja gerne direkt ihre IP-Pakete an die Devices schicken, zum Beispiel. An so einen offenen Port von so einem Windows-PC.
Die Herren aus Nigeria bleiben dann halt in der Zentrale hängen. Ja, ich hab hier ein Angebot für Sie. Nur 50.000 Euro für Sie sind für Sie bereit.
An wen soll ich sie durchstellen? Schade. Das ist sozusagen einer der wenigen positiven Dinge im Nebeneffekt davon. Aber zum Beispiel, du kannst in einem Mobilfunknetz in Deutschland durch diese Natterei, kannst du keinen, du könntest keinen Web-Server betreiben, der im UMTS hängt. Geht nicht. Weil du kriegst halt eine Adresse, die irgendwie umgenartet wird. Du kannst selber kein Portmapping definieren, was beim Provider denn aktiv ist, wo du dann sozusagen einen Dienst anbietest. Du kannst es immer nur aus dem Mobilfunknetz, du kannst es immer nur aktiv von drinnen nach draußen. Du kannst es nicht von draußen nach drinnen. Aber natürlich, wie gesagt, solche Sachen wie Push-Notification und was sieht nicht alle, dann ein erheblicher Schwert. Es gibt übrigens Provider in meinem Lieblingsreisland Schweden. Da benutze ich ja den Provider 3. Der gibt mir echte IP-Adressen zu, richtig echte, echte. Das ist die IP-Adresse, die mein iPhone sieht und hat auch die, die man im Internet sieht. IPv4. Die haben damals wahrscheinlich gut zugelangt, haben genug Adressraum für ihre 10 Millionen People, die sie da rumzuhüpfen haben oder keine Ahnung. Und die geben dir richtige IP-Adressen. So, zack. Also es geht, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es technisch nicht ginge, aber wie gesagt, wenn so ein Vodafone hingehen würde und jetzt mal anrufen beim Reib und sagen, wir haben jetzt hier so 30 Millionen Smartphone-User, habt da mal 30 Millionen IP-Adressen, dann gibt es ein kurzes Gelächter und das Gespräch wird einfach aufgehängt.
Das Land, in dem Milch und Honig und IP-Adressen fließen.
Genau. Ja, also, Summa summarum, Adressen sind knapp.
Also diese Adressknappheit ist auch real und sie ist eingetreten. Also wir reden hier nicht mehr von irgendeiner Zukunft, sondern die erste Stufe ist erreicht. Es kann gar nichts mehr in irgendeine Region hinein. Delegiert werden und auch die, die da delegieren, die sitzen jetzt sozusagen nur noch auf sperrlichen Pools.
Die setzt Leernuckeln.
Die gibt es Schätzungen, wie lange das noch so hält. Ich meine, das ist ja auch immer so ein bisschen kommen und gehen, aber wir haben ja schon gesagt, das Problem mit diesen ISPs, die dann irgendwie wegsterben und so. Also die verrotten auch so ein bisschen.
Na ja, es hält noch ein bisschen, weil sie haben ja Adressen vergeben an die ISPs, die jetzt erst mal neue Kunden werben müssen und so. Das findet auch eine gewisse Marktsättigung statt. Hier in Deutschland hat ja nun fast jeder einen DSL-Anschluss oder so. Fast jeder. Wir werden gerade, denke ich, in Deutschland, wenn die endlich mal aus dem Kniff kommen und mal auf dem Land noch ein bisschen was tun, werden wir noch ein paar Millionen davon verbratzen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viel sozusagen die ISPs selber noch an ihrer eigenen Reserve haben. Das einzige, was öffentlich bekannt gemacht wird, ist halt, was diese Riris eben sagen. Die sagen, okay, wir haben unsere Zuteilung von oben alle gekriegt, da kommt nichts mehr. Und wir haben jetzt das letzte so und so angeknackt. Das letzte Slash-8 haben wir jetzt angeknackt. Aus dem verteilen wir jetzt Adressen. Bald gibt es monatliche Statistiken, wo man sehen kann, wie viel sie davon schon rausgegeben haben. Aber wie viele davon jetzt wirklich ins Feld gelangen, kann man jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres sagen, weil die ISPs aus Geschäfts-, wie sagt man, Trade Secret, aus Geschäftsinteresse natürlich nicht öffentlich allen und vor allen Dingen ihren Konkurrenten sagen, wie viele Kunden sie jetzt wirklich am Start haben. Aber es kommt jedenfalls nichts mehr nach. Also wenn jetzt jemand nochmal mit einer tollen neuen Technologie kommt und nochmal so was wie ein iPhone erfindet oder ein ganz neues Funknetz oder sonst irgendwas, der kann einfach mit V4 nichts mehr werden.
Ja, wenn man jetzt selber mal Large Scale Provider werden möchte. Jetzt?
Dann fängst du mit V6 an.
Das heißt, man ist eigentlich erstmal außen vor jetzt, oder?
Ja, es gibt da natürlich diese Fair Use, Fair Distribution Policies. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt den Finger hebst und das auch ernst meinst, dann kriegst du natürlich von Raipe, denke ich mal schon, primär auch Adressen, damit du überhaupt loslegen kannst. Aber du wirst halt nie so viel kriegen, wenn jetzt, ich will jetzt Large Scale Provider werden, eine Million User bedienen oder 10 Millionen, oder lach dich aus, das haben die nicht mehr.
Aber ist denn das jetzt der einzige Grund, warum man V6 braucht, die Sache mit den Adressen?
Das ist der Grund, den man primär gerne mal anführt. Das ist auch der, den man so in einer Tagesschau sieht oder auf tagesschau.de, wenn mal davon geredet ist, oder von V6 Day oder so was, wo man halt einfach versucht, der Masse des Volks klar zu machen. So, hier ist ein Ressource, hier ist jetzt einfach ein Ressource am Ende und es muss eine neue her. Und deswegen muss alles ganz neu und ganz schön. Wobei jetzt Otto Normal User, die wissen davon gar nichts. Die geben oben in ihren Browser ein, die geben in ihr Suchfeld ein facebook.com, dann kriegen sie die Google-Response-Site und dann klicken sie auf Facebook.
ZB sie geben einen Facebook-Login.
Ja, das Beste, was ich mal gesehen habe, ist, dass jemand echt die Google-Seite aufgerufen hat, in denen er in den Google-Search-Bar oben Google eingegeben hat.
When you type Google into Google, you can destroy the Internet. Das Beste, was ich fand, ist, dass mal jemand, dass das mitbekommen, dass so eine Bude, so eine Techno-Seite mal über Probleme beim Facebook-Login ein Artikel schrieb und dann im Google-Ranking für Facebook-Login ganz nach oben geriet. Und die Leute, die halt wirklich Facebook-Login eingegeben haben, dann alle auf diese Seite kamen, auf diesen Artikel und sich dort in den Kommentaren beschwert haben, warum denn das Seiten-Design hätte sich geändert, warum habt ihr das geändert. Was sehr schön, es fällt leicht, sich darüber lustig zu machen. Nur, ich denke, dass es eben für die technisch orientierte Teil dieser Internetgemeinde immer auch sehr schwer nachzuvollziehen, wie groß der Unterschied in dieser technischen Detailwahrnehmung ist. Und es muss natürlich alles sehr einfach sein. Und teilweise ist es eben auch so, auch so die Realitäten von IPv4, auch die Realitäten vieler anderer Protokolle und Standards im Internet einfach eine Einfachheit auch gar nicht erlauben. Also allein so dieses, verbinde dich mit mir. Wie kann ich denn jetzt die große Datei von A nach B übertragen?
Und was ist eine Datei?
Ja, dass man solche komischen Hoster braucht, wo man was hoch lädt, damit der andere sich das runterlädt. Warum kann man sich nicht direkt mit dem anderen verbinden? Da steckt eben auch viel von dieser IPv4-Naturalität mit drin. Und leider ist es auch so, dass eben viele dieser lästigen Sachen dann eben auch Providern und anderen Mitspielern in dem Netz auch teilweise eben einfach interessante Business-Modelle sichern. Also allein so dieses, ich kann keinen Server im UMTS-Netz anbieten oder ich kann überhaupt von zu Hause aus nicht ohne weiteres Dienste anbieten. Da trennt man halt schön so den Privatkundenbereich von dem, ja hier, wir haben ja auch einen Host für dich und so weiter, was man so mühelos zu Hause absetzen könnte.
Man sieht es bei Telekom DSL, Geschäftskundenanschlüssen versus Privatanschlüssen. Technisch genau das selbe in grün dahinter. Nur eine andere Konfiguration in der Database. Und kostet halt einfach mal, keine Ahnung, doppelt oder so. Wie viel wird so ein Geschäftskunden-DSL-Anschluss kosten? Ist ja schon dreistellig oder so. Klar, da sind Business-Modelle dahinter auch.
So, aber es gibt auch andere Probleme. Außer den Adressen.
Ja, das ist, wie ich es sozusagen eingespielt habe. Es gibt viele Probleme rund um Adressen. Eins davon ist die Knappheit von Adressen. Es gibt einen ganzen Sack von Problemen, die sich um diese Verteilung von Adressen ranken. Also um diese ganzen Hierarchien. Wo kriege ich jetzt eigentlich eine her? Aber vielleicht sollte man das sagen, was wir schon vor einer Stunde hätten sagen sollen. Das Problem bei den Adressen ist, dass man eindeutige Adressen haben möchte. Es geht nicht darum, irgendeine IP-Adresse zu haben. Du kannst ja einfach irgendeine eintippen. Sondern es geht darum, eine zu haben, die dir zugeordnet ist, die auch nur du hast. Das ist wie eine Telefonnummer. Wäre ja blöd, wenn es dieselbe Nummer fünfmal gäbe und du rufst sie an und dann kriegst du rendemäßig einen von den fünf Leuten. Deswegen versucht man halt eine eindeutige Zuordnung zu machen. Und das ist wie gesagt ein heiloser Zoo im V4. Das hat man versucht im V6 sowohl administrativ als auch technisch auch mit zu fixen. Man ist also gleich hingegangen, hat sozusagen politische Strategien mit der Technik mit ersonnen und auch beschlossen zu sagen, so werden Adressen verteilt, so und nicht anders. Und in dieser Reihenfolge und du kriegst das und delegierst das an denen weiter und so, das ist im V4 ist das ein Zoo. Im V6 ist das sozusagen ein bisschen deutlicher geregelt. Auch eben aufgrund von Abkommen zwischen diesen Regionen zum Beispiel. Adressen sind ein Thema, nicht nur wegen der Knappheit, sondern eben auch wegen der administrativen und der Vergabemechanismen, die dazu gehören, auch dann zum Beispiel bis hin zum Endgerät. Wenn so ein Endgerät irgendwie mit einem Netz verbunden wird, entweder weil man es das erste Mal reinsteckt oder weil es ein Gerät ist, was man jetzt sozusagen mit sich rumschleppt, was sich per WLAN irgendwo einbucht, die Mechanismen, die dahinterstehen, dass dieses Gerät dann auch eine IP-Adresse bekommt. Und wie das funktioniert, sind halt eben auch in V4 zwar gelöst, aber haben immer noch immer mal so Haken und Ösen. Da gibt es ja dieses DHCP-Protokoll, DHCPv4. Das ist auch problembehaftet immer wieder. Also ich merke das häufiger mal, wenn ich in irgendwelchen Gegenden bin oder im Hotel oder unterwegs in irgendwelchen Lounge ist oder sonst was, und manchmal auch in Firmennetzen, ist es vorkommt, du buchst dich da ein und WLAN funktioniert super toll und du kriegst trotzdem keine Verbindung zum Internet. Und dann gucke ich nach, stell fest, oh, ich habe keine IP-Adresse bekommen. Also dieser DHCP-Mechanismus hat dann auch nicht funktioniert, weil er keine mehr hatte oder DHCP ist ja aber gerade doof oder tot ist oder wie auch immer, ist egal. Aber das ist halt eben auch so ein Thema, dass man nicht nur Adressen grundsätzlich zugeteilt bekommt, man muss sie auch auf die Geräte bekommen.
Also kurz gesagt, die Vergabe von IP-Adressen ist in dem IPv4-Standard in dem Sinne überhaupt gar nicht konkret geregelt. Und deswegen wurden dann Sachen wie DHCP ersonnen, um so eine automatische Vergabe, die vorher schlicht manuell stattgefunden hat, es gab einen Vorläufer, der nannte sich BootP, das BootP-Protokoll.
Der war wahnsinnig simpel, hatte aber auch zum Beispiel den Nachteil, dass eine IP-Adresse, die darüber vergeben wurde, auch immer weg war. Weil es gab keinen Timeout-Mechanismus, oder ich benutze die Adresse nicht mehr, tu sie zurück in den Pool. Sondern hast du BootP gemacht, dann hat dir jemand, wenn er nett war, dir eine IP-Adresse gegeben und das wars. Was natürlich in unserer heutigen Welt, wie wir sie gerade haben, du gehst mit deinem iPhone, Laptop, wie auch immer, in irgendein WLAN-Netz rein und wieder raus. Und dann besuchst du mal jemanden, oder gehst in ein Lounge, in ein Hotel oder wie auch immer, wär der tot, wär nichts zu machen. Das war eins der Hauptfeatures mit von DHCP, was übrigens eine Erfindung von Microsoft ist.
Die Lease-Time.
Überhaupt ein Lease-Mechanismus, dass man sagt, hallo, gibts hier erstmal, dass man überhaupt mal fragt. BootP war so brute force. Es ist ein Broadcast, man hat einfach in den Raum reingebrüllt, sozusagen, ey, ich brauch hier ne Adresse. Und wenn jemand nett war, hat er zurückgebrüllt. Ey, du da, hier, Hasse. Und bei DRCP ist das ein bisschen netter. Da wird also erstmal gefragt, gibt es hier jemand, der hier Adressen verteilt oder man kann auch sagen, ich brauch keine Adresse, ich will hier nur so was wie Nameserver wissen oder so. Man kann sich erst mal ein bisschen orientieren. Dann sucht man sich verschiedene Angebote und diese Angebote werden dann auch angenommen. Bei BootP war es so, wenn der BootP-Server zurückgebrüllt hat, hier Hasse, hat er die sozusagen rausgenommen aus dem Pool. Das war es denn. Bei DECP sucht man sozusagen erst mal einen Server, holt sich Angebote ein. Wenn da mehrere DECP-Server sind, sagt man, hier habt ihr ja so eine Adresse, auch die gefällt mir, die Leastime, wie lange kann ich die haben? Auch fünf Tage, nehme ich. Haben will. Und dann heißt, da war eben auch so ein Zeitverhalten mit drauf, dass man sagt, man kann diese Adresse jetzt für einen Zeitraum X benutzen. Man konnte sich dann vor Ablauf dieser Zeit melden und die verlängern. Man konnte sie aber freiwillig zurückgeben, was BootP auch nicht konnte.
Was davon hat jetzt Microsoft ersonnen?
Das Ganze, die ACP. Die ACPv4 ist sozusagen eine...... Es basiert so ein bisschen auf BootP, benutzt noch dieselben Ports und so. Aber ist halt ein bisschen elaborierter, ein bisschen schlauer schon. Weiterhin hat man dann auch gesagt, man braucht jetzt noch mehr Informationen außer einer IP-Adresse. Ich möchte hier auch gerne was über Namen wissen oder ich möchte gerne wissen, wo sind die Nameserver, also die DNS-Server. Wo ich jetzt so einen Namen www.facebook.com mal zu einer IP-Adresse verwandeln kann. Womit wir bei deinem Thema sind, was wir eben schon angesprochen haben, wieso schert sich eigentlich ein Facebook-User um IP-Adressen? Muss er da eigentlich nicht. Man sieht da auch nie einer. Der tippt halt oben seinen Facebook-Login in sein Google-Searchfeld ein und dann ist gut. So soll das übrigens auch sein. Was sozusagen an dieser Stelle sagen kann, was interessieren Facebook-User vor sechs? Gar nichts. Also Hörer, die jetzt nur darauf gewartet haben, die Antwort darauf zu kriegen, wie das ihre, wie sagt man, ihre Facebook-Homepage, wie sagt man?
Wie es unser Leben beeinflussen wird.
Wie es unser Leben beeinflussen wird. Sollte es das nicht tun?
Ja, V6 ist halt eigentlich, im Idealfall ist es ein, reden wir hier wirklich von einem unsichtbaren Vorgang, der eigentlich sollte sich, V4 sollte einen Schritt zur Seite treten und sukzessive durch V6 ersetzt werden. Aber wir reden ja jetzt ja auch zu den Leuten, die sich für die Details dann doch interessieren. Und dass das alles so reibungslos vonstatten geht, ist ja auch eher eine Illusion. Aber um es nochmal kurz zusammenzuweisen, also die Adress, es geht generell, also die Argumentation für V6 ist Adressen. Aber wir haben verschiedene Aspekte davon. Erste hatten wir gehabt, die Knappheit. Zweite haben wir gehabt, die Art und Weise der Vergabe, sowohl auf so einer internationalen Ebene, wie überhaupt erst mal Adressen weiter verteilt werden, bis sie an einem Ort sind, wo ich sie mit meinem Computer abholen kann. Aber dann eben auch dieser Aspekt, wie kriege ich die? Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal sagen, was eigentlich V6 jetzt neu ins Spiel bringt. Was ist denn da jetzt anders?
Na, die Designer haben sich das mal angeguckt, haben gesagt, okay, ein IPv4-Paket ist hauptsächlich, ich sag mal, definiert oder ein interessantes Teil steckt in dem Header, in dem IPv4-Header. Der Rest hinten drin ist Payload. Das ist ein Problem anderer Leute, ein paar. Das, was vorne drin steht, ist das, was uns interessiert. Da stecken halt die beiden Adressen drin. Bei V4 2x 32 Bit. Und die müssen wir erstmal größer machen. So grundsätzlich. Also 2x im Sinne von Sender und Empfänger. Das grundsätzliche Konzept dort, Sender und Empfänger zu haben, hat man sich überlegt, das ist gut, das behält man so bei. Wir machen die Adressen größer. Und zwar nicht von 32 auf 40 Bit oder sowas, sondern auf 128 Bit. Und das sind jetzt nicht 4x so viele Adressen.
Das sind nur 4x so viele Bits.
4x so viele Bits. Das ist ein unglaublich großer Adressraum. Da kann man jetzt lustige Zahlenspiele mitmachen. Da kommen wir nachher noch drauf. Es gab auch mal Leute, die behauptet haben, dass das so viele Adressen sind, dass man jedem Atom auf der Erde eine eigene IP-Adresse geben könnte. Habe ich mal nachgerechnet, kommt nicht ganz hin. Jedenfalls nicht, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass die Erde einen Eisenkern hat. Aber es ist trotzdem, es sind unglaublich viele Adressen. Man wusste allerdings schon, dass man eben sehr viele von diesen...
Aber jedem Sandkorn könnte man eine geben.
Ja, es könnte hinkommen. Jedem Sandkorn könnte man bestimmt eine IP-Adresse geben. Müssen wir mal nachrechnen oder so. Aber ist wahrscheinlich möglich. Jetzt geht es allerdings nicht so um die Menge, sondern ich habe ja vorhin schon erwähnt, dass ein wichtiger Mechanismus, damit das alles funktioniert, ist die Struktur. Diese Adressen müssen Struktur haben. Und man verwendet also viele dieser 128 Bits, um Struktur zu erzeugen. Das heißt, man verschwendet effektiv, sozusagen, wenn man hinterher drauf schaut, sagt, wieso geben wir dem so viele Adressen? So viel braucht er doch gar nicht. Ja, aber dann kann er sie besser organisieren, wenn er so viele davon hat. Gut, dieser Teil. Dann hat man sich noch ein paar andere Sachen angeguckt. Man hat gesagt, wenn wir das jetzt anfassen, IPv4-Header ist ja relativ simpel. Da sind noch ein paar andere alte Schuhe drin, die wir jetzt auch mal abwerfen. Zum Beispiel trägt ein IPv4-Header eine Checksum mit sich rum, die aber gar nicht über das gesamte Datenpaket geht, sondern nur über den Header. Da hat man sich gedacht, das ist relativ albern. Weil man transportiert heute IP-Pakete auf unteren Schichten, die für sich schon so mit Checksums vollgestopft sind, dass eigentlich ein Paket eher verloren geht, als dass es falsch ankommt. Es gibt doch noch einen anderen Grund, warum man diese Checksum eliminiert hat. Da komme ich gleich noch drauf. Es gibt nämlich noch ein Feld, was spannend ist. Es gibt es im V4-Header. Das nennt sich dort die Time to Live. Das ist ein 8-Bit-Feld, was, wie gesagt, schon seit früher Zeit gab. In der Urdefinition von IP, in dem IP-Protokoll RFC791, sieht man drin, dass ein Zähler, der soll sozusagen jede Sekunde einmal runtergezählt werden und jeder Router, der ein Paket weiterleitet, soll außerdem diese Zahl mindestens um 1 dekrementieren. Das hat man dafür gemacht, damit Pakete, die falsch geroutet werden, nicht ewig im Kreis laufen. Ein Paket hat sozusagen eine Lebensdauer. Das kann man schon mal sehen, die haben damals Paket-Lebensdauer in Sekunden angegeben. Man kann ein Paket in die Antarktischicken und zurück in unter einer Sekunde. Das ist schon das Weiteste, was so geht. Und alles, was dann später kommt, ist ohnehin. Es interessiert keine Sau mehr. Irgendwie gibt es da so einen Spruch. Und IP-Pakete, die eine Sekunde alt sind, sind eigentlich schon old news. Abgesehen davon ist es, wie gesagt, auch eine alberne Definition. Das hat man geändert. Im V6 ist man ja einfach nur sagt, es ist jetzt ein Hop-Count. Das heißt, man kann jetzt sagen, der Absender kann entscheiden, wenn ich ein Paket losschicke, das soll maximal durch 10 Router durch. Wenn es denn immer noch nicht da ist, dann vergiss es. Das ist mir denn zu weit oder das macht keinen Sinn mehr oder wie auch immer. Jetzt war es aber so, dass im IPv4 war ja, wie gesagt, die Pflicht eines Routers, er musste das alle Sekunde, aber mindestens einmal runterzählen, wann er es weitergemacht hat. Das heißt, er hat dieses Feld verändert im IPv4-Header. Und dadurch, dass es diese Checksum gab, über den gesamten IPv4-Header, wo auch der Time-to-Live-Feld mit drin war, musste er also auch die Checksum neu berechnen. Damals war die Software-Implementation so, man kann jetzt schon mal so eine Checksum neu berechnen, aber es war trotzdem lästig. Das ist albern. Vor allem, man hatte das Ding nicht wirklich gebraucht. Deswegen hat man das im V6 weggelassen. Man hat gesagt, wir wollen jetzt gerne einen Header haben, wo man nicht dauernd immer die Checksum neu berechnen muss. Man hat solche Veränderungen gemacht. Dann gibt es sowas im IPv4, es gibt sogenannte Options. Eigentlich im heutigen Internet fast gar nicht benutzt. Oder mir fällt dir so wirklich keine ein, die da ernsthaft benutzt wird. Aber man hat dafür eine ganze Menge Mechanismen vorgesehen im IPv4. Es gibt auch im V6 wieder Options. Allerdings hat man gesagt, die pappen wir jetzt hinten dran, als wäre das irgendwie eine Payload. Als wäre das jetzt ein TCP oder UDP-Paket. Aber die behandeln wir jetzt nicht als Core, in dem Core-Header mit von dem Zeugs. Man hat also dieses ganze Handling von dem Ding sehr viel vereinfacht. Und eben die beiden großen fetten Adressen dran. Das ist sozusagen im Prinzip die Geschichte. Man hat sich gedacht, wir machen das ganze Protokoll mal einfacher, dass man es einfacher implementieren kann. Eigentlich so oft, als man hat das Leben, ne, das stimmt nicht. Man hat gesagt, wir machen das Leben für die Router einfacher. Beim IPv4 war der Anspruch, der, dass man sagte, man möchte relativ simple Clients haben oder simple Hosts haben. Die sollten eine möglichst einfache Implementation haben, um eben auch so Kleinstgeräte mal zu unterstützen, so ich sag jetzt mal Kühlschrank oder so, mit wenig Hirn oder so.
Die Glühbirne mit Internetanschluss.
Die Glühbirne mit Internetanschluss. Da hat man sich gesagt, man macht das da ein bisschen simpler und packt die Intelligenz, die man braucht, in den Router rein. Das ist auch heute immer noch nicht falsch. Allerdings ist halt mit der Masse des Verkehrs, versucht man natürlich, die Pakete so schnell wie möglich durchzuschießen. Man kann es so ein bisschen vergleichen mit wie Postleitzahlen. Die Post hat ja auch funktioniert vor Postleitzahlen. Aber da musste halt eben jemand früher lesen. Hamburg. Und da musste der Postler halt eben drüber nachdenken, sagen, Hamburg, das war doch der Sack da hinten in der Ecke und da den Brief reinschmeißen. Und dann hat man halt irgendwann mal überlegt, wir wollen es simpler machen. Wir führen halt sozusagen eine einfache Lesbarkeit der Adresse in dem Prinzip sozusagen mal ein. Dass sozusagen jemand, der diese Dinge handhabt, einfacher damit umgehen kann. Ist jetzt ein bisschen hinten der Vergleich, aber die Idee ist sozusagen dahinter. Dies hat sich so ein bisschen umgekehrt. Man hat also jetzt festgestellt, dass man sagt, okay, wir haben genug Brains in den Endgeräten, also in Hosts oder in den Clients. Die Router sind auch nicht dümmer geworden in den letzten Jahren, aber sie haben viel mehr zu tun. Man möchte also höhere Paketraten erzielen. Deswegen muss man also immer mehr Funktionen in Hardware packen. Man kann also nicht jedes Paket immer noch auspacken und mit einem Stück Software da drauf gucken, wie ist das jetzt gemeint, wo soll das hin, warum und so. Sondern wir wollen so viel wie möglich durch Hardware abwickelbar machen. Das heißt, man hat diese...
Die Automatisierbarkeit der Weiterleitungen soll verbessert werden.
Genau, das heißt also, ist auch einer der Punkte, zum Beispiel im V4 gibt es einen Mechanismus, nennt sich Fragmentierung. Da würde ich jetzt nicht allzu tief drauf eingehen, aber ich muss es, glaube ich, mal erwähnen.
Da wenn halt ein Paket zu groß ist, um es von A nach B zu übertragen, würde es auch schon nochmal zerhackstückelt.
Die Strecke von A nach B hat ja mehrere Strecken. Man muss ja hier sozusagen aus der Tür raus, dann auf die Straße, straßelang, dann die Hauptstraße und so weiter und so fort. Also so ähnlich sieht es ja im Internet auch aus. Da hast du da verschiedene Wege, die unterschiedlich breit sind und so. Und dann gibt es halt eben auch mal Wege, wo bestimmte IP-Pakete nicht durchpassen, weil sie halt einfach zu groß sind. Da ist es im V4 so, dann ist halt der Router, der vor so einem dünnen Weg sitzt, in der Pflicht, dieses große Paket vorher in zwei oder drei kleine zu zerschneiden, die über den dünnen Weg rüberzuschicken. Und ursprünglich war es gedacht, dass der Router auf der anderen Seite sie wieder zusammensetzt. Das hat man aber dann auch bald fallen lassen. Das macht dann das Endsystem, was hinten sozusagen ganz am Ende kommt. Das kriegt dann sozusagen drei einzelne Teile, die es erstmal wieder zusammensetzen muss, um ein IP-Paket zu haben. Das ist nun eine Fragmentierung. Eigentlich soll das keine Rolle spielen, spielt aber eine Rolle, weil es jeder, der wahrscheinlich das hier hört, hat diese Thema zu Hause mit seinem DSL-Router. Das liegt daran, dass du auf deinem Ethernet zu Hause, was du wahrscheinlich hast, oder auf deinem WLAN hast, hast du eine MTU, eine Maximum Transmission Unit, von 1500 Bytes. Das heißt, ein Paket auf einem Ethernet kann 1500 Bytes groß sein. Das Paket, was durchs DSL durchpasst, kann aber nur 1492 Bytes groß sein. Das heißt, das ist jetzt ein ganz fieses Thema, da müssen wir jetzt nicht darauf einsteigen, warum das so ist, aber das ist so. Das heißt, jeder DSL-Router zu Hause, der, wenn er von einem Endgerät ein 1500er Paket kriegt, muss das eigentlich zerschnipseln und einen 192er draus machen und einen 8er. Was durchaus ein Performance-Problem ist. Da gibt es jetzt verschiedene Mechanismen für, wie man das abwendet. Dann hat sich das MV4 auch schon überlegt, dass das blöd ist, weil dadurch verdoppeln sich auch die Pakete und du hast immer so einen Schnipsel, der da hinten noch dran ist. Das weißt du, wie man sich früher geärgert hat, wenn man mit einem Textverordnungen eine Seite gedruckt hat und dann kommt eine zweite Seite raus und da steht der letzte Satz drauf. Du hast dafür die zweite Papierseite verschwendet.
Und auf der steht, bitte bedenken Sie an die Umwelt, wenn Sie das ausdrucken.
Das ist der selbe Effekt. Und deswegen gibt es solche Mechanismen, die bei V4 erst später dazu ersonnen wurden. Ich nenne jetzt immer das Stichwort, es nennt sich MTU Discovery. Das heißt also die beiden Endgeräte, Client und Server, versuchen zu ermitteln, wie dick die dünnste Stelle der Verbindung zwischen ihnen ist und schicken dann gar nicht erst Pakete, die größer sind als solche. MTU Discovery funktioniert so, dass man ein Paket schickt, wo man einen Fleck setzt, dass man sagt, hallo lieber Router, dieses Paket darfst du nicht fragmentieren, das darfst du nicht zerschneiden. Wenn man ein solch großes Paket schickt und es landet an einem Router, der es eigentlich zerschneiden müsste, dann guckt er, sagt, oh darf ich nicht, schmeißt es weg und in der guten alten Tradition des Internets sagt so ein Router, der ein Paket wegschmeißt, schickt eine Notifikation an den Absender, zurück sagt, hallo, ich hab grad eben eins deiner Pakete weggeschmissen, komm mal weil. Zum Beispiel auch wenn diese für einen erwähnten TTL abläuft, wenn ich jetzt ein Paket wegschicke mit TTL von 5, dann hoppelt es los und der 5. Router zählt die runter, sagt, oh, von 5 auf 0, wegschmeißen, schickt mir eine Nachricht zurück, sagt, ich hab grad eben dein Paket weggeschmissen, weil die TTL ist abgelaufen. Ebenso sagt er halt eben, ich hab grad eben dein Paket weggeschmissen, weil ich hätt es fragmentieren müssen, aber ich durfte nicht, du hast ja gesagt, ich darf nicht, also deswegen hier hab ich's weggeschmissen. Daraufhin schicke ich halt, er schickt mir auch mit, wie groß die MTU gewesen wäre, auf die er zugeschnitten hätte. Daraufhin schicke ich also jetzt wieder ein Paket los, diesmal in der angesachten Größe und hoffe, dass das durchgeht. Wenn das durchgeht, ist fein, wenn da wieder ein Router drin ist, der noch was kleineres haben will, schickt er mir wieder den zurück. Und dann ist gut. So funktioniert eigentlich MTU Discovery. Das hat natürlich für das normale Internet funktioniert. Für Leute, die in Firmennetzen sitzen, ist das eine immer wiederkehrende Quelle der Freude. Weil Firmenadminen glauben immer noch, dass ICMP, das nämlich das Protokoll, was dafür benutzt wird, dass dir so ein Router sagen kann, dass er gerade eben eins deiner Pakete weggeschmissen hat. Die halten das für die schlimmste Erfindung, seit es Schokolade gibt. Weil das ist ja das Hacker-Protokoll. Damit exploren ja Hacker unsere Netze. Deswegen ist das erste, was Dieter Dummchen als Administrator in seinem neuen Job macht, erst mal ICMP-Pakete in der Firewall zu verbieten. Was dazu führt, dass MTU-Discovery nicht mehr geht. Das ist auch eine Pest. Das Schöne ist, bei IPv6 haben sie sich gesagt, wir hören jetzt mal auf mit dem Blödsinn. Wir erklären jetzt MTU-Discovery zum Credo. Wir diskutieren da gar nicht drüber, ob sowas benutzt wird. Sowas wird benutzt, weil unsere Router fragmentieren einfach nicht mehr. Fertig. Es gibt keine Router-Fragmentation mehr. Ende.
Wenn deine Pakete zu groß sind, dann kommen sie einfach nicht an.
Genau. Das heißt, du musst jetzt rausfinden, wie das funktioniert. Du musst MTU-Pass-Discovery benutzen. Und wenn ein Admin jetzt das abstellt, dann geht das Internet nicht mehr schlecht. Dann geht es einfach gar nicht mehr. Wie gesagt, die haben etliche solcher alten Dinge überfahren, wo sie einfach sagen, das ist jetzt Blödsinn, was die Leute hier machen. Wir hören das mal auf mit dem Zoo, wir machen das jetzt richtig.
Das heißt, IPv6 geht schon über einen geänderten Header und geänderte Adressen hinaus. Es definiert auch darum herum noch so verschiedene Verhaltensweisen, die vielleicht bisher noch nicht existierten, optional waren. ZB lässt auch bestimmte einfach weg. Einfach sozusagen das Gelernte aus mittlerweile fast 30 Jahren IPv4.
Oh, länger, 40 Jahre, über 40 Jahre.
Seit wann gibt es das?
1969 glaube ich. Weiß ich nicht.
Als es noch Arpanet war.
Ja, aber da, wo dieses Ding erfunden wurde, da war noch ein Sechs vorne oder eine Sieben. Aber jedenfalls 40 Jahre haben wir schon rum. Ja, das heißt, die haben jede Menge Zöpfe abgeschnitten, haben einfach gesagt, hier werden religiöse Kriege geführt, wie z.B. verbiete ich ICMP-Pakete oder nicht? Nein, das tust du nicht mehr. Hör jetzt auf mit dem Scheiß. Ja, das sind so ein paar Errungenschaften auf politischer Ebene, die sozusagen damit kommen.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal so ein bisschen diesen Prozess jetzt durchgehen. Aber vielleicht muss man dazu auch noch einiges erklären. So dieses, wie kommt jetzt der Computer ran? Ich meine, du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, IPv6-Adressen, da ist dann auch noch die Verteilung mit dabei. Wie funktioniert denn das jetzt sozusagen genau? Also wie kommt denn der Rechner zu seinen V6-Adressen? Wo kriege ich die denn jetzt her? Ja, alle haben jetzt den Podcast gehört und wollen V6 haben. Wo ist denn das Loch in der Wand, wo das V6 rauskommt? Beziehungsweise, was muss man jetzt über diesen eigentlichen Prozess?
Na, da kann man jetzt mal Folgendes sagen. Auch ein spannender Punkt vielleicht. Ein Rechner, der V6 benutzen möchte, grundsätzlich erst mal, um diese Adresse zu kriegen, muss man ihn anmachen. Und das sage ich jetzt mit all dem Smirking dabei, was man auch vielleicht raus hört. Es gibt erst mal einen Grundmechanismus, der V6-Inne wohnt, der es einem Rechner erlaubt, ohne auch nur mit irgendjemand auf der Welt zu reden, sich erst mal eine Adresse zu generieren. Oder mehrere davon. Das ist ein unglaublich wichtiger Schritt, eine unglaublich wichtige Errungenschaft auch. Das ist eine, ich rede hier von den sogenannten Link-Local-Adressen. Das heißt, das kannst du selber ausprobieren, wenn du einen Rechner hast, der nicht vielleicht schon IPv6 angeknipst hat, so wie er aus dem Laden kam, sondern wo du das anmachst und guckst auf das Interface drauf, das hat sofort eine IP-Adresse. Ohne, dass es auch nur mit irgendjemandem geredet hat. Du brauchst im WLAN gar nicht eingebucht zu sein oder dein Internetkabel gar nicht reinstecken.
Aber das ist ja bei IPv4 eigentlich auch so. Also die Link-Local-Adressen gibt es ja auch.
Ja, aber da stochert er erstmal rum. Also da fängt er erstmal an. Also er probiert erstmal, sich eine geben zu lassen. Guckt erstmal, gibt's hier einen DRCP-Server? Aber dann irgendwann, wenn ihm eine Standard einfällt, dann tauchen auch diese Link-Local-Adressen auf. Das sind die 169.254.x.x-Adressen.
Die könnte er sich doch auch gleich selbst geben.
Ja, macht man irgendwie nicht. Oder machen die Implementationen nicht. Beim IPv6 ist es wie gesagt so, dass es diese Link-Local-Adressen gibt, die gibt's einfach fertig, Punkt, Ende, aus. Die sind auch essentiell wichtig, weil um überhaupt mit der Außenwelt in Kontakt zu treten, braucht man eine Adresse. Bei V4 war das nicht so. Da konnte man auch zum Beispiel dieses vorhin erwähnte BUP-Protokoll, da hat man selber mit der Absender-Adresse von 0.0.0.0 in den Raum gebrüllt. Sozusagen ein Paket von 0.0.0.0 an 255, von 255, 4 mal 255 hat man in den Raum gebrüllt, hat gesagt so, ich bin hier, ich weiß gar nichts, hat jemand eine Adresse für mich? Bei V6 ist das nicht so, weil du hast eine. Du hast sozusagen qua Definition eine. Jetzt die Frage, wo kommt die her? Die große Frage, die im Raum steht, wo kommt die her? Ich gehe jetzt mal von dem simplen Fall, das gebe ich als Disclaimer vorneweg. Wir reden jetzt mal primär, wenn ich nichts anderes sage, reden wir mal von Ethernet. Wir reden jetzt nicht von DSL oder PPP-Verbindung oder Tokenring oder schlimmeren Dingen, die es da noch gibt, oder IP over Avian Carriers oder sowas, sondern wir reden jetzt von Ethernet.
Oder WLAN.
Das ist ein Ethernet. Nur mit, ohne Schnur. Und dort sind jedem Gerät, was eine solche Hardware hat, die daran teilnehmen kann, ist vom Werk aus eine Adresse mitgegeben worden. Eine Mac-Adresse. Das hat jetzt nichts mit Mac oder Apple zu tun, sondern eine Adresse für den Media Access Control. Das ist eine 48-bitige Zahl, die auch wieder einer gewissen Struktur folgt. Da ist es ganz interessant, da kann man auch mal kleine Worte gleich zu verlieren, die jedem Gerät mitgegeben ist. Die ist dort eingebrannt in einem EEPROM, EEPROM oder wie auch immer. Das heißt, der Hersteller selber stellt, der Hersteller einer Ethernet-Card oder eines WLAN-Chips oder wie auch immer, stellt von Hause aus schon sicher, dass dort eine eindeutige Adresse drin ist. Die ist 48-bit lang. Das heißt, sie wäre sozusagen für einen entsprechenden Approach bei automatischer Adressvergabe bei V4 wäre sie schon zu lang. Bei V6 hingegen haben wir ja 128-bit für eine Adresse. Und da kann man ja diese 48-bit, die man sozusagen aus dieser MAC-Adresse eines Ethernet-Chips oder so was draus lesen kann, kann man ja gut da rein verwursten. Und die ist schon sozusagen von Werk aus weltweit eindeutig. Das funktioniert so, dass es gibt eine Organisation, die IEEE diesmal, ist das International? Electrical Engineering E, irgendwas. Also irgendeine Assoziation von Elektrikern.
Institute of Electrical and Electronics Engineers.
Ah, der Fast-Googler.
Dem Ingenieur ist nichts zu schwören.
Die verteilen die ersten 24 bits von dieser Zahl als an eine Organisation. Das kostet auch nichts, man kann da so hinschreiben, ich hab ja selber auch mal Router gebaut. Dann kann man da in den höflichen Mail hinschreiben, sagen, hallo, ich bin der und der oder die und die Firma und wir wollen gerne das und das machen. Teilt mir doch mal bitte einen sogenannten OUI zu, einen Organisational Unit Identifier, wo man sozusagen sagt, ich bin hier die Abteilung der Firma so und so, ich brauch mal so, weil ich möchte eindeutige Adressen vergeben weltweit, gibt mir doch mal so ein Ding. Dann geben die sozusagen die ersten 24 bits davon und die restlichen kann man denn dafür benutzen, um dort seine Geräte durchzunummerieren. Und man ist halt in der Verantwortung als Hersteller, dass man das auch ordentlich macht, dass man sozusagen keine Adresse rausgibt, die in ihren gesamten 48 bit nochmal woanders auftaucht. Die glauben auch, dass das noch ein bisschen hält. Die glauben, dass sie damit noch bis 2100 durchkommen.
2100?
Ja, ist so die Ansage, die sie gemacht haben, dass sie mit diesen 48 bit identifieren. Allerdings haben sie jetzt auch schon vor ein paar Jahren gesagt, es gibt auch noch mal eine Advanced. Dann machen wir das als 64 bit Zahl und da sehen wir nicht, dass wir in irgendwie absehbarer Zeit da hinten rauslaufen mit der Anzahl dieser Dinger. Dass wir sozusagen diese Identifier vergeben, dass es da einen gibt, der doppelt auftaucht.
So, die ganze Liste kann man sich runterladen.
Die OUIs.
Mal eine ordentliche Textdatei, auch mal so zum Testen, wie schnell der eigene Texteditor so ist. Das ist hier 2,6 MB, 2,7. Da stehen sie alle drin. Alle diese Firmen, die jemals... Was hattet ihr denn für einen Identifier damals?
Ich hab den Identifier nicht im Kopf. Kannst du mal gucken, net.cs, net.cs.
Ah ja, hier. 00A0AB.
Ja, 00A0AB, genau. So, und wie gesagt, da ist relativ leicht rankommen. Man benutzt die Übens, ich hab zwar eben gesagt, wir sprechen hauptsächlich über Internet, aber man benutzt die Übens auch für andere Sachen, also auch so Bluetooth-Chips und so was, benutzen die auch als eindeutige Identifier. Also sozusagen, wie man mal so will, für Netzwerkprotokolle eindeutige Identifier, die man da mal sozusagen verteilt.
Die Hardware-Adresse.
Die Hardware-Adresse, ja. Die ist allerdings nicht wirklich in den Chip eingebrannt, dass sie sie wirklich ultimativ verwendet, sondern sie wird sozusagen nur mitgeliefert zu jedem Ding, was irgendwie Ethernet, WLAN spricht oder Bluetooth oder wer auch immer die da alle benutzt. Die haben halt diese kleine E-Prom an Bord, wo drauf steht, hier hast du eine eindeutige Adresse, wenn du eine brauchst, aber wenn du irgendwelche anderen benutzen willst, pff, mir egal. Go. So, also man hat, wenn man so einen Rechner einschaltet und der hat eine Ethernet-Chipschere zum Beispiel, dann hat er mindestens eine solcher eindeutigen Identifier. Und mit dem kann man sich jetzt schon mal eine Adresse basteln, die man benutzen kann, wo sichergestellt ist, dass die keine andere hat.
Aber auch nur auf dem Interface.
Also wenn ich jetzt WLAN und Kabel-Ethernet habe...
Du hast zum meisten zwei MAC-Adressen.
Dann hab ich auch zwei V6-Adressen sozusagen.
Dann hast du auch zwei V6-Adressen. Wie gesagt, es ist nicht Pflicht, dass man die benutzt, deswegen gibt es schon noch eine Möglichkeit einer Kollision. Jemand kann ja einfach seinen Identifier auf denselben setzen, wie du das gerne machst. Oder was zum Beispiel auch sehr beliebt ist, siehst du gerade so in nerding-Veranstaltungen. Musst du mal gucken, auf dem Kongress zum Beispiel, wie viele Leute da die MAC-Adresse oder mindestens einen gibt, der hat zum Beispiel deadbeef. D-E-A-D-B-E-E-F. Wie so ne Dinger, deadbeef4223 oder wie so weit, ne? Man kann die halt eben auch auf was anderes setzen, aber in der Regel, wenn man so ein Ding aus der Kiste holt und anmacht, hattet halt erstmal diese MAC-Adresse und daraus bildet man sich ne eindeutige V6-Adresse. Das heißt, man ist also jetzt nicht mehr drauf angewiesen, irgendwelchen Blödsinn zu machen oder irgendwelche anderen Protokolle zu benutzen, um erstmal rauszufinden, wer man so selber ist. Man hat erstmal die Identität, das ist schonmal sehr wichtig. Diese Identität gilt allerdings auch erstmal nur für dieses Interface, nämlich die, wo diese MAC-Adresse zugeordnet ist. Deswegen heißen diese Adressen auch Link Local. Die kann man nur auf einer Verbindung mit anderen Rechnern, auf einer direkten Verbindung mit anderen Rechnern benutzen. Die kann man nicht im Internet benutzen, geht gar nicht. Es geht sogar noch viel schlimmer, wenn man eben vor 6 eine Link Local-Adresse benutzt, dann muss man auch immer dazu sagen, welches Interface man meint. Also du kannst zwei Rechner, die vor 6 sprechen, mit einem Ethernet zusammenschalten. Man kann die gegenseitig anpingen. Sie können sich sofort anpingen, weil sie jeder eine eindeutige Adresse haben. Aber man muss bei dem Ping das Interface mit angeben. Also hier jetzt über WLAN oder jetzt über LAN, nicht über WLAN, weil das, wie gesagt, so complete standalone ist. Die haben keine Ahnung, wer da noch ist und wer wo noch ist. Man muss sozusagen das IP-Paket an die Hand nehmen und sagen, du gehst jetzt bitte aus diesem Interface raus. Da findest du jetzt drüben deinen Partner. Das ist aber sehr wichtig, weil diese Adressen braucht man, damit die weiterführenden Mechanismen, die wir von beschrieben haben, nämlich jetzt sich mal eine richtige Adresse zu besorgen, mit der man jetzt mal ein bisschen in die große weite Welt hinaus könnte. Um diese zu erlangen, braucht man erst mal eine eigene Identität. Jetzt kommen wir zu einem anderen Punkt, ein wichtiger Punkt bei IPv6 ist, dass man gesagt hat, auch das ist eine Erfahrung oder eine Lehre, die man gezogen hat aus dem V4. Eine Interface oder eine IPv6-Implementation muss in der Lage sein, mehrere IP-Adressen pro Interface zu unterstützen. Theoretisch beliebig viele, aber natürlich irgendwann, dann gibt es noch ein Memory-Limit oder sowas, aber du kannst nicht mehr hingehen, ein Device bauen. Und wenn es auch nur ein Dover-Kühlschrank ist, der sagt, nö, hier auf diesem Interface ist eine IP-Adresse drauf, gib sie mir ein und die nehme ich dann. Sowas gibt es nicht mehr. Du musst in der Lage sein, mehrere IP-Adressen zu machen. Du kannst da, wie gesagt, aus Sicherheitsgründen wie immer, kannst du Beschränkungen drauf machen, zum Beispiel so ein Mac, Mac aus X mit dem V6-Deck, der da drin ist, lässt sich nur 16 Präfixe zuteilen. Da kommen wir hinterher drauf. Also er redet mit maximal 16 Routern, von denen er sich Präfixe geben lässt. Das heißt, du hast dann plus der Link-Local-Adresse, hast du den temporären Adressen, hast du dann da drauf so 33 Adressen maximal. Aber das ist eine Beschränkung, die kann man ändern. Da kann man also durchaus hingehen und sagen, ne, das stört mich, ich will die Zahl hochsetzen. Die wird halt gemacht, um irgendwelchen DINALDOF-Service-Attacks vorzubeugen.
Ja, klingt jetzt auch nicht so wie etwas, was mich sonderlich limitiert in meiner täglichen Arbeit.
Aber das ist Pflicht, selbst wenn du eine Glühbirne baust mit V6, musst du in der Lage sein, mehrere IP-Adressen zu unterstützen auf einem Interface.
Wer haut einem denn auf die Finger, wenn man sich nicht richtig verhält?
Keiner, aber das ist halt immer so, wenn du wahrscheinlich deinen Mitbewerber, in Deutschland kriegst du eine Abmahnung, wenn du draufschreibst, auf dein Produkt wäre IPv6 fähig und das ist nachweislich, entspricht nicht dem Standard. Der Standard sagt ganz deutlich, machst das und das wirbst du mit einer falschen Behauptung und dann kriegst du in Deutschland eine Abmahnung. Aber es gibt jetzt keine Zentralinstanz von einer ITF, die so eine Sonde-Einsatzkommando hat, was bei dir durchs Fenster springt und deine Entwicklungsabteilung lüncht.
Wobei das mal nicht die schlechteste Idee wäre.
Aber solche Sachen, das kommt eben auch mit, wenn man sagt, okay, in der V4-Welt haben wir es häufiger schon gesehen und es ist immer so ein Generv, bei V4 muss man manchmal ein Pseudo-Interface machen oder bei manchen heißt es denn Interface-Aliases oder so, wenn man mehr als eine Adresse auf hat. Das ist halt so C. Bei V6 hat man einfach gesagt, das ist so. Und das wird auch intensiv genutzt. Selbst bei einem normalen, autonormalen User, der jetzt nur sein Mac anschließt und den hochfährt. Wenn du denen in einem vernünftig konfigurierten IPv6-Netz hochfährst, zum Beispiel in die Uni oder hier zum Beispiel zu Tim, in die Metaebene, fährt hier sein Mac hoch, dann kriegt er erstmal drei IP-Adressen auf seinem Interface. Nämlich eine Link-Local-Adresse und eine Global Public und eine Global Temporary. Da kommen wir gleich noch drauf. Also das wird intensivst auch genutzt, dass man mehrere Adressen hat pro Interface.
Ist alles so ein bisschen moderner?
Ja, wo wir jetzt das Thema schonmal angefasst haben, ein bisschen terminologisch. Wir müssen mal kurz mal erwähnen, was es so überhaupt für Adressen gibt. Die sind nämlich nicht alle gleich. Ähnlich wie im Telefonnetz zum Beispiel. Eine Notrufnummer ist zwar auch eine Telefonnummer, aber es ist was anderes als eine normale Rufnummer. Es gibt grundsätzlich von den Adresstypen, egal, ob man nur über IP spricht und V4 oder V6 oder noch schlimmere Protokolle, gibt es mal die Unterscheidung, sondern die Unicast-Pakete. Das sind Pakete, die gehen von A nach B, haben einen eindeutigen Absender, einen eindeutigen Empfänger, eine 1 zu 1 Beziehung.
Das sind sozusagen die normalen Pakete.
Das sind die normalen Pakete. Dann gibt es sogenannte Multicast-Pakete. Multicast-Pakete gehen von einem Absender an mehrere Empfänger. Wie das funktioniert, kommen wir gleich noch drauf, müssen wir nämlich auch wissen. Aber einer an mehrere Multicast. Davon gibt es dann eben V4 noch den, sagen wir mal, Spezialfall, den sogenannten Broadcast, wo nämlich mehrere gleich alle ist, sozusagen geht nicht von einem an mehrere, sondern von einem an alle. Broadcast hat man im V6 komplett gestrichen. Weil das macht weder im lokalen Netz macht das Sinn, noch semantisch im gesamten Internet. Ich wüsste keine Applikationen, außer in den Null of Service Attacks, die spannend fänden, ein IP-Paket von einem Absender an alle Empfänger im Internet zu schicken.
Naja, die Spammer werden das bestimmt geil finden.
Ja, da gibt es, das wäre eine interessante Anwendung. Haben die sich aber gedacht, das ist blöd, aber jetzt haben sie also komplett abgeschafft. Also Podcast gibt es nicht mehr. Dann gibt es eine andere lustige Sache, die ist eine interessanter Geschichte. Es gibt einen sogenannten Anycast. Den gibt es auch schon im V4, der wird auch dort benutzt. Da kann ich gleich mal ein Beispiel erklären. Anycast heißt von einem an einen anderen, also ähnlich wie Unicast, aber an irgendeinen anderen.
Aber nur einen?
Aber nur einen.
Also irgendeiner darf das jetzt haben, aber nur einer?
Genau, also irgendeiner bestimmter, ich gebe schon eine gewisse Gruppe mit an, wenig der Intendiere, aber mir ist egal, wer von euch das macht. Stell dir vor, wie so ein Chef in den 60er Jahren, der so einen riesen Raum voller Sekretärinnen hat und der kommt in den Raum rein, wedelt mit seinem Diktaphone und sagt, mir scheißegal, irgendeiner von euch tippt das jetzt hier ab. So, ist jetzt ein blödes Beispiel, aber so ungefähr kann man sich das vorstellen. Ihm ist egal, wer das bearbeitet, aber ob da einer das macht. Das wird schon im V4 benutzt, zum Beispiel die Name-Server. Viele Name-Server, die großen Name-Server. Es gibt ja, wenn man sich das Name-Server-System anguckt, es gibt 13 sogenannte Root-Server, A bis K. Davon gibt es welche, die existieren wirklich nur einmal. G zum Beispiel glaube ich. G ist nur eine Maschine, die steht in einer Uni in den USA. Ein Rechner, eine Root-Server oder so. Und dann gibt es halt andere wie F oder K zum Beispiel. Das sind in Wirklichkeit hunderte von Rechnern, die auf der Welt verteilt sind, die alle dieselbe IP-Adresse haben. Und wenn man so ein Ding anspricht, ist mir scheißegal, ob jetzt der in Frankfurt antwortet oder der in Amsterdam oder in Düsseldorf, Berlin oder Tokio. Ich will halt, dass einer von denen soll mir antworten. Aber nicht alle. Deswegen mache ich ein Anycast-Schicke sozusagen. Irgendeiner wird das von denen kriegen. Wir beantworten, dann ist gut. Mir ist dann auch egal, welcher.
Aber man geht dann schon davon aus, dass dieselbe IP-Adresse mireren zugeordnet ist.
Ja, aber es geht. Du kannst halt, was in Effekt passiert ist, dass man sozusagen dieselbe Route existiert im Internet halt endmal. Und der Effekt, und das ist auch genau, den man erzielen will, ist, dass natürlich die Router optimieren das. Die geben dir sozusagen dann den nächsten. Ja, das ist, wie gesagt, ist ähnlich wie bei einer, wenn du im Telefonnetz eine 112 willst, ist das ein Anycast. Die ist eigentlich egal, mit welchem Notruf du redest. Das sollte ein möglichst einer sein, der dicht dran ist. Aber ob der im selben Ort ist oder am Nachbarort, ist dir egal. Du willst jetzt einen Notruf sprechen.
Geschieht das jetzt automatisch, weil der Router das weiß? Oder muss ich explizit sagen, dieses Paket soll im Anycast-Modus verschickt werden?
Das weiß der Router. Eine Anycast-Adresse ist nur semantisch unterschiedlich, aber sonst technisch gesehen ist es ein Unicast.
Okay, also es ist keine andere Art und Weise des Absendens, sondern es ist nur eine andere Art und Weise des Weiterleitens.
Eine andere Art und Weise des Weiterleitens und das Einverständnis oder das Verständnis, dass es diese Adresse mehrfach gibt, dass man sich jetzt nicht künstlich aufregt oder das künstlich unterdrückt, wenn man feststellt, was, wie, die gibt es einmal links und einmal rechts, das kann doch gar nicht sein, hier ist was falsch. Nein, es ist eine Anycast-Adresse, die darf sowohl links als auch rechts als auch oben als auch unten sein. Das ist okay.
Aber das Wissen darüber liegt sozusagen nur bei den Routern.
Ja, also für den Anwender ist das ganz normal. Aber das ist, wie gesagt, auch ein wichtiges Thema. Ja, dafür wird es ja gemacht. Wird halt aus Redundanz- und Lastverteilungsgründen gemacht, bei den Nameservern zum Beispiel, was ja meiner Meinung nach die größte Anwendung dafür ist. Jetzt muss man allerdings sagen, das ist auch ein bisschen beschränkt, weil du kannst zum Beispiel nur vernünftig UDP dafür benutzen, also nur ein datagrammorientiertes Protokoll. Weil du nie weißt, ob jetzt jedes Paket, was du da hinschickst, immer bei derselben Kiste landet. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt keinen intensiveren Dialog aufbauen. Das kann dir also passieren, dass du sozusagen stellst Frage 1, kriegst eine Antwort, stellst Frage 2 und beziehst sie hier zu Frage 1 und der sagt so, wie? Weil deine Frage 2 ist bei einer ganz anderen Kiste gelandet. Du kannst sozusagen keinen größeren Kontext etablieren und darüber einen größeren Dialog führen. Theoretisch ginge das, man kann auch TCP machen mit Anycast, das ist aber sehr...
Okay, aber diese Arten sollte man auf jeden Fall jetzt im Hinterkopf haben, um weiteres zu verstehen. Unicast, das normale A nach B, Multicast, von A nach viele Bs, Broadcast, das ist irgendwie an alle Bs, aber gibt's nicht mehr. Das ist so der Laut-Howard des Networking, der ist irgendwie verbannt worden. Wollte keiner mehr zuhören.
Weg das.
Und Unicast halt sozusagen, dass man eigentlich zu einem B schickt, aber es mehrere Bs gibt und man nicht genau weiß, welches konkrete Bs letztendlich es kriegt, aber halt nur eins.
Irgendeiner von denen. Das sind so die Adress- oder grundsätzlichen Adresstypen, die man denn dort hat. Dann unterscheidet man einen sogenannten Scope. Nämlich sozusagen in einem wie groß gearteten Raum, Adressraum oder geografischen Raum ist meine Adresse gültig. Das heißt also, gültig heißt mir zugewiesen und eindeutig. Habt ihr auf jeden Fall schon erwähnt, diese Link-Local-Adressen, die ich mir einfach sozusagen aus der Luft greifen kann, ohne mit irgendjemandem darüber zu diskutieren, haben einen Scope, der sagt, das darfst du aber nur direkt auf dem Draht machen, wo du mit jemandem anders redest. Das darfst du nicht darüber hinaus benutzen. Nur einen Scope, der ist sozusagen nur auf dem Link, nur auf dem Draht. Dann gibt es eigentlich, als sie angefangen haben mit V6, gab es mal eine Zeit lang sogenannte Site-Local-Adressen. Man sagt, okay, das sind jetzt Adressen, die kannst du innerhalb deiner Organisation benutzen, vielleicht auch jenseits von irgendwelchen Routern, wenn deine Organisation größer ist oder so, zwischen Standorten oder wie auch immer, aber nicht im Internet, also nicht global. Das hat man aber inzwischen weggelassen, diesen Scope, den gibt es doch nicht mehr. Und dann gibt es die globalen Adressen, also Adressen, die dir global zugeteilt und global eindeutig sind. Das heißt also weltweit eindeutig sind. Über ASP-Grenzen weg, über Röhre-Grenzen weg, Router-Grenzen weg, ist das deine eindeutige Adresse. Man braucht das eine, um an das andere ranzukommen. Ich will jetzt mal nicht zu sehr in die Details gehen, aber du hast angefragt, wie komme ich an so eine Adresse ran? Wenn ich mein Gerät anschalte, hat es ja wie gesagt eine Link-Local-Adresse. Das heißt, das hat schon mal eine Möglichkeit, auf einem Draht mit jemandem anders zu reden. Die hat es einfach. Und diese Adresse kann ich dazu benutzen, um einen Multicast loszutreten. Ich kann nämlich zum Beispiel fragen, es gibt Multicast-Adressen, die sind im Standard vorgegeben. Zum Beispiel gibt es eine Multicast-Adresse, die lautet alle Router in diesem Netz. Ein Router, der ein Router sein will, verpflichtet eine Multicast-Adresse, diese Multicast-Adresse zu bedienen, darauf Pakete zu empfangen und damit irgendwann anzustellen.
Was es bei V4 nicht gab, da waren irgendwie alle gleich.
Es gibt zwar dort auch eine All-Routers-Multicast-Adresse, aber es gab keinerlei Verpflichtung im Standard, die in irgendeiner Form zu bedienen oder damit was zu machen. Bei V6 ist es so. Bei V6 gibt es gar keine Frage. Wenn du Router bist, dann musst du Pakete, die an die Multicast-Adresse All-Routers gehen.
Teilweise ist V6 auch eigentlich nur das Enforcement von Sachen, die man sich früher schon mal dachte, das wäre wahrscheinlich eine gute Idee, was aber bis dahin noch keiner realisiert hat, dass das eine gute Idee war.
Oder nicht alle realisiert haben. Oder jeder Hersteller das anders gemacht hat. Bei V6 haben wir gesagt, das machen wir jetzt mal gerade.
Das heißt, ich kann mich jetzt exklusiv an die Router, also an die mit dem selben Netz verbundenen Devices, die mich mit anderen Netzen verbinden?
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die da sind. Weil noch hab ich ja nichts gesagt. Hab ich mich nur eingeschaltet, hab meine Link-Local-Adresse, die weiß ich jetzt. Und jetzt kann ich das einfach mal als Test so los treten. Kann so sagen, so hier alle Router, die hier so sind. Wenn hier jemand ist, sag doch mal Piep. Sag doch mal, ob ihr da seid. Wer so da ist, alles. Ja, ich bin übrigens hier Link-Local-Adresse so und so, als Absender, ja, und sag doch mal was. Und wenn so ein Router halt eben ein IPv6-Compliant-Router ist, dann antwortet er auch darauf. Dann macht er ein sogenanntes Router-Advertisement. Das macht er auch sowieso, periodisch, aber man kann ihn, wie gesagt, auch antreten. Das gibt es schön in Englisch über Soliciting. Kann das sozusagen Soliciting. Das heißt, kann selber sagen jetzt hier, wenn hier ein Router ist, sag doch mal Piep, mach doch mal dein Advertisement, ich bin jetzt da, ich kann das und das und so. Und dann macht er genau das. Und Teil dieses Router-Advertisements ist, dass er sozusagen die Clients in seinem Laden darüber aufklärt, wie die globale Situation so aussieht. Wie die Großwetterlage so ist. Er sagt, also ich bin ein Router, erstens ich existiere, ich bin hier, ich denke, also bin ich. Und übrigens Jungs, wir haben von unserem ISP folgenden Adressraum zugewiesen bekommen. Wir reden da von einem Präfix, also sozusagen wieder ein Teil dieser 128-bitigen Adresse. Nämlich im Falle von einem Ethernet, üblicherweise die ersten 64-Bit. Man kriegt sozusagen, der sagt, er brüllt auf sein Ethernet raus als Antwort in diesem Router-Advertisement und sagt, so Jungs, wer hier global mitspielen will, wir haben zugeteilt bekommen, über welche Mechanismen lassen wir jetzt mal aus und vor, wir haben zugeteilt bekommen folgende 64-Bit. Die letzten 64-Bit bildet ihr euch bitte selber. Hab ich keinen Bock drauf. Das ist auch zum Beispiel so ein Unterschied gegenüber dem DHCP-Mechanismus, wo jede einzelne Adresse einzeln verteilt wurde. Sondern der sagt halt einfach, pass mal auf, Kinder, wenn ihr im Internet global mitspielen wollt, hier habt ihr die ersten 64-Bit und die anderen 64-Bit, die bildet ihr euch bitte aus eurer MAC-Adresse oder sonst irgendwie oder würfelt, mir egal. Interessieren mich nicht. Da kommt dann dieser EUI64 identifiziert. Also man nimmt dann die MAC-Adresse und popelt diese ein bisschen auf, schiebt da noch so 16-Bits rein, damit das 64 werden. MAC-Adresse haben wir gesagt 48-Bits. Schiebt da noch so 16-Bits rein und invertiert ein anderes Bit. Ja, deswegen, wenn du genau hinschaust, wenn du dir mal die Link-Local-Adressen anschaust mit ifconfig und die mit deiner MAC-Adresse vergleichst, wirst du sehen, dass da genau ein Bit gekippt ist. Nämlich... Irgendein? Nee, das zweitniedrigste Bit aus dem ersten Byte.
Willst du die Story dazu hören?
Sicher, ich guck nur gerade.
Diese vorhin erwähnte MAC-Adresse, diese 48-Bit, man hat damals vorher gesehen, dass man sagt, man möchte vielleicht auch MAC-Adressen benutzen, die man sich selber ausdenkt, die man sich also nicht von der IEEE besorgt. Und man hat dort in diesen 48-Bit stecken vorne drin, in dem zweiten Bit des ersten Bytes, steckt ein Indikator drin, der dir sagt, ob diese IEEE-Ui von der IEEE zugewiesen wurde oder ob du dir die selber ausgedacht hast. Wenn diese Bit auf 0 ist, dann ist das von der IEEE eine zugewiesene MAC-Adresse. Wenn das Bit auf 1 ist, ist das eine selber ausgedachte Adresse. So, wenn man jetzt daraus sich jetzt eine V6-Adresse bildet, dann hat man immer so ein bisschen ein Problem, wenn da ein Automatismus am Start ist, können die Bits ja beliebig sein. So ein Rechner, dem ist ja völlig egal, ob das Nullen oder Einzen sind, oder wie lang die Adresse dann wird oder so, das ist ja vollkommen wurscht. Für den sind das 128 Bit. Wenn ein Mensch sowas macht, dann ist der aus verschiedenen Gründen dazu geneigt, möglichst viele Bits davon mit Nullen zu besetzen, weil er sich dann einfacher schreibt. Da kommen wir noch drauf, wenn wir uns unterhalten, wie man IPv6-Adressen aufschreibt. Da gibt es nämlich einen Mechanismus drin, mit dem man diese Nullen hinterher beim Schreiben wieder wegoptimieren kann. Ähnlich so, wie man in einer normalen Schriftsprache, wie wir sie benutzen, weil das ist die führende Nullen weg. Du sagst ja auch nicht, ich habe jetzt hier 0-0-1-0-0-D-Mark oder Euro erhalten. Sondern du sagst, ja, ich habe 100. Das ist die führende Nullen weg. Ähnliches gibt es eben auch. Da war natürlich genau verkehrt rum. Weil wenn ein Mensch sich selber eine IP-Adresse ausdenkt, die er irgendwo benutzen will, dann will er möglichst viele Nullen drin haben. Aber da wäre genau dieses Bit verkehrt rum gewesen. Weil bei der UEI 64-Generierung oder bei der OUI-Zuweisung muss dieses Bit nämlich auf 1 stehen, wenn du die Adresse selber ausdenkst. Deswegen haben sie das invertiert, damit es hinterher mehr Nullen hat. Damit es mehr Nullen hat. Kann man die Details im Wikipedia nachher inkludieren. Das hat jetzt keiner verstanden.
Ich wollte gerade mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen. Ich bin ein Computer, ich schalte mich ein. Ich habe ein Netzwerkinterface. Das Netzwerkinterface hat eine MAC-Adresse 48-Bit. Dann kann ich einfach irgendeinen Präfix mir nehmen.
Erstmal hast du die Link-Local-Adresse. Die Link-Local-Adresse bildest du auch mit dieser MAC-Adresse.
Das meine ich ja gerade. Ich bilde sie mir, indem ich den Präfix von das ist eine Link-Local-Adresse nehme. Also der sozusagen definiert ist. Das ist welcher?
Das ist dieser FE80.
Genau. FE80, ganz viele Nullen. Und dann baue ich da hinten irgendwie meine MAC-Adresse rein.
Die du, wie gesagt, vorher noch, wurde noch 16 Bits reingeschoben und eins umgekippt hast.
Genau, wo ich noch 16 Bits reinschiebe und eins davon noch irgendwie Kopputthämmer. Von den 16? Oder von den 48? Von den 48 genau noch eins irgendwie auf null setze. Und die kann ich dann einfach benutzen. Dann muss ich jetzt sozusagen anders als in der V4-Welt nicht erstmal losgehen und jemanden bitten, mir überhaupt irgendeine Adresse zu geben, damit ich überhaupt richtig kommunizieren kann. Sondern ich fange irgendwie erstmal gleich an und sag so, okay, Netz hab ich jetzt schon mal. Wie sieht es denn hier mit Internets aus? Irgendwelche Router da?
Kurze Intermission hier. Du solltest eine Sache machen, die ist aber meines Wissens glaube ich nicht verpflichtend. Du solltest, obwohl du eigentlich ja schon davon überzeugt bist, dass deine IP-Adresse eindeutig ist, weil sie, anstammt ja einer deiner Meinung nach, eindeutigen MAC-Adresse, solltest du so nett sein und eine sogenannte Duplicate IP-Adress Detection machen. Das heißt, du solltest so nett sein, um rauszufinden, ob es da draußen jemanden gibt, der rein zufällig doch die gleiche Adresse hat. Und wenn ja, sollst du den anderen ausdenken. Das machst du dadurch, indem du sozusagen einfach mal jemanden an den anschwätzt. Also du schwätzt dich selber an, bevor du dir selber die IP-Adresse gibst und benutzt, schwätzt du erstmal jemanden an. Oder schwätzt du die erstmal an und guckst mal, ob da jemand zurückkommt. Ja, das kommt vom Prinzip.
Aber wie kann ich sie denn anschwätzen, wenn ich selber noch gar keine habe?
Das ist der einzige Fall meines Wissens, wo du die Nuller-Adresse benutzt, also wo alle Bits null sind, die so viel heißt wie ich weiß nichts.
Aber wie kann ich denn dann darauf eine Antwort bekommen, wenn ich noch gar keine Adresse habe?
Ja, das liegt daran, dass da Multicast wieder im Spiel ist. Das heißt, es wird wieder ein Multicast-Adresse angesprochen und der wird auch wieder mit Multicast geantwortet und auf die Multicast-Adresse kannst du dich schon draufsetzen und draufhorchen. Also nochmal Duplicate Address Detection, DAD, ist ein Spiel, das brauchen wir später nochmal, wenn wir über temporäre Adressen oder so was reden. Aber eigentlich solltest du über Boot-Holz... Macht keine Sau, glaube ich. Aber man sollte, aber das macht kein Mensch. Ich habe es jetzt noch nicht so häufig gesehen in meinen Snoops. Kann aber auch sein, dass ich mal drüber hinweggucke. Weil die meisten Rechner, die ich benutze, haben denn schon irgendwelche Adressen, die sich ganz früh im Boot-Prozess holen und haben dann schon ihre Link-Local-Adresse etabliert, bevor ich irgendwie einen Packet-Snooper starten kann oder sonst irgendwas. Und ich will jetzt nicht rumlügen, aber eigentlich ist der Plan der, dass wenn du dir selber eine Adresse zuteilst, wie auch immer, dass du guckst, ob die vorher schon jemand hat. Selbst wenn es noch so unlikely ist, dass jemand anderes sie hat. Okay, aber lass mal kurz. Wir haben jetzt diese Link-Local-Adresse.
Wir können das ja mit einbauen. Also ich bilde mir diese Link-Local-Adresse, nachdem ich mich irgendwie versichert habe, dass es die nicht gibt. Entweder durch pure Annahme oder durch Überprüfung. So, dann schrei ich irgendwie, gibt es denn hier irgendwelche Router? Dann antworten wir vielleicht eins bis mehrere und sagen, ja, hier gibt es irgendwie einen Weg nach draußen und der heißt sowieso. Das heißt, er nennt mir quasi einen Präfix.
Nee, der sagt nicht der Heißt so und so. Der sagt, der Weg nach draußen, um den Weg nach draußen beschreiten zu können, müssen wir folgende Adressen benutzen.
Ja, das meinte ich.
Das ist so, wie wenn du am Flughafen durch den Gate gehaben wirst und da ist so ein blauer EU-Symbol drüber, solltest du einen EU-Pass haben, sonst nichts geht. Okay, Scheißvergleich.
Das war jetzt wirklich ein Scheißvergleich. Worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist, die unterscheiden sich. Also jeder hat was im Angebot und der Tunnel nach draußen. Also Tunnel ist vielleicht ein Wort, das wir hier nicht verwenden sollten in dem Zusammenhang. Also der Weg nach draußen ist halt mit einem Präfix verbunden. Ich kriege nicht eine fertige Adresse, sondern ich kriege einen Präfix. Das ist ja hier so ein wiederkehrendes Wort.
Die ersten 64-Bit-Adresse.
Genau, die erste Hälfte. So, und dem klatsche ich jetzt im Normalfall einfach dasselbe dran, was ich schon mal im Link Local rangeklatscht habe.
Die letzten 64-Bit. Das Ding nennt sich übrigens Interface Identifier. Die letzten 64-Bit sind Interface Identifier. Das ist übrigens auch zum Beispiel so ein Punkt, wo wir jetzt wieder bei V4, V6 unterschieden sind. Bei V4 war das ja so, die Größe hat man ja von erwähnt, als wir über Citroen gesprochen haben, die Größe deines Netzes, wie viele Bits gehören zu meinem Netz und wie viele Bits gehören zu meinem Interface Identifier oder zur Vorwahl und Rufnummern, war ja da variabel. Das kannst du auch immer noch spielen bei V6. Sie haben es nicht komplett verboten, aber dann funktionieren keine dieser Automatismen. Die gehen alle davon aus, dass du sagst, pass auf, wir haben hier ein Adressschema, das sieht so und so aus und das sagt halt auf dem Ethernet oder überhaupt auf dem lokalen Link, 64-Bit. Der Rest, dem kannst du deinen Interface Identifier machen. Und wenn du irgendetwas anderes spielen willst, wenn du irgendwelche anderen Annahmen treffen willst, was Netzgrößen so trifft, dann mach das von Hand. Dann wollen wir davon nichts wissen. Ja, dann geht auch vielerlei Zeug schief. Ich würde auch wirklich niemandem raten, damit zu experimentieren, aus welchen Gründen auch immer seinen Ethernet, also diesen Präfix irgendwie von dem Ethernet auf was anderes zu setzen als das 64. Das geht auf jeden Fall schief.
Wie ist denn überhaupt die Struktur der IPv6-Adressen? Ich meine 128 Bit, da passt eine Menge rein. Jetzt hast du ja gesagt, eine der Sachen, die man überarbeitet hat, ist die Art und Weise, wie Adressen verteilt und zugeteilt werden. Welcher Logik unterliegt denn jetzt das? Ist das immer noch nur noch irgendwie Netzwerk und Host? Oder ist da irgendwie was?
Na ja, es gibt mehrere Hierarchie-Ebenen, wie die Verteilung stattfindet. Du fängst halt an, dass erstmal wieder eine Regional Internet Registry, wie zum Beispiel Raipe was zugewiesen wurde, so ein Bereich, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie groß der ist, oder wo der überall steckt, aber ich sag jetzt mal, ich sag jetzt mal, irgendein Bereich 2001, IP-Adressen, IPv6-Adressen mit 2001 anfangen, sind europäische IP-Adressen. Hab ich ja hier auch. Ja, die haben noch mehr, die haben viel größere Bereiche. Ich müsste jetzt mir noch mal genau anschauen, aber ich setze mal ein Beispiel. Die gehen jetzt halt hin und verteilen die wieder unter an ISPs, die bei ihnen Sozialmitglieder sind. Also wenn jetzt hier bei so einem, nennen wir jetzt mal einen kleinen ISP, zum Beispiel unsere Freunde von Internetnet oder Snafu in Berlin, das ist ein kleinerer ISP. Die gehen halt eben hin und sagen, gibt uns IP-Adressen, sagen sie, hier habt ihr einen Präfix, die ersten 16 Bit, äh, entschuldigung, die ersten 32 Bit geben wir euch. Also 1 slash 32, den wird 1 slash 32 zugeteilt. Kann ich dir auch sagen, 2001 colon 1560 ist der, haben die. Ähm, wenn du so jemand bist wie eine Telekom oder sowas, deutsche Telekom, die haben riesen Adressbereich. Ich bin durch Zufall mal drauf gestoßen, die haben irgendwie einen slash 9 oder einen slash 10 oder 11. Also irgendwas war, also was denn sozusagen, muss man überlegen, du musst jetzt immer 128 abziehen, das heißt, die haben irgendwie über 100, 108 oder irgendwie, 110 Bits haben die oder 110 Bits oder 12 Bits haben die sozusagen diese benutzen können, um Adressen auf ihre Kunden zu verteilen. Die haben wahnsinnig viel Spaß.
Da ist ja schon wieder ein großer Teil dieses Adressraums schon wieder an eine Firma geopfert.
Nee, nee, da ist so viel Platz da oben. Also jedenfalls, ihr müsstet nochmal nachgucken, aber die haben jedenfalls irre große Dinger. Normalerweise kriegt so ein kleiner ISP einen slash 32 zugeteilt. Das ist sozusagen von 128 Bits sozusagen, legt die Regional Internet Registry, legt fest, die ersten 32 Bits sind hier so festgelegt, das bist du, mit dem Rest machst du es egal. Der ursprüngliche Plan sah vor, dass man sagt, okay, so ein ISP hat jetzt Kunden, an die er die IP-Adressen weiterverteilt. Und man hat gesagt, du gibst bitte jedem Kunden ein slash 48. Das heißt, jeder Kunde, so ein ISP, der so ein slash 32 zugeteilt hat, hat sozusagen 16 Bits, wo er seine Kundennummer reinmalen kann, also 65.000 Kunden. Und jeder Kunde kriegt von dir so ein slash 48. Das heißt, ein Kunde von den 128 Bits hat selber 80 Bits, mit denen er sich überlegen kann, was er damit macht. Und die Idee war, ich sage jetzt war, das hat sich ein bisschen geändert, die Idee war, dass der Kunde jetzt die nächsten 16 Bits nimmt, nämlich die von 48 bis 64, um sich zu entscheiden, welche seiner vielen Ethernetze er da bestückt. Also eine Slash-48-Zuteilung reicht auch für die größten Konzerne, weil die werden nicht mehr als 65.000 Ethernetz haben. Aber die waren damals so wahnsinnig, als sie das akkord haben gesagt, wir machen das als grundsätzliche Zuteilung. Ob du jetzt eine Oma bist, die jetzt nur von ihrem Enkel ein DSL-Router und ein Gerät zum Facetime-Geschenk gekriegt hat, oder nicht, hier hast du eine Slash-48, hast hier noch Bits, amuse dich damit. Das hat man inzwischen eingesehen, dass das ein bisschen doch zu exzessiv ist. Der Trend geht jetzt momentan dahin, dass man einem Kunden, was gibt, was ein bisschen größer ist als ein Slash-64. Also üblich, was so in der Planung ist, so Slash-56. Das heißt, der ISP, bei dem du jetzt mit deinem DSL-Router connectest, gibt dir von den 128 Bits, gibt er dir 72 vor.
Jetzt lässt er 72 über.
Quatsch, 56, 72 lässt er dir über. 56 gibt er dir vor. Das heißt, du kannst dann selber in deiner eigenen Infrastruktur zuhause, kannst du ohne weitere Nachfragen oder irgendwas, kannst du 256 Lans betreiben. Und in jedem Lan hast du dann 64 Bit. Was du nicht mal überlegen musst. Wie gesagt, doppelt so viele Bits sind, wie der gesamte Adressraum des IPv4 jetzt.
Aber warum gibt man denn überhaupt so viel? Ich meine, das ist doch völlig illusionär, dass irgendjemand so viel wirklich benötigt.
Nochmal, es geht nur um die Strukturen. Man sagt sich, wir haben die Bits und wir geben halt, je mehr wir davon rausgeben, desto einfacher können wir das strukturieren und desto besser können wir hingehen und die Leute sich organisieren lassen. Und desto einfacher ist es, auch Adressen zu generieren, die einfach eindeutig sind. Du kannst ja zum Beispiel, ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, diese Link-Local-Adresse wird normalerweise gebildet, wenn du ein Ethernet hast, indem du die Mecca-Adresse von der Ethernet-Karte benutzt oder so was. Aber wenn du sowas nicht hast, dann kannst du auch einfach würfeln. Die Chance, dass du, wenn du einen guten Zufallszahlen-Generator hast, dass du 64 Bits generierst, die irgendjemand anders auf dieser Welt gleichzeitig auch generiert hat, ist so verschwindend gering. Das ist, hast du da keine Probleme damit? Also nochmal, es ist jetzt vielleicht auch schwer zu folgen, wenn man dem zuhört von außen, gerade mit diesen Zahlen. Aber man muss sich halt wirklich überlegen, wie so diese Hierarchie runtergeht, wie das so aufgeteilt wird. Aber es ist trotzdem wichtig zu verstehen.
Es gibt verschiedene Hierarchieebenen, aber es ist gar nicht festgelegt, wie viele es gibt. Es ist nur festgelegt, dass es welche gibt.
Ja, es gibt schon welche, allerdings enden die natürlich daran, wo es in eine private Organisation reingeht und ich weiß, wie die innen drin aussieht. Also es ist einfach, wenn du die Hierarchieebene hast von der Rirre, also von RALP zum Beispiel, zu einem ISP in deinem Land, der dich als Kunden anschließt, die Adressen zuteilt und wenn du eine Einzelperson bist, wartet auch schon. Wenn du aber ein Siemens-Konzern bist, dann hast du da eine Oberabteilung, Hauptabteilung, Unterabteilung, Nebenabteilung und ein Team und die können sich sozusagen hinten über die letzten N-Bits dann kloppen, über die letzten 80 Bits, wie sie die aufteilen und wo sie da ihre Grenzen einziehen. Das ist denn deren Spiel. Da hast du von außen von der Standardisierung keinen Einblick. Aber man hat halt eben gesagt, in der Standardisierung von IPv6 hat man schon hingegangen, hat gesagt, pass auf, wir geben einem Kunden auf jeden Fall nicht bloß eine Adresse, wie es im V4 war. Wir geben ihm als aller, aller, aller kleinstes Minimum geben wir ihm 64 Bit. Du kannst eigentlich nichts zuteilen. Es gibt keine Zuteilungsmechanismen, die funktionieren, wenn du dem Kunden weniger als 64 Bit überlassen willst. Also die Hälfte, die Hälfte der 128 Bits. Es gibt auch ein paar ISPs, die schon vor sechs gemacht haben. Zum Beispiel meine Hassfreunde Comcast in den USA. Die machen das schon eine Weile. Die geben ihren Kunden auch nur einen 64. Aber das sind halt bei dem Minimum. Üblicherweise hat sich inzwischen die Erkenntnis eingebürgert, dass mal Leute auch mehr als ein Netz zu Hause haben. Was du hier auch kann man ja sagen, ist ja nicht geheim. Du hast ja auch ein normales Netz und ein Gästenetz. Also betreibst du zwei Netze. Da würdest du mit 1 slash 64 nicht hinkommen. Weil dann müsstest du nämlich diese Netze mit weniger als 64 Bit betreiben. Und dann passiert genau das, wie man sagte, funktioniert diese ganze Autodiscovery und Router. Und Router-Advertisement funktioniert halt nicht mehr. Das heißt, wenn du mehr als ein Netz betreiben willst, brauchst du mehr Bits. Man hat mal gesagt, wir wollen jetzt nicht hingehen und sagen, wir machen jetzt 62 Bits. Dann kann sich jeder zu Hause vier Netze legen. Sondern man hat genug davon. Dann kann man eben sagen, okay, 56. Das heißt, du hast acht Bits, die dir zugeteilt werden, die kannst du dafür benutzen, um deine Netze zu unterscheiden. Und dann hast du auf jedem deiner 256 Netze hast du halt 64 Bits, wo sich denn die Geräte darauf austoben können. Das ist so das, was sich so herauskristallisiert. Trotzdem eine ganz schöne Verschwindung. Anfänglich war es krasse. Anfänglich haben sie gesagt, auch normalen End-Usen slash 48. Das heißt, du hättest 65.536 Netze mit jeweils 64 Bit betreiben können. Das war der ursprüngliche Gedanke. Aber das haben sie dann doch überlegt. Das machen sie übrigens immer noch. Ich habe auch slash 48 von meinem Provider zu bekommen. Weil wenn du sozusagen eine Organisation bist und jetzt nicht wie ein einzelner DSL-User mit seinem PC zu Hause, dann macht das auch durchaus Sinn.
Also wie gesagt, 48 ist auch noch üblich. Als wir über die Vergabe geredet haben, war es ja so, mein Router erzählt mir, hier gibt ihr doch die Adresse selbst. Ich meine, wenn sich jetzt alle Geräte selber ihre Adresse selbst geben, per Zufall dann oder was? Oder einfach nur, indem die MAC-Adresse verwendet wird?
Sie nehmen den Präfix, der definiert die ersten 64-Bit-Adresse. Und sie nehmen halt ihren Interface-Identifier, nämlich die letzten 64-Bit, die auch schon in der Link-Local-Adresse drin stehen, und basteln sich da draußen eine globale Adresse.
Aber das ist doch das, wo die Aluhüte anfangen zu schreien, oder?
Genau, das ist das, wo die Aluhüte anfangen zu schreien. Wenn man sich das jetzt realisiert, stellt man fest, dass man auf so viele Arten und Weisen dort so unglaublich globally unik ist, dass Werbeleute oder sonst Leute, die darauf stehen, möglichst viel von dir zu erfahren, nasser Hosen kriegen. Weil so eine MAC-Adresse von so einer Ethernet-Karte ändert sich nicht. Damit ändert sich auch dein Interface Identifier nicht. Okay, du wechselst vielleicht mal deinen Wohnarbeitsplatz, wie auch immer, oder dein ISP teilt dir, wie im V4 üblich, jede Nacht eine neue Adresse oder in diesem Fall einen neuen Präfix zu. Aber das kann man ja weggucken. Man guckt einfach hinten rein in die letzten 64 Bit und stellt fest, dass das immer wieder selber Typ, der gerade eben noch auf Viewpoint geklickt hat, klickt jetzt irgendwie bei My Colorful Pony oder wie auch immer. Das ist ja das, wovon die träumen. Und das ist ja das, weswegen auch die Aluhüte dann sozusagen so ein bisschen aufs Dach gestiegen sind. Übrigens dazu noch ein wichtiger Punkt. Bei V4 hatten wir von diesem NAT-Thema besprochen. Das heißt, welche Geräte du in deinem lokalen Netz hast, wurde immer maskiert, sozusagen durch den Router, weil ja alles auf die eine IP-Adresse, die in der ISP zugeteilt hat, umgemappt wurde. Bei V6 gibt es in diesem Sinne kein NAT mehr. Macht auch keinen Sinn, ist auch böse, ist auch wirklich verpönt. Du kannst auch auf eine ITF-Veranstaltung hingehen, die dreimal im Jahr passiert, stellst dich in einen Raum rein von einer IPv6 Working Group und sagst, ich habe hier mal einen Vorschlag, wie man NAT machen könnte. Und dann rennst du. Also das ist wirklich ein extrem verpöntes Thema. Das heißt, die IP-Adressen, die deine Geräte haben intern, werden nicht mehr umgelogen. Das heißt, die sind auch nach außen hinsichtbar. Das heißt, man sieht auch außen, außerhalb deines DSL-Routers, zum Beispiel bei besuchten Webseiten, ob du die jetzt mit Gerät A oder B angefunkt hast. Man sieht sogar noch mehr. Du hast ja vorhin diese OUIs, die ersten 24-bit der MAC-Adressa schon geguckt. Da gibt es ja diese Tabelle. Man kann daraus zum Beispiel auch sehr viel schließen. Man kann zum Beispiel gucken, es gibt mehrere Dutzend Assignments, die sich Firma Apple dort hat. Und da ja die OUI-Bestandteil der MAC-Adresse ist und die MAC-Adresse Bestandteil des Interface Identifiers, kann man an einem IPv6 Interface Identifier, der so gebildet wurde, kann man halt nicht nur erkennen, ah, das ist der selbe Typ wie vorhin oder vor zwei Monaten, sondern man kann auch sagen, ah, ein Apple User. Das heißt, man sieht auch, was das für ein Gerät ist, was da am Start ist. Also von welchem Hersteller, sagen wir mal so, oder wer die Mac-Adresse vergeben hat.
Genau, also mit anderen Worten, man könnte irgendwie, egal über welchen Internetprovider, über welchen Weg, ich gehe über alle Webseiten hinweg, auf ewige Zeit immer wieder das auf mich zurückträgen, beziehungsweise ich, der immer vor demselben Gerät sitze und man weiß auch noch in etwa, was das für ein Gerät ist. Und vielleicht kriegt man, ja...
Ja, man kann ein iPhone von einem Mac unterscheiden und von einem Android-Tablet und ein PC und so.
Also die Web-Strings, die da noch rübergehen im HTTP, dann weiß man auch ziemlich genau, was es ist. Ja, das ist doch doof.
Ja, das ist blöd. Das ist komischerweise oder interessanterweise ist das erst Leuten relativ spät aufgefallen. Man würde jetzt ja meinen, dass das von die Leute, die IPv6s sich gedacht haben, ausgedacht haben in den 90ern, dass die schon mal auf den Trip gekommen sind, darüber nachzudenken. Das hat man ihnen aber sozusagen erst vor die Füße gelegt, als sie sozusagen fertig waren und mit großem Tadda auf die Bühne sprangen und sagten so, zack, so machen wir das jetzt. Und dann kam jemand, meinte so, privacy? Und dann waren sie so ein bisschen überrascht davon. Man hat also dann so nannte privacy extensions definiert. Das heißt, man hat also jetzt gesagt, okay, das ist ein Verhalten, was wir so nicht gut finden. Wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass man die Leute nicht an diesem Interface Identifier hinten erkennen kann oder wieder erkennen kann. Die einzige Möglichkeit, die du dazu hast, ist, den halt regelmäßig zu wechseln. Es liegt aber nur in deiner Verantwortung, weil der Router hat davon gesagt, pff, mir ist scheißegal, wenn du hinten in den letzten 64-Bit reinmalst. Für mich ist wichtig, dass du vorne einen richtigen Präfix dran hast. Und man wird sozusagen jetzt dem Endgerät überlassen, ob es seine Interface Identifier, die letzten 64-Bit, ob er den ändert oder nicht. Da gab es ja auch so ein bisschen Bohau. Gerade als diese Thematik von den Aluhüten entdeckte und auch veröffentlicht wurde oder verbreitet wurde. Da gab es zwar diese Privacy-Extensions noch, waren aber zum Beispiel in manchen Betriebssystemen nicht von Hause aus an. Ich glaube, in Mac aus X waren sie sogar in Snow Leopard noch nicht an. Die sind glaube ich erst seit Lion an. Egal. Jedenfalls kamen da ein paar Leute erst sehr spät mit aus dem Kniff. Auch in IOS, auf dem iPhone oder so. Das ist auch erst seit IOS 4 oder 5 von Hause aus an.
Was machen denn diese Extensions?
Diese Extensions machen einfach nichts weiter, als dass man gesagt hat, pass mal auf, du darfst ja ohnehin mehrere IP-Adressen haben. Der IPv6-Standard mandatiert ja, dass man sagt, du musst in der Lage sein, mehrere IP-Adressen verwalten zu können. Okay, hat man sich gesagt, wir machen Folgendes, du hast halt deine Link-Local-Adress, die musst du sowieso haben, sonst funktioniert das ganze Interface nicht richtig, weil du sonst mit keinen Routern und so reden kannst. Du hast dann eine globale IP-Adresse, die traditionell gebildet wurde mit einem Interface-Identifier, der konstant ist. Und du wählst dir noch zusätzlich so genannte temporäre IP-Adressen aus. Und zwar machst du die, das ist ein ganz wildes Verfahren, wie man sich die bildet. Und zwar, wenn man anfängt, sucht man sich die Zeit mit NTP-Zeitstempel, das sind 64-Bit, präpelt da noch irgendwie Teile seiner MAC-Adresse rein und macht da drüber dann irgendwie einen SH1-Hash, jedenfalls würfelt man sozusagen wild rum und würfelt sich sozusagen eine, eine IP-Adresse, diese 64-Bit hinten einfach aus. Der spannende Teil ist, das passiert automatisch und periodisch, das macht ein Betriebssystem. Wenn man mal nachguckt, auf dem MAC sind das zum Beispiel, macht das jeden Tag, jeden Tag würfelt er eine neue IP-Adresse aus. Und zwar macht er das so, die ist auch entsprechend markiert, auch in der Liste der Adressen, das ist eine temporäre IP-Adresse und die bleibt so lange bestehen, solange du sie noch benutzt. Also wenn du jetzt nochmal eine TCP-Verbindung aufmachst und einen Webstream oder sonst irgendwas und der ist noch in Benutzung, dann kann man eben natürlich nicht unter dem Arsch weg die Adresse ändern. Dann passiert Folgendes, dann wird eine neue generiert, dann hast du, wenn diese Zeit rum ist, dann kriegst du temporär eine vierte Adresse, die wird dann für alle neuen Verbindungen benutzt von da an und die alte Adresse bleibt noch so lange in deinem System bestehen, wie sie noch irgendjemand benutzt, also wie es noch irgendeinen Socket gibt, der darauf offen ist und den benutzt. Und wenn das nicht mehr der Fall ist, wird die weggeräumt. Das heißt, das wird sozusagen immer rumrotiert, werden immer neue Adressen generiert und die alten wieder rausgeschmissen, in dem Moment, wo sie nicht mehr benutzt werden, nach Ablauf einer gewissen Zeit. Und der Mac macht das zum Beispiel wie die meisten Unix-basierten Systeme so machen, nicht einmal am Tag. Kann man auch ändern, gibt ein Parameter, Systemparameter kannst du ändern, kannst du sozusagen alle Stunden eine neue IP-Adresse hast.
Das heißt der alte Fluch, dass ich irgendwie übernatt die ganze Zeit neue IP-Adressen bekomme, kehrt jetzt sozusagen wieder, weil das der Rechner selber macht?
Nein, du kannst das abstellen. Du kannst sagen, ich will das nicht. Mir ist das scheißegal, ob Facebook mich dreckt oder Google. Ich möchte gerne immer dieselbe IP-Adresse haben. Die hast du ja übrigens auch. Die ist zum Beispiel dann wichtig, wenn dich jemand ansprechen will. Wenn du einen Server betreibst oder irgendwas, ist ja blöde, wenn du jeden Tag deine IP-Adresse änderst. Das Thema haben wir ja im V4. Das heißt du hast dann sozusagen eine Adresse, die ist konstant, die wird aber normalerweise nicht für abgehende Verbindungen benutzt. Außer wenn eine Applikation das explizit will. Aber zum Beispiel dein Browser, mit dem du rumsurfst im Internet, nimmt, präferiert, immer eine temporäre Adresse, wenn eine da ist. Da gibt es bestimmt welche Default-Options oder sonst irgendwas, wo man das wieder abstellen kann, aber das normale Behavior dafür für so ein System ist, wenn ich eine temporäre Adresse habe, dann benutze ich die für abgehende Verbindungen. Und wie gesagt, die wird periodisch geändert. Üblicherweise einmal am Tag. Kann man aber, wie gesagt, auch ändern.
Oder auch häufiger.
Kann man ändern, du kannst da einen anderen Wert reinstellen.
Wenn er sich jetzt eine neue wählt, dann vergisst er die davor nicht sofort wieder und reagiert auch noch.
Der vergisst die davor dann, wenn sie nicht mehr in Benutzung ist. Aber wenn irgendjemand noch diese alte Verbindung benutzt für irgendetwas, weil da noch eine Verbindung drauf besteht, dann bleibt die noch so lange erhalten.
Ja, aber ich sehe hier ganz viele irgendwie gerade Adressen, die hier temporär sind, aber deprecated sind.
Ja, temporär, deprecated sind. Ja, ich bin eine temporäre Adresse, aber ich soll nicht mehr benutzt werden, bitte, weil ich eigentlich gibt es schon eine neue.
Ja, aber dann merkt sie sich noch für den Fall, dass noch was reinkommt.
Oder dass noch eine Verbindung steht. Kann ja sein, dass du irgendwelche Clients hast, die irgendwelche Software, die da drauf ist, die diese alte Verbindung noch benutzt. Wenn du also da mal deinen Mit-Netz-Stand minus AN, die du immer anguckst, was du also für Verbindungen hast, dann findest du auch welche, die diese alten Adressen noch benutzen. Also es ist sozusagen ein dauerndes Kommen und Gehen. Wenn man sich erklären würde, du ziehst hier dauernd immer andere Klamottenanwender aus dem Haus, gehst. Das macht man wie gesagt künstlich, ohne sich die Probleme damit einzuhandeln, die man im V4 hat. Weil im V4 war das zum Beispiel ein Problem, wenn du einen Dienst selber betreiben willst, wenn du einen Webserver betreiben willst, ist es halt blöd, wenn der dauernd immer seine IP-Adresse ändert. Aber dadurch, dass du im V6 mehrere IP-Adressen hast, hast du sozusagen eine, die ist immer konstant, damit du dort schön deine Dienste betreiben, damit man dich darauf erreichen kann. Und eine Adresse, die du benutzt, um rauszuzuführen. Kann man ein schönes anderes Beispiel nehmen?
Aber der prefix bleibt ja sozusagen immer gleich.
Ja, komm mal gleich noch drauf. Aber ich will nur ein schönes anderes Gleichnis stellen. Dafür rennst du mit zwei Handys rum. Du hast einerseits deine Vertragskarte mit einer festen Rufnummer, auf der nimmst du nur Rufe entgegen. Und wenn du selber Anrufe machst, dann nimmst du so ein Burner-Cell, also so eine Prepaid-Karte, die du jeden Tag wegschmeißt und jeden Tag eine andere Prepaid-Karte einlegst. Das ist so ungefähr der vergleichbare Fall dafür. Das heißt, du bist erreichbar unter deiner Nummer. Aber selber, wenn du abgehende Rufe machst, hast du jeden Tag eine Anrufnummer.
Verstehe.
So kann man sich das vorstellen.
Das heißt, die ganzen Trecker könnten dann allerdings immer noch nach diesem prefix unterscheiden und davon ausgehen, dass die meisten Leute zuhause dann doch eher nur so ein oder zwei, drei Rechner im Betrieb haben und häufig vielleicht auch alleine einzelne Nutzer dieses Netzbettennetzes sind. Ist schon eine zielgerichtete Zuordnung möglich, als das derzeit der Fall ist?
Niemand sagt ja, dass dein ISP nicht nach wie vor alle 24 Stunden deine DSL-Verbindung kappt und dir danach einen neuen Präfix zuweist.
Was vorher nur eine IP-Adresse war, ist jetzt sozusagen ein Präfix, der sich genauso ändern kann. Also in dem Sinne verschlimmert sich nichts.
Ja, ist interessant, weil als diese ganze Idee aufkam, schrieben natürlich die ganzen Nerds, geil, endlich mal feste IP-Adressen, lalala, tralala, pipapo. Und jetzt sind die alle Hütte aufgetaucht und jetzt wurden Provider, die eigentlich ursprünglich dazu gedacht haben, wir haben jetzt hier noch Adressen, wir heben jetzt einfach jedem seinen Präfix und dann ist gut, wurden sozusagen wieder dazu genötigt, aus diesen Privacy-Gründen künstlich wieder sozusagen eine Trennung einzuführen, den Leuten wieder neue Präfixe zuzuweisen. Das kann man übrigens auch anders machen. Also IPv6 ist auch in der Lage, ohne dass man jetzt die DSL immer kappt und wieder von vorne anfängt, auch neue Adressen zuzuweisen. Das ist übrigens auch noch so ein Punkt. Die Mechanismen, die da in place sind, erlauben eine Rekonfiguration eines Netzes zur Laufzeit. Also Beispiel, ich hab jetzt mein Netz aufgeworrt, hab da meine Rechner drin und hab jetzt, sagen wir mal, eine Fritzbox mit meinem T-Online dahinter. Wenn du deinen Provider gewechselt hast, früher hast du deinen Router ausgewechselt und hat alles hoch und runter gefahren und deine Adressen neu konfiguriert, das machst du heute nicht mehr. Heute würde man hingehen und sich einen zweiten Provider dazu nehmen. Nehmen wir mal und einen Provider XY. Von dem kriege ich auch noch einen Router, den klemme ich einfach dazu. Den klemme ich nicht anstelle meines bisherigen. Den klemme ich dazu. Ich habe jetzt zwei Router in einem Netz. Und jeder von denen kriegt von seinem jeweiligen ISP, an dem er hängt, einen Präfix zugewiesen. Und beide Router sagen, Hallo alle Leute, die hier im LAN sind. Ich bin hier, ich bin Router und wir spielen heute mit folgendem Präfix oder mit folgendem Set von Präfixen. Aber egal, also wir spielen heute mit folgendem Präfix. Das heißt, so ein Endgerät, so ein armer kleiner Mac, der da im LAN hängt, hat plötzlich zwei Router, die ihn vollquatschen und zwei Präfixe. Und was macht er? Er macht genau das selbe, was er mit dem ersten macht, macht er mit dem zweiten auch noch mal. Das heißt, du generiert wieder eine globale IP-Adresse aus dem Präfix des zweiten Routers mit dem Interface Identifier und er generiert wieder eine temporäre mit dem zweiten Präfix. Das heißt, du hast, wenn du vorher nur drei Adressen hattest, hast du jetzt fünf. Nämlich Link-Local, Global-Private und Global-Temporary von dem einen Provider und Global-Private und Global-Temporary von dem anderen Provider. Da kommt jetzt diese Limitation her, die ich vorhin sagte, dass da aus Gründen, dass man sagt, man will ja nicht beliebig viele Ressourcen verschwenden, dass da so, man begrenzt auf 16 oder so, aber der Standard lässt das offen. So, das kannst du in der Laufzeit machen. Du musst deinen Rechner nicht booten. Selbst wenn das ein Windows-PC ist, musst du ihn nicht booten. Der kann zur Laufzeit neue Präfixe lernen. Und der kann auch zur Laufzeit Präfixe wieder fernlernen. Das heißt, wenn du diese Setup gemacht hast, hast du jetzt von deinem neuen Provider den Router dahin, das läuft alle tuffig, und dann sagst du, okay, eine Woche später, jetzt rufst du einfach den Router weg, den ersten, von dem ersten Provider.
Woher weiß ich denn, dass er den neuen dann auch schon benutzt?
Ja, aber du rufst jetzt den alten weg, kannst zur Laufzeit, ohne dass du irgendwas booten musst, und zwar egal, ob es ein Windows-PC, ein Mac oder ein iPhone oder ein Kühlschrank ist oder eine Glühlampe, das muss die so supporten. Das ist Standard, da kommst du nicht dran vorbei. Du musst diese Geschichten zur Laufzeit ändern können, dass du sozusagen deine Präfixe dort änderst. Natürlich werden Verbindungen, die du offen hast, wenn du jetzt eine offene TCP-Verbindung hast oder ein Streaming, der aus dem Telekom-Link, aus dem ersten rausgeht, und du schaltest den Telekom-Router ab, natürlich bricht der ab. Aber du verlierst nicht die Konnektivität. Wenn du in dem Moment dann den wieder re-etablierst, also eine neue Verbindung machst, geht die über den neuen Provider und fertig. Oder dass du irgendwas gebootet oder re-konfiguriert, oder dass der Benutzer auch nur irgendwas gemacht hat. Das passiert sozusagen voll automatisch damit. Und das sind so Geschichten, muss man auch verstehen, in einem globaleren Kontext. Ich erzähle das jetzt immer so ein bisschen in dem Heimnetzwerk-Kontext. Aber wenn du dir das mal überlegst, es gab ja früher schon größere Organisationen, entweder Server-Betreiber oder ich sage jetzt mal so Firmennetze. In der Frühzeit des Internets, die Firmennetze, da war es durchaus Usus, wenn du groß genug warst, hast du dir den Luxus geleistet, zwei ISPs zu haben. Das heißt, du hattest einen Adressbereich, aber zwei ISPs. Das heißt, beide ISPs haben dann gesagt ins Internet raus, hallo, ich kenne den Weg zu 192.42.23.0.24. Und man hat sozusagen denselben Adressraum benutzt. Sowas gibt es im IPv6 eigentlich nicht mehr. Es gibt eigentlich keinen privaten Adressraum mehr in dem Sinne. Sondern du kriegst den Präfix von dem Provider, bei dem du bist. Du kannst beliebig viele Provider haben. Zwei, drei, vier, fünf, n. Ja, und einen kündigen, den neu machen. Du erbst sozusagen die Gesamtheit dieser Präfixe, die von denen kommen. Verwurzest du sie in jedes Endgerät, nimmt die auch auf in sich und verarbeitet die, um sich daraus Adressen zu generieren, die er benutzt. Und du kannst sie beliebig an- und abschalten. Klar, wenn Verbindungen gerade drüber laufen, schaltest du es ab, gehen die kaputt, aber wenn du eine neue Verbindung wieder aufmachst, nimmst du einen anderen Weg.
Aber die Adressen haben jetzt keinerlei Priorität oder so, die Präfixe. Ich meine, wenn jetzt mein Rechner zwei global gültige Adresspräfixe jetzt bekommt und er kann ja selber sehen, dass er sozusagen über mehr als ein Outlet rausgeht, weiß nicht, wie das für die Zukunft gedacht ist, dass man dann irgendwie so ein Fenster hochkriegt mit über welchen, durch welche Brücke willst du gehen irgendwie.
Das ist einer der spannenden Themen bei IPv6. Da steckt auch sehr viel Logik drin. Er hat ja vorhin erwähnt, dass man versucht, sehr viel Intelligenz von dem ganzen Zeug aus dem Router, wo es früher war, rauszuschieben in den Client. Die sogenannte Address-Selection. Also wenn ich jetzt ein Zoo von Adressen habe, welche benutze ich, wofür? Das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, da kommen wir auch gleich noch drauf. Man hat diese Geschichte nochmal ein bisschen erweitert. So ein Router kann in seinem Router-Advertisement auch so ein Finger heben und sagen, benutze mal mich, priorisiere mich mal. Das eröffnet natürlich auch wieder Tür und Tor für den Service und la la la, aber die Idee ist, dass man sozusagen hinhängt, du hast einen ISP und das ist alles toll, und jetzt willst du den wechseln, steckst den zweiten Router dazu, sagst dem, du löst jetzt einen anderen ab, dann sagt der, priorisiere mich, und dann kann man den ersten abreißen. So ein Router kann sagen, ich nehme gerne Arbeit entgegen, lieber als mein Kollege. Das sagt der aber unkoordiniert, deswegen ist es sicherheitsmäßig nicht so, dass die beiden Router sich erst miteinander austauschen, sagen, wer bist du? Telekom, VDSL, und der andere sagt, oh, ich bin nur L, es ist 16 Megabit, aber die koordinieren sich nicht.
Das ist andersherum nicht besser, dass der Router von sich aus sagt, ich bin jetzt hier deprecated, wenn du mich jetzt benutzt, dann geht das auch.
Ich bin jetzt immer von dummen Home-Routern ausgegangen, wo du sozusagen den einfach abschaltest. Aber wenn man den real sieht, wenn man so einen Firmenrouter hat, so einen Cisco-Router oder so, und du konfigurierst da, den schaltest du ja nicht ab und schmeißt den weg, sondern du konfigurierst den um. Und dann ist der so nett und sagt in seinen Router-Advertisement, so diese Präfix übrigens, erstmal gibt man eine Lifetime mit an, wenn ich Router bin und einen Präfix annonziere, sozusagen hier benutzt man das immer, das gilt für so und so lange, dass nicht ewig der Elefant im Raum stehen bleibt. Und zweitens kann er auch explizit so ein Router-Advertisement auch wieder zurückziehen. Er kann also sagen, so ich gehe denn jetzt mal.
So, tschüss, war das nur Spaß.
Ja, oder es macht man zum Beispiel auch dann, wenn zum Beispiel so ein Router seinen ablinkt, also sozusagen das Kabel ins Internet, wenn er merkt, das funktioniert nicht, da ist jetzt Linkdown, Stromausfall, wird es sich sonst umwandt. Das kann er auch von sich aus sagen, so ja, ich bin zwar noch da, ich bin noch ein Router, aber momentan ist meine Konnektivität nach draußen nicht so golden. Wenn es da noch jemand anderes gibt, dann geht doch mal lieber dahin. Aber nochmal, der wichtige Teil, aber der Verständnis davon, sowas gab es früher auch schon. Wenn jetzt Leute wiederkommen, sagen, aber ich habe da schon Routing-Protokolle, man könnte doch RIP anmachen. Aber das kann, das konnte eine IPv4 betriebene Glühlampe, kann das nicht. Bei v6 sind diese Sachen einfach voll schlimm. Du bist nicht v6-compliant, wenn du nicht als Client diese Minimumspiele regeln kannst. Punkt, Ende, aus. Das bedeutet, wie gesagt, mehrere Router, mehrere Präfixe, sowas musst du können, sonst darfst du nicht mit dir spielen. Jedenfalls nicht mit dem offiziellen Label, ich bin IPv6-compliant. So, interessant ist zum Beispiel, also du hast gefragt, woher will ich aus, wenn ich wenig benutze. Die Antwort ist in einem Falle relativ einfach, nämlich wenn ich zum Beispiel ein Server bin, der bei mehreren ISPs dranhängt, dementsprechend viele Präfixe hat, dementsprechend viele globale Adressen hat. Der wird ja von außen angesprochen. Und der leitet seine Antwortpakete einfach über den Router zurück, der ihm den Präfix zugeteilt hat, auf dem er angesprochen wurde. Also selbe Weg raus wie rein, fertig, easy peasy. Bei abgehenden Verbindungen ist es sehr spannend, weil du kannst wie gesagt einen ganzen Zoo von Adressen drauf haben auf deinem Interface. Und da gibt es wieder den einfachen Fall, nämlich die Applikation gibt es vor. Wenn du spezielle Server-Protokolle hast oder irgendwas, kannst du sagen, ich möchte gerne, wenn ich rausgehe, abgehende Verbindungen von folgender IP-Adresse machen. Dann ist das Thema für den Colonel auch einfach. Schwieriger wird es bei diesen Applikationen, wie zum Beispiel am normalen Brose, der einfach nur sagt, mir scheißegal, was ich für eine Adresse habe, ich will mit dem da drüben reden, macht das mal klar lieber Colonel. Und dann gibt es da so eine Adresse-Selection, dann gibt es da Mechanismen, die die Adressen durchgehen, sagen, was ist das für eine Adresse? Also erstmal Link-Local kann ich nicht benutzen, um uns raus zu sein. Site-Local gab es früher mal, kann ich nicht benutzen. Ulas kann ich benutzen. Was war Ulas? Ah, Unique-Local-Adresses. Kommen wir gleich noch. Sollten wir nochmal kurz erwähnen.
Hat man glaube ich noch nicht erwähnt.
Oder zum Beispiel, was wir auch noch nicht erwähnt hatten, war ein Tunnel. Du kannst ja auch deinen IP-Adressverkehr über bestimmte Tunnel bekommen. Das kann man der Adresse ansehen, dass sie sozusagen kein echtes IPv6 ist, sondern dass es nur IPv6 ist, was über V4 getunnelt wird. Das weiß der Colonel auch. Oder die Libraries. Das heißt, so ein Browser kann sagen, okay, ich hab zwar eine IPv6-Adresse, aber die wird eh bloß über V4 getunnelt. Also kann ich auch, wenn mein Ziel eine V4-Adresse hat, kann ich auch gleich die V4-Adresse benutzen, anstatt noch mal eine Schicht dazwischen zu schieben. Das heißt, in dem Falle wird zum Beispiel auch eine V4-Adresse präferiert. Womit wir bei dem Thema sind, wenn wir über Adresse-Selection reden, also welche Adresse benutze ich für abgehende Verbindung, kommt ja noch in dieser Zeit, wo es noch beide Protokolle nebeneinander gibt, gibt ja noch die Frage dazu für so ein Browser, wenn ich jetzt www.facebook.com eingebe, benutze ich jetzt V4, benutze ich jetzt V6, wenn ja, welche V6-Adresse und so weiter. Da gibt es halt verschiedene Strategien, die gehen sogar, die sind auch nicht exakt festgelegt in den Standards. Das merkt man darin, dass zum Beispiel so eine, die Firma Apple hat sich überlegt, sie macht das so richtig dynamisch. Wenn du mit deinem Browser eine Site ansprichst, die sowohl V4 als auch V6 hat, und du hast selber auch beides, dann probiert der Browser, nicht der Browser, dann probiert irgendwelche Libraries, irgendwelche Frameworks und der Kernel, probieren zusammen aus, was dann davon am besten funktioniert. Das heißt, die hauen erst mal ein paar Request raus mit V6 und dann hauen sie noch mal einen mit V4 raus oder zwei und dann gucken, ah, okay, der auf V4 antwortet schneller, dann nehmen wir V4.
Das heißt, wenn ich eine Webseite ansurfe und da sind dann wiederum Bilder, sonstige Sachen, dann nimmt er mal V4, mal V6.
Und irgendwann entscheidet er sich, nimmt er nur noch das eine. Und zwar weil er sich die, wie gesagt, der probiert die aus, er probiert die aus, welche davon am besten funktionieren. Also nicht nur welche davon überhaupt funktionieren. Das war früher, dass man gesagt hat, man probiert halt, die ursprüngliche Strategie war, wenn ich V6 habe und der drüben hat auch V6, nehme ich V6. Inzwischen ist die Strategie so, dass man sagt, weil man halt, wie Steve sagen würde so, das Erleben, das Erlebnis für den Benutzer muss halt geil sein. Sind halt eben hingegangen, haben gesagt, okay, ja, es gibt V6, es gibt auch schon ein paar Provider und so und die das machen, aber manchmal wird das getunnelt oder das ist halt performance-mäßig nicht so geil. Dann wollen wir die...
Oder der Klassiker ist, dass halt irgendwelche Server einfach eine V6-Adresse mal so eintragen, weil der Admin der Meinung ist, oh ja, V6 haben wir ja sogar drauf, aber dann dieser Web-Server, der darüber erreicht ist, gar nicht auf V6 lauscht. Das hatte das häufiger, dass ich hier so bei IPv6-Tunnel eingeführt habe und auf einmal waren einfach bestimmte Webseiten nicht mehr zu erreichen, weil dann der Browser gesagt hat, oh prima, hier V6, gibt es auch eine Adresse, nehme ich das modern und kam dann aber nicht mehr zum Ziel, dann habe ich V6 ausgeschaltet, bumm. Genau.
Wir hätten ein bisschen warten müssen, die meisten haben halt eben. Aber das war trotzdem nur diese, wie schnell, also geht es oder geht es nicht, und dann wurden so Timeouts abgewartet. Inzwischen ist es wie gesagt so, man feuert aus allen Rohren, guckt, was am besten funktioniert und merkt sich das und fährt dann darauf weiter. Aber wie gesagt, dasselbe, wie gesagt, Adressselection, du guckst, native Adressen, also welche, die nicht mehr in den Tunnel kommen, werden präferiert gegenüber anderen. Dann kommt wie gesagt dieser Präferenzfleck, was ein Router mitschicken kann, wo er sagt, hier nehme ich noch mal eher als meine Kumpel, kommt mit ins Spiel und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln vor allen Dingen, weil das auch nicht exakt in den Standards beschrieben ist, sondern das macht halt jeder, so wie er es für seine Implementation gerne am schönsten findet. Und das ändert sich auch, wie gesagt, dieses ganze Behavior hat sich geändert bei Mac OS X in den letzten, also seit Snow Leopard hat sich dort wahnsinnig viel getan.
Bevor wir auf Tunnel nochmal kommen, glaube ich, da müssen wir auf jeden Fall nochmal drüber sprechen. Haben wir denn jetzt diesen ganzen Bereich, wie redet mein Rechner im Netz mit Routern und anderen? Du hast ja auch mal gesagt, hier Multicast, da gibt es so verschiedene Gruppen von Devices. Ich kann alle Router ansprechen, etc.
All Nodes, ich kann auch mit allen IPv6-Sprechern reden. Das ist fast so was wie ein Broadcast, aber man sagt halt nicht alle Leute, die einem Draht hängen, sondern alle Leute, die mich verstehen können. Und es gibt auch noch andere Multicast-Adressen.
Also man kann so seine Nachbarn da irgendwie finden?
Ja, man muss mal grundsätzlich noch mal kurz einsteigen, wie funktioniert ein Ethernet? Ethernet ist relativ einfach. Man hat von diesen erwähnten 48-Bit-Adressen, haben wir wieder als Sender und als Empfänger. Früher war ein Ethernet ein Kabel. Da hängen alle dran, so dick wie ein Gartenschlauch, das Ding, Yellow Cable. Später wurde es ein bisschen dünner, so für Time-Netzwerke, BNC-Stecker dran und so. Das war aber alles ein Kabel. Das heißt, was dich auf dieses Kabel rausgebrüllt hat, haben eh alle gehört, die da dran waren. Dann fing man halt irgendwann an, das ein bisschen zu optimieren, indem man halt Switches eingeführt hat. Also eine sternförmige Topologie, also nicht mehr ein Bus, sondern ein Stern. Und dieser Switch hat versucht, möglichst schlau zu sein, indem er sozusagen bei einer Kommunikation zwischen A und B C, D, E, F gar nicht behelligt hat. Der Switch findet also raus, an welchem Port von ihm oder hinter welchem Port hängen welche MAC-Adressen. Und wenn man jetzt ein Internetpaket schickt an eine dieser MAC-Adressen, schickt er das halt aus dem Port hinten raus.
Aber bei Broadcast muss er dann trotzdem...
Bei Broadcast hat das aus allen rausgeblasen. Bei Multicast ist es jetzt ganz tricky. Multicast auf einem Doof-Switch, wie den sozusagen im Saturn kaufst, so ein nettgeher Switch für 20 Euro oder sonst irgendwas, der haut Multicast auch einfach aus allen Ports raus. Was, wie gesagt, durchaus eine Belästigung darstellt für Unbeteiligte. Du hast es ja hier auch schon erlebt, wenn du hier fett rumgemulticastet hast, dann sind plötzlich deine Drucker oder sonst irgendwelche Dinge hinten übergekullert. Weil die halt eben Pakete kriegen, die eigentlich gar nicht an sie adressiert sind. Aber die trotzdem zumindest erst mal angucken müssen, um festzustellen, das sind ja gar nicht meine. Das stellt dir vor, wie du hast einen kleinen, normalen Briefkasten und jeden Tag stellt dir einer einen Container mit Papier vor die Tür und du musst immer nachgucken, ist da jetzt was für mich drin oder ist das Alt-Plus-Werbung?
Ich hab mir meine Kleinstgeräte gedidost sozusagen.
Die Glühlampe haben angefangen zu glühen. So. Das heißt ein moderner Switch versucht rauszufinden, wer ist jetzt eigentlich an welchen Multicards interessiert. Wer gehört eigentlich zu welcher Gruppe. und auch wegen höherleveliger Mechanismen muss ein Gerät, was am Multicard teilnimmt, zumindest mal ein paar Leute erzählen. Da muss zum Beispiel Leute auf seinem Link erzählen. Hallo, bin hier, bin es da und ich interessiere mich für Multicards an folgende Gruppen. Da gibt es ein Protokoll, was es schon zu IPv4-Zeiten gab. Was dort in mannigfaltigen Versionen vorliegt, ist IGMP, das Internet Group Message Protokoll, worüber einen Not sagen kann, ich nehme jetzt an dieser Gruppe teil. Also nach dem Motto, schickt mir, wenn ihr was dahinschickt, schickt es mir auch. Interessiert mich. Oder ich interessiere mich dafür nicht mehr. So ähnlich wie so eine Mailinglist. So Subscribed und Unsubscribed gibt es da so Mechanismen. Das nennt sich nur Join und Anjoin. Join und Leave. Join und Leave heißen die Mechanismen. Das heißt, man tritt einer Gruppe bei, kriegt dann plötzlich den Verkehr für die und beim Leave kriegt man sie nicht mehr. Das ist ein bisschen komplexer, das Thema, aber wollen wir dabei mal lassen. Ein moderner Switch hört diese Dinger mit.
Obwohl er schickt dann sozusagen gar keinen Multicast, wenn man nicht vorher gesagt hat, dass es in das Interesse ist.
Es gibt so ein paar Multicasts, die zum Beispiel diese All-Notes-Multicast, wo jemand sagt, das geht eh an alle oder fast alle. Die kriegst du aber bei den anderen Sachen nur dann, wenn du vorher gesagt hast, du willst sie haben.
Also sozusagen ein Opt-in-Verfahren.
Ja, sehr gut. Das ist ein Opt-in-Verfahren. Das heißt, denn das passiert auch automatisch, das muss eine Applikation nicht machen, das macht der Colonel für dich. Wenn du als Applikation schreibst, die sich auf eine Multicast-Gruppe drauf setzt und darauf horcht, also ein Socket aufmacht, für ein Multicast-Socket aufmacht und darauf horcht, dann sendet der Colonel automatisch diesen IGMP-Join. Und wenn deine Applikation den Socket zumacht oder zum Beispiel stirbt oder weggeschossen wird oder wie auch immer, geht der Socket ja zu, dann macht der automatisch seinen Leave. Außer wenn es noch jemand anderes gibt auf deinem Rechner, der das auch hören möchte.
Gibt es da auch ein Timeout drauf, musst du das regelmäßig erneuern?
Ja, musst du das regelmäßig immer wieder erneuern und man muss auch, wenn jemand danach fragt, man kann das auch wieder solicitieren, man kann also sagen ey, hallo, interessiert sich jemand für den Scheiß, den ich hier erzähle? Soweit gibt es auch. Aber das sind so die Mechanismen dabei.
Ja, das ist durchaus auch eine Technologie. Da kann man auch was fürs soziale Leben beilernen, wenn man sich mit solchen Protokollen beschäftigt hat. Es gibt auch so Leute, die solche Nachrichten einfach einem immer so zustellen, obwohl man sie manchmal gar nicht haben will. Und die ganzen Announcements, die man so von sich gibt, werden einfach ignoriert.
So verwaltet sich zumindest diese Multicast-Szene. Da kann man wirklich stundenlang darüber diskutieren, wie das funktioniert. Für Multicast werden spezielle MAC-Adressen benutzt.
Das heißt, IPv6 macht auch diese ganze Multicast-Realität besser, weil auch hier wieder mehr vorgeschrieben ist?
Ja, die Mechanismen in V4, wenn man Multicast benutzt, sind sehr gut vorgeschrieben. Aber es ist nicht vorgeschrieben, dass du Multicast unterstützen oder benutzen musst. Bei V6 geht es gar nicht anders. Das liegt daran, dass grundlegende Mechanismen, wie zum Beispiel wie finde ich meinen Router, basieren auf Multicast. Wenn du das nicht kannst, kannst du deinen Router nicht finden, dann kannst du das auch stecken. Dann brauchst du auch mit gar keinem reden. Oder mit irgendjemand anderem. Die sogenannte Neighbor Discovery ist ja ein Thema. Wenn ich auf einem Internet bin und da sind N-Rechner drauf, ich möchte jetzt mit denen reden, wie finde ich die eigentlich. Finden im Sinne von, wie finde ich deren Internetadresse raus. Ich muss ja, hab ja nur die IP-Adresse. Ist mal in diesem Fall egal, ob V4 oder V6. Ich weiß, mit dieser IP-Adresse möchte ich reden. Und damit ich den ansprechen kann im Ethernet, muss ich dessen Adresse wissen. Ich kann nicht mehr wie früher in das Rohr einfach reinbrüllen. Das ist ein Ur-Ethernet. Wie ich vorhin sagte, ich schick das Paket einfach raus. Das kriegen eh alle. Und der, den es angeht, der wird damit schon was anstellen. Sondern da ist jetzt ein schlauer Switch dazwischen. Der schickt es nur dann dorthin, wenn ich auch genauer sage, wo es hin soll. Das heißt, ich muss rausfinden bei gegebener IP-Adresse, was hat mein Ziel für eine Ethernet-Adresse. Bei V4 hat man das später draufgestrickt. Klar, weil IPv4 wurde erfunden, dann gab es noch kein Ethernet. Also muss man sich da was überlegen. Es gibt dann diese Sub-Network-Conversion-Protokolls. Wie ARP. Habt ihr bestimmt schon mal gehört. Es gibt so ARP-Kommande und so. Das ist im Falle von V4 ein komplett separates Protokoll. ARP wird benutzt von V4, aber hat mit V4 nichts zu tun. Du kannst ARP auch dazu benutzen, um andere Protokolle und die Adressen herauszufinden. Vom Prinzip ist das so ein Vermittlungs-Ding. Man sagt ARP, ich bin IP-Adresse und Ethernet-Adresse so und so und suche die Ethernet-Adresse zu folgender IP-Adresse. Finde doch mal raus. Bei ARP ist das ganz simpel gemacht. Da wird ins Rohr gebrüllt. Da wird ein Broadcast gemacht. Ich bin der und der und suche so und so. Gibt es den? Wenn der da ist, sollte er möglichst antworten. Und dann findet man, dessen Ethernet-Adresse raus, kann mit dem reden. Das ist aber, wie gesagt, bei V4 ist das ein komplett getrenntes Protokoll. Bei V6 ist das implizit mit. V6 sagt, wir brauchen kein separatet Protokoll mehr, weil wir können ja auf jeden Fall überhaupt miteinander reden. Wir haben ja Link-Local-Adressen und Multicast. Das heißt, ich kann also rausbrüllen, wenn ich jemanden suche. Sagen, hallo, ich suche den mit der IPv6-Adresse so und so. Kann ich als V6-Multicast rausschicken. Wenn der da ist, meldet der sich. Diesen Prozess nennt man Neighbor-Discovery. Man sucht seinen Nachbarn. Man kann den auch selber anstoßen. Man kann auch selber wieder sagen, hallo, ich bin jetzt neu hier. Ich habe folgende Interface.
Aber da muss auch der Switch das eigentlich jedem zustellen, damit die dann antworten können. Oder ist das schon der Switch, der dann sagt, wenn ich den noch nicht gesehen habe bisher, dann wird das auch keinem zugestellt.
Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen, dass wir die Leute nicht verwirren. Du hast recht, es gibt ein Thema, wohin schickt ein Switch ein Paket an eine Adresse, die er noch nie zuvor gesehen hat? Die Antwort lautet, aus allen Ports, aus allen aktiven Ports. Dieser Mechanismus nennt sich Flooding. Damals ist es übrigens auch eine super DDoS-Geschichte. Du gehst in ein Netz und sprichst eine Ethernet-Adresse an, die es dort gar nicht gibt.
Die du einfach mal ausgedacht hast.
Kannste machen. Also musst du von Hand baseln, weil deine Colonel machen das nicht. Die haben keinen Grund dafür, das zu tun. Aber kannst du machen. Kannst du von Hand ein Ethernet-Paket rausschicken, eine unbekannte MAC-Adresse. Und die wird von allen Switches gefluttet. Und hinter dem Switch hängt ja vielleicht noch ein Switch. Der fluttet auch wieder aus allen Ports. Und hinter dem Switch hängt noch ein Switch. Der fluttet auch wieder aus allen Ports. Da kann man Spaß haben mit. Aber in dem Moment, wo ein so ein Switch mal... Also die Idee ist folgende, dass wenn man jetzt da nicht irgendwelchen DDoS-Quatsch mitmacht, sondern wenn man wirklich jemand anspricht, den es gibt, wird er hoffentlich antworten. In dem Moment lässt er sozusagen die Hüllen fallen. Der Switch lernt also, ah, an dem Port Nummer 5 steckt er dran. Und schickt von da an eben Pakete, die an diese Adresse gesagt haben, nur noch aus Port 5 raus. Weil er von da die Antworten gekriegt hat. Deswegen kann man zum Beispiel auch dort Switches super verwirren, indem man ein Gerät an mehrere Switch-Ports anschließt und mal ein Paket da und da raus schickt. Weil dann wissen sie nämlich nicht so, wie du warst da... 5? Ne, jetzt 7? Hallo? Wo bist du denn nun? Da sind die nicht so richtig drauf geeicht. Da kann man echt Spaß mit haben.
Oder wenn man ein Gerät macht, was auf alle Adressen antwortet und sagt, ja ich bin's, ich bin's, ich bin's.
Kannste auch machen, weil so ein Switch hat nur eine begrenzt große Tabelle, wo er sich merken kann, welche Mac-Adresse hinter welchem Port sitzt. Und wenn die voll ist, fängt er auch wieder an zu flatten. Oder abzustürzen. Die billig Switches stürzen ab, habe ich gerade neulich mal ausprobiert. Die crashen einfach und andere strecken alle vier von sich, sagen, okay, das sind mir zu viele, ich kau einfach alle Pakete aus allen Ports raus.
Aber man könnte das ja auch als Indiz nehmen, dass da vielleicht was faul ist und da vielleicht auch ein bisschen viele Adressen im Einsatz sind.
Ja, man könnte das auch als Indiz nehmen, dass auf der Internetveranstaltung, die man gerade für 3000 Nerds veranstaltet hat, wo jeder mit einem Rechner, einem iPhone und einem iPad aufläuft, plötzlich 9000 Mac-Adressen im Spiel sind. Dafür könnte man das auch als Indiz nehmen. Okay, so funktioniert dieser Mechanismus. Beim IPv4 wird, wie gesagt, gearbt. Das heißt, ich sage, ich bin IP-Adresse so und so, Ethernet-Adresse so und so, suche die Ethernet-Adresse von dem, der IP-Adresse so und so hat. Der antwortet und dann merkt man sich das, dann gibt es, wie gesagt, auch wieder Timeouts drauf und so weiter. Beim v6 macht man das so, dass man aus der Adresse, die man sucht, sich ein paar Bits extrahiert und daraus eine Multicast-Adresse generiert. Das heißt, man schränkt den Empfängerraum ein drastisch. Im Idealfall, wenn alles gut geht, habe ich eine Multicast-Adresse gewählt, auf die nur der intendierte Empfänger horcht. Wenn da doch zwei, drei andere sind, okay, belästige ich zwei, drei andere, aber nicht alle. Im Falle von ARB ist es ja ein Broadcast, alle müssen sich das erstmal anhören. Ich suche so und so, ich suche so und so. Die Glühlampe ist total genervt davon, da sucht ein Drucker oder ein Drucker sucht ein Mac oder wie auch immer und das geht die Glühlampe gar nicht an. Im V6 ist das durch die Verwendung, durch die Nichtverwendung von Broadcast und durch die Verwendung von Multicast, ist das so geregelt, dass man, man weiß ja schon, bei dem Nader Discovery weiß er schon bestimmte Dinge von seinem Ziel, dass man sucht, nämlich die Adresse, die man sucht und aus diesen Bits, die da drinstecken, kann man sich schon sozusagen eine Multicast-Adresse generieren, eine von mehreren Milliarden Multicast-Adressen. Und da schickt man dann sozusagen seine Suche hin. Ja, das ist auch da wieder so ein Optimierungsschritt, den man da eingeführt hat als Verbesserung gegenüber V4.
Ähm, jetzt ist es ja nun einfach die Realität noch nicht, dass IPv6 einfach so aus der Dose fällt. Wenn man heute DSL hat oder auch Mobilfunk etc., dann dürfte man wahrscheinlich in den allermeisten Fällen noch nur IPv4 vermittelt bekommen.
Ja, hier in unseren deutschen Landen, wo regelmäßig nicht, es gibt welche. Es gibt so ein paar Kabelnetzbetreiber oder so ein paar Standnetzbetreiber, die sind nett gelohnt, spielt damit rum. Und jemand hat neulich aus München berichtet, er kriegt sowas auch aus der Wand oder so. Aber es ist nicht die Regel.
Und selbst wenn es dann so ist, ist es noch nicht klar, wenn man jetzt feste Adressen haben will, wie man sicherstellen kann, dass man nicht immer wieder neue kriegt. Das ist der Spaß, unter dem man jetzt schon so leidet, mit der dynamischen Vergabe von IP-Adressen, dass das gleich endet.
Naja, diese 24-Stunden-Nummer passiert ja, naja, ist halt ein Politikum. Dieses Thema, wo wir jetzt reden, ist ein politisches, kein technisches. Das strecken die Leute von der ITF die Hände sagen. Ja, wenn dein Provider jeden Tag eine neue IP-Adresse geben will, ist das ein Bier, da haben wir nichts mit zu tun. Das ist nach wie vor immer noch so ein Punkt, wenn wir jetzt nicht von Tunneln reden, sondern von dem sogenannten nativen IPv6, was sozusagen einfach aus der Wand kommt, wie Strom oder wie jetzt V4, dann ist man auf gedeihem Verderben dem ausgeliefert, was sein Provider dort anbietet. Gibt es ja jetzt auch, du hast ja auch im V4 dynamische IP-Adressen, jeden Tag eine neue, oder du zahlst halt x mehr und kriegst eine statische IP-Adresse im Bleib. Das wird im V6 genauso sein. Im V6 kriegst du halt nicht eine Adresse, sondern Präfix. Und der ändert sich oder ändert sich nicht. Das ist ein politisches Thema, was du mit deinem Kreuzchen beim Auftrag, bei deinem ISP, bestimmst.
Also möchte man jetzt vielleicht seine Connectivity mal sichern, indem man A, jetzt überhaupt erstmal IPv6 kriegt oder zumindest sich das von wo holt, wo man ein bisschen die Hand drauf hat. Genau, wo Leute die Ahnung haben, aber wo auch der Präfix dann definiert ist, wenn ich nämlich jetzt wirklich, also wenn es einfach nur um den Remote-Access geht, ohne dass sich das Ding permanent bei irgendwelchen dünnen DNS-Providern registrieren muss.
Ich will nur mal ganz kurz mal ein bisschen in den Raum werfen, warum ich glaube, dass die ISPs da noch so schwachbrustig sind, dass das nicht nativ aus der Wand kommt. Ich glaube, das liegt nicht daran, dass die zu blöde sind, sich Equipment zu kaufen, was das kann. Das kann man ja auch demonstrieren. Ich hab ja schon nach dem letzten CRE schon so ein Test-Setup gemacht, was auch in dem Blog da zu sehen ist, wie man das machen kann, dass man überall einen TDSL-Anschluss in Deutschland auch vor sechs kriegen kann. Was ich denn bereitstelle von meinem Test-Setup. Aber es ist also nicht so, dass die Infrastruktur das nicht könnte. Meine Vermutung geht dahingehend, dass die ASPs mit ihrer Drum-rum-Infrastruktur noch nicht in der Lage sind, das zu verwalten. Da gehört ja heute mehr dazu als Leuten, IP-Adressen zu geben und die zu routen, sondern musst ja Abhörschnittstellen bereitstellen. Du musst Adresslogging machen, damit dich die Content-Industrie dir einen Gerichtsbeschluss zustellen kann, damit du sagst, wer hatte dann und dann, die sind jener IP-Adresse. Du musst eine Hotline betreiben, die das versteht und so weiter. Und dieser ganze Zoo, glaube ich, geht denen noch so ein bisschen ab. Deswegen machen das die kleinen ISPs. Die kochen ja mit demselben technischen Equipment wie die Großen, aber die haben halt weniger von diesem Zeug am Arsch.
Auch für die Mitarbeiter, die sie schulen müssen.
Ja, und die sind halt auch dafür, ist halt die Knowledge-Konzentration höher. Die haben halt einen höheren IQ. Oder habe ich böse Schriften für gekriegt, als ich gesagt habe, die mit 70, unter 70 arbeiten bei der Telekom. Nein, das gibt auch sehr schlaue Leute, habe ich auch seit dem letzten Podcast auch festgestellt. Wollte ich jetzt an dieser Stelle nochmal sagen. Aber egal, bei den kleinen ISPs ist halt eben das Know-how oder auch der Willen, sowas auch zu machen. Auch einfach, weil man es kann einfach hören. Die Großen sagen, pff, noch Hamba-V4-Adressen, das ist das Einzige, was uns drückt. Ja, es ist uncool, aber wir wollen ja Geld verdienen, nicht cool sein. Also deswegen haben sie diese ganze Support-Infrastruktur da drum, Abhörschnittstellen, ich sage nur Abhörschnittstellen und so weiter alles. Das ist so meine große Vermutung, woran es noch hakt, warum der Telekom oder der Alistit noch nicht längst angeknipst haben in Deutschland.
Aber es wird kommen, aber bis dahin kann man sich jetzt Tunnel aufsetzen. Da gibt es ja irgendwie richtig, richtig viel, habe ich so den Eindruck, was man so nehmen kann.
Die Grundidee bei einem Tunnel ist, dass man sagt, okay, IPv6 ist ja dafür designed, dass es auf alle möglichen läuft, also auf dem Ethernet, Tokenring, Laser-Strecke, Avian Carriers, Brieftauben. Oder auch IPv4. Niemand verbietet dir ein IPv6-Paket nicht über ein Ethernet, sondern über ein IPv4-Paket zu transportieren, was dann über Ethernet oder so läuft. Diesen Mechanismus nennt man Tunneln. Da gibt es sehr, sehr viele Sachen, die man machen kann. Es gibt ein paar Mechanismen, obwohl die sollte ich vielleicht eher am Schluss, weil das ein netter Mindfuck ist, 6 to 4. Die einfachste Möglichkeit ist, man sucht sich jemanden, der eine IPv6-Konnektivität hat, der also sozusagen an dem großen IPv6-Internet dranhängt, einigt sich über eine Adressvergabe, also man lässt sich von dem einen Präfix zuteilen und einigt sich irgendwie darüber, wie man diesen Tunnel zustande bringt. Das ist eigentlich der kritische Teil, dass man sagt, wir benutzen folgendes Encapsulation oder folgendes Tunnelprotokoll und, das ist der viel schlimmere Teil, ich wechsle ja leider meine IPv4-Adresse jeden Tag. Das heißt, theoretisch müsste ich, wenn ich mich mit einem Tunnelprovider verabredet habe, den jeden Tag anrufen, morgens um vier, wenn die Telekom mir eine neue IP-Adresse zugeteilt hat, sagt, hallo, schickt mir jetzt bitte die getunnelten Pakete nicht an die alte Adresse, sondern an die neue. Um dieses Problem zu adressieren, gibt es halt verschiedene Mechanismen und gibt Tunnelmanagement-Protokolle, sage ich mal. Also gibt es zum Beispiel dieses AJAJA, wie A, Y, I, Y, A oder so. Und diverse andere. Man kann es aber auch ganz, ganz simpel machen. Man kann zum Beispiel einfach sagen, da meine IP-Adresse sich dauernd ändert, bin ich in der Pflicht, meinem Tunnelprovider regelmäßig Bescheid zu geben, wo ich jetzt gerade bin mit meiner V4-Adresse, damit er sozusagen die Pakete da hintunneln kann.
Anything in anything. Frag mich nicht.
Also, um man, also das ist sozusagen, die Einfachmacht wurde. Das heißt, man stopft einfach das fertige IP-Paket, als hätte man sozusagen ein Netz, ein Ethernet oder wie ich immer, stopft es halt bloß nicht auf ein Ethernet, sondern packt es auf ein IPv4-Paket, deklariert Dorin, hallo, deine Payload ist ein V6-Paket und schickt es an einen Tunnel-Endpunkt und der macht genau das selber. Das heißt, man benutzt sozusagen das Internet at large als Transportmechanismus. Warum auch nicht? Da wirst du ja da. Der Interessante daran ist, dass diese Tunnel-Endpunkte irgendwo sein können. Das muss nicht dein ISP sein in dieser Stadt. Du kannst ja auch einen Tunnel-Endpunkt in Japan suchen. Das ist zwar vielleicht aus Performance-Grund dämlich, aber niemand hält dich davon ab, das zu tun. Da gibt es jetzt ein paar Organisationen, die gibt es schon sehr lange. Die gab es schon bevor der ganze IPv6-Hype sozusagen losbrach. Zum Beispiel gibt es die nette Organisation SIXS, S-I-X-X-S, SIXXS, SIXXS. Zugang zum SIX.
Zugang zu SIX. Das sind freundliche Kollegen, die glaube ich in Holland beheimatet sind. Sehr ambitionierte Leute, aber keine kommerzielle Organisation, soweit ich feststellen konnte. Dort kann man sich anmelden, also sixs.net, sixxs.net. Da holt man sich einen Account und kann dann dort einen Tunnel beantragen. Das heißt, man kann erst mal sagen, hallo, ich möchte hier mitspielen, gib mir noch mal einen Tunnel. Da muss man so ein paar Fragen beantworten, weil die haben mehrere sogenannte Pops. Das sind also Leute, die vor Sexkonditivität haben und auch bereit sind, diese Tunnel bereitzustellen. Die sind überall verteilt, erst nur europäisch, ich glaube auch inzwischen auch weltweit. Die haben auch Nodes in Asien und so. Und diese ganze Verwaltung davon machten die Sex-Leute für die. Das heißt, du musst also jetzt nicht mit dem jeweiligen ISP oder der Firma dort in Kontakt treten, sondern du lockst dich bei Sex ein und sagst, ich brauch einen Tunnel und ich sitze jetzt selber in Berlin und mein nächster Tunnel-Endpunkt sitzt halt, wettest ich, in Hamburg oder Düsseldorf oder wo auch immer. Dann schreibt man noch einen kurzen Salm dazu, was man machen will. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendjemand liest und schickt das ab. Und dann kriegt man nach ein paar Stunden eine Mail, dass man sagt, ja, okay, hier hast du so ein paar Daten, hier sind deine Tunneldaten, lock dich da unter einen, da kannst du das machen. Zu den Details können wir gleich noch kommen. Da gibt es jetzt, man kann diese Tunnel direkt aufbauen von seinem Endgerät aus, es gibt also Client Software für Windows, für Mac, für Linux, für Schieß mich tot. Oder man hat zum Beispiel einen Router, einen DSL-Router, der das auch kann, die von mir ja sehr gerne häufig benutzte und erwähnte Fritzbox kann das schon seit relativ lange. Denen gibt man sozusagen einfach nur diese 6-Account-Daten und die Fritzbox lockt sich dann selber dort ein und holt sich die ganzen Konfigurationen, die man da verbraucht und sagt auch selbstständig dem Tunnel-Endpunkt auf der anderen Seite Bescheid, was ja Sinn macht, weil die Fritzbox ist ja die, die immer periodisch eine neue IP-Adresse kriegt jede Nacht. Das heißt, die ist die erste, die davon erfährt, wenn sich was ändert an dem Tunnel. Und deswegen, wenn die sozusagen merkt, oh, meine IPv4-Konnektivität hat sich geändert oder sie war ja selber aktiv daran beteiligt, geht sie sofort hin, sagt dem Tunnel-Endpunkt, hallo, ich bin jetzt hier. Also zieht sozusagen diesen Tunnel immer hinter sich her. Das macht die von alleine. Das ist sehr nett. Wenn man diesen Weg geht, der kostet auch nichts. Er ist ein bisschen Zeitintensiv. Kann ich noch kurz erwähnen warum. Aber der ist der einfachste. Wer also zu Hause eine Fritzbox hat, dann kann man eine neueste Version drauf machen. Bei Internetkonfiguration oben IPv6 anmachen, Six-Tunnel auswählen, sich bei Six vor einen Account holen, den Account out einklopfen und gut ist.
Dann kriegt man immer denselben Präfix, weil man sozusagen diese Subnet, diesen Präfix einmal zugeteilt bekommt. Den hat man dann irgendwie immer.
Obwohl sich die V4-Adresse immer ändert.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo die Fritzbox dann wieder die neue Verbindung, also was weiß ich hier, Telekom-Mitarbeiter, Schrauben an meiner Box rum, irgendwie disconnecten mich, connectet gleich wieder im Idealfall. Dann merkt er, oh, neue IPv4-Adresse. Dann ist ja der Tunnel sozusagen tot, weil die Gegenseite schickt das an die falsche Stelle. Dann connectet er sich hin und sagt hier, schickt mal wieder hierher. Im Idealfall können dann die Rechner, die eben da noch über V6 was rübergepumpt haben, dann einfach mit derselben Adresse weitermachen.
Ja, auch bestehende TCP-Verbindungen unterbrechen halt kurz, während die Telekom dein DSL-Link da resettet. Und wenn jetzt nicht die Applikation selber in den Timeout läuft, wenn du eine SSH-Session oder irgendwas offen hast, die geht halt einfach weiter. Du hast ja nach wie vor die selbe Adresse. Deswegen hast du übrigens auch so viele deprecated-Adressen, weil du da noch Applikationen offen hast, die Verbindungen ins Netz offen haben vielleicht, wo sich längst deine V4-Infrastruktur drei-, vier-, fünfmal darunter geändert hat und du also andere, was ich alles hast, die sind so langlebig, dass sozusagen deine Verbindungen, dass du sozusagen mehrere Wechsel dieser temporären Privacy-Adresse überstanden haben.
Aber wie kann ich denn jetzt noch sicherstellen, dass meine Rechner auch dann immer unter derselben Adresse erreichbar sind? Weil hier krieg ich ja auch nur erstmal denselben Präfix.
Ich hatte ja von erzählt, du hast einen Interface, der bleibt ja konstant.
Okay, der bleibt gleich, genau. Das ist die feste Adresse.
Von außen erreichbar. Diese Six-Nummer hat ein kleiner, weiß nicht, großer Nachteil, aber erstens sie haben nicht Pops überall. Also für uns Berliner zum Beispiel, der nächste Pop ist in Hamburg, der ist aber voll und kriegt immer irgendwelche Adressen aus Süddeutschland oder aus Düsseldorf oder sonst wo. Und ich glaube, die sind mal schwer missbraucht worden. Deswegen sind die so ein bisschen, die gucken sich das alle von Hand an. Also es ist jetzt kein Automatismus, wo du hinklickst, sagst, ich will einen Tunnel und drei Sekunden später hast du die Mail und da ist dann dein Tunnel drin und so. Sondern du musst dahin gehen, musst das beantragen und dann guckt sich das jemand von Hand an und klickt auf OK und dann kriegst du wieder eine Mail. Und die haben auch so einen Mechanismus, die haben so eine virtuelle Währung. Du kannst ja noch mehr machen mit V6-Geschichten. Du kannst jetzt nicht nur einen Tunnel haben wollen, sondern du kannst zum Beispiel noch mehrere oder größere Prefixe darüber haben wollen. Also richtig fette Netze, 48er oder so. Oder möchtest gerne DNS-Einträge machen, DNS-Reverse-Mappings und so weiter und so fort. Die kosten alle, ich sag jetzt mal Geld, aber nur diese virtuelle Währung. Und diese virtuelle Währung verdienst du dadurch, dass du einen Tunnel permanent betreibst, korrekt betreibst. Was die damit verhindern wollen, ist, dass die Ressourcen raus tun an Leute, die damit bloß mal zwei Stunden rumspielen und danach nie wieder anfassen.
Dass er dann rumliegt und verbraucht ist.
Und deswegen machen die das so, du kriegst erst mal nur einen Tunnel mit einem relativ kleinen Präfix, den betreibst du ein bisschen und dann hast du schon nach ein paar Tagen oder noch ein paar Stunden genug ISKs, heißt diese Währung, zusammen, wo du dann sozusagen weitere Features kaufen kannst mit. Was ich eigentlich ganz vernünftig finde. Der andere Mitspieler, den ich noch erwähnen möchte, weil er auch ganz sexy ist, ist eine Firma namens Hurricane Electric. Das ist ein größerer globaler ISP. Der hat auch ein paar lustige Pops, auch zum Beispiel in Berlin. Die betreiben eine Seite namens tunnelbroker.net. Wenn man sich dort registriert und dort anständig macht, kriegt man sofort seine Dinger zugeteilt, seine Tunnel und seine Adressen und so weiter und so fort kriegt man zugeteilt. Sozusagen schneller drankommen und auch für bestimmte Leute performen die besser als diese Six-Tunnel. Sind halt dichter dran. Dichter dran, schneller. Ist halt ein richtiger ISP, der das macht und nicht irgendwie Konglomerat von Fans, wie bei Six. Der Nachteil ist, man muss ein bisschen dieses Hallo, meine IP-Adresse hat sich geändert, muss man ein bisschen von Hand hinfummeln. Weil sowas wie eine Fritzbox kann das leider noch nicht. Ich hab die schonmal angetickt, schonmal gefragt, ob sie das nicht mal mit reinbauen wollen oder sowas. Vom Prinzip muss man halt einfach nur, man muss eine HTTP-Requestin machen. Oder eine HTTPS-Requestin. Also sozusagen per HTTPS-Request gelegentlich immer mal wieder sagen, Hallo, ich hab jetzt eine neue IP-Adresse. Damit die auch da diese Tunnelgeschichte wieder umstellen. Und dann ist gut. Ist ein bisschen gebastelt, aber ist wie gesagt auch ganz nett. Dann sollte man noch erwähnen, es gibt einen im Standard vorgesehenen Tunnelmechanismus. Der geht einfach so, den kann man einfach anknipsen. Hat ein paar andere Nachteile. Ist nämlich der so nette 624-Tunnel. Dort macht man nämlich Folgendes. Man nimmt deine V4-Adresse, die du hast, die sich ja jeden Tag ändert. Und benutzt diese 32-Bit, um daraus einen IPv6-64-Bit-Prefix zu generieren. Nee, der ist sogar kürzer, glaube ich. Aber egal, um einen IPv6-Prefix zu generieren. Und das ist automatisch deiner. Wenn du die IPv4-Adresse 1234 hast, dann gehört der automatisch der Präfix 2002, 1, 2, 3, 4. Sozusagen, wem die IPv4-Adresse gehört, gehört automatisch ein passender Präfix dazu. Ein Nachteil ist, der ändert sich natürlich. Jedes Mal, wenn sich deine IPv4-Adresse ändert, ändert sich auch dein Präfix. Was aber jetzt nicht notwendigerweise stört, wenn du keine Dienste betreiben willst. Wir haben vorhin gelernt, dass auf einem laufenden Netz alle Systeme können müssen, einen neuen Präfix zu lernen und einen alten zu verlernen. Das ist ein Standardprozedur. Das müssen die können. Und dann kann man das auch machen. Das geht auch mit so einer Fritzbox. Fritzbox zum Beispiel möchte gerne 624-Tunnel. Dann guckt sie auf ihre V4-Adresse, generiert daraus automatisch den passenden IPv6-Präfix. Die kann man wie gesagt daran erkennen, dass sie alle mit 2002 anfangen. Und nichts anderes fängt mit 2002 an, außer 624-Tunnel. Und annonciert diesen Präfix und alle Systeme lernen das automatisch, wie vorhin erwähnt, und benutzen den. Aber wo tunnelt der hin?
Ja genau, wo schicke ich das denn hin?
Der tunnelt an eine Anycast-Adresse. Wo wir auf einen so schön waren. Es war eine V4 Anycast-Adresse. Jetzt muss ich gerade mal schauen. Ich betreibe nämlich auch so einen Tunnel-Endpunkt. Ich vergess immer wieder. 199? Ne, 192.88.99.1. Das heißt, dein Router, deine Fritz Boxer, wenn man jetzt nichts davor benutzen will, hat sich ja selber gerade ein IPv6-Präfix generiert. Und schickt einfach diese Tunnel-Paket brutal an die IPv4-Adresse 192.88.99.1. Wer das ist und wo du es scheißegal ist, ist ja eine Anycast-Adresse. Wenn dein ISP cool ist, dann geht es sozusagen nur bis dahin und da ist der Gateway. Wenn dein ISP blöd ist, hoppelt das Ding durchs halbe Internet und findet dort irgendwo auf dieser Welt einen Gateway, der das V6-Paket wieder auspackt und in die V6-Welt rausschubst. Wie kommt das Paket zurück? Ja, da in der V6-Adresse, wie ich schon erwähnt ja, deine V4-Adresse, deine aktuelle enthalten ist, kann dir irgendjemand auf dieser Welt, einfach auf diesen Mechanismus, die Pakete wieder zurückschicken. Weil er weiß ja, an welche V4-Adresse er sich schicken muss. Weil die steht ja drin in der V4-Adresse. Ist ein bisschen holprig. Und wie gesagt, du weißt nie, wo welcher Gateway, du hast auch asymmetrische Druting. Also das Hinpaket nimmt nie denselben Paket, den es in den Rückweg nimmt. Was auch im V4 immer schon so ein Problem ist und so. Also ein bisschen hakelig. Aber es geht. Kann man halt einfach anmachen. Man muss sich vorher nirgendwo registrieren. Kein Nix, kein Gar-Nichts. Kann man einfach anmachen. Es gibt auch viele Betriebssysteme, die auch dir erlauben, so einen Tunnel mit einem IF-Config-Befil einfach zu generieren.
Verstehe, das heißt, die V6-Pakete, die ich verschicke, gehen an diese eine spezielle Adresse, die unter Umständen schon bei meinem ISP, vielleicht aber auch bei irgendeinem anderen ISP, dann irgendwie ausgepackt wird. Aber irgendwo landet sie auf jeden Fall.
Da wird sie ausgepackt. Und dann wird das V6-Paket, was darauf reitet, runtergenommen und in den V6-Internet geschubst.
Und dann kommt es irgendwann zu dem V6-Host, der denn das ist. Und der antwortet aber dann auch über V6.
Der antwortet über V6.
Und das geht dann erstmal wieder zu diesem anderen...
Da muss wieder irgendwo ein Gateway existieren, wahrscheinlich bei seinem ISP oder da in der Nähe.
Der auch schon auf die ursprüngliche hätte reagieren können, wenn er eben zufällig denjenigen gewissen wäre.
Nee, nee, der ursprüngliche war der Hinweg. Das ist der Hinweg auf V4. Jetzt habe ich V6 und muss wieder den Rückweg wieder finden.
Aber es ist sozusagen...
So, der annonciert diesen, ich kann 2002 routen. Alles, was mit 2002 anfängt, annonciert der, kriegt dieses Paket, guckt sich in den Teil vorne rein von der V6-Adresse, wo sozusagen die 32 Bit der V4-Adresse drin embedded sind und schickt es dann da einfach hin. So, Rom's. Kannste einfach anmachen. Kann auch eine Fritzbox, kann man auch auf dem System einfach machen. Also 624-Tunnel ist das Stichwort. Weil das so holprig ist, wird es zum Beispiel von verschiedenen Betriebssystemen oder von Frameworks gerne missachtet. Wenn du zum Beispiel ein aktuelles Mac aus X hast und du hast nur ein 624-Tunnel und du sprichst eine Seite an, die sowohl V4 als V6 hat, macht sie immer nur V4. Das macht auch Sinn, weil wir sagen, um 624 betreiben zu können, musst du eh V4-Konnektivität haben. Das macht jetzt keinen Sinn, das V6 dazwischenzustecken, wenn ich eh gleich V4 mit dir reden kann.
Also 624 ist eigentlich nur für V6-only-Dienste interessant.
Genau, du kannst 624 dann anmachen, wenn du Dienste oder Seiten ansprichst, die nur V6 können, dann werden die überhaupt benutzt, sonst wären die nicht benutzt. Das war aber früher anders. Also wenn du zum Beispiel noch einen schönen Snow Leopard am Start hast oder so, der nimmt auch die einfach, wenn sie da ist. Aber die modernen, so die Alliance oder auch andere, ich rede immer von der Mac-Welt, aber gibt es eigentlich noch Leute, die was anderes haben und diesen Podcast hören?
Es gab auch noch andere...
Linux-Leute, aber da funktioniert es ähnlich. Linux und BSD-Leute, egal. Ja, so viel zu den Tunneln. Kann man machen...
Ich guck gerade mal hier in dieser Fritzbox, da gibt es ja auch noch andere Tunnelsysteme, die hier genannt werden. Hier ist noch von einem 6RD und von einem 6IN4.
Ja, das ist...
Also 624 und 6IN4.
6IN4 ist sozusagen, du musst das alle von Hand konfigurieren. Deine Tunneldinger. 6RD, also man muss dazu erzählen, damit könnte man alleine wieder Stunden füllen und jetzt kommt wirklich fiese Mindfucks raus. Es gibt, seitdem man überhaupt mit der Idee rausgekommen ist, wir machen ein neues Internetprotokoll, hat man sich über die Transition-Strategies Gedanken gemacht. Also, was mach ich? Die erste Antwort war, wir machen erstmal beides. Und dann sagten aber die Leute, naja, ist schön, aber wir machen ja v6, weil wir wissen, dass wir mit v4 nicht mehr weiterkommen. Es wird also irgendwann mal eine Zeit geben, da haben wir einfach nicht mehr genug Adressen für v4. Das heißt, wir müssen v6-only machen. Das trifft aber jetzt nicht alle Leute gleichzeitig auf der Welt. Ja, wir Europäer sind noch so eingedeckt, aber aufstehende Staaten in Asien und in Afrika, die jetzt eher spät kommen da mit oder so, kriegen vielleicht keine IPv4-Adressen mehr. Das heißt, die können nur v6-only, aber wir haben hier immer noch Server, die v4-only sind, die möchten vielleicht trotzdem auf diese Webseite drauf. Also, was macht man jetzt da eigentlich? Wie sind eigentlich die Strategien dafür, wenn man sozusagen nur v6 hat und v4-Webseiten ansprechen will? Oder andersrum, wie es jetzt ist, ich hab nur v4, möchte aber v6 ansprechen. Oder ich hab beides, welche präferiere ich? Also, da kann man sich wirklich stundenlang, tagellang mit unterhalten, da gibt es halt eben auch verschiedene Mechanismen. Gerade diese Szenarien, ich hab nur v6, was ja antizipiert wird, dass die Leute sagen, die ISPs geben ihren Kunden nur nach v6. Und dann gibt es irgendwo auf der Welt noch eine Handvoll v4-Webseiten. Wie sprechen die die denn jetzt eigentlich an? Und diese Zeit mit Handvoll, also Handvoll sind ein paar Millionen. Und diese Zeit, wo man annimmt, dass das passiert, dass sozusagen da wird über Dekaden gesprochen.
Das halte ich auch für realistisch.
Das heißt, man muss sich da also schon eine Strategie überlegen, was mache ich jetzt damit? Ich habe auf der einen Seite Leute, die haben nur noch v6 und wollen jetzt einmal Webseiten reden, oder mit anderen Internetsystemen, die nur v4 haben. Da kommt jetzt wieder das große böse Spiel der Elephant in the Room Nut von hinten erwähnt, Network Address Translation, aber diesmal nicht in deinem Heimrouter, sondern diesmal beim Carrier. Das heißt, dein Router und dein Endsystem ist total unschuldig, denkt, das hängt an einem riesengroßen v6-Internet und plötzlich rennen alle deine Pakete in eine riesen Monsterbüchse bei deinem Carrier rein. Stell dir mal vor, so ein Telekom oder so ein Alice mit ein paar Millionen Kunden oder sowas. Die haben dann diese Monster-Nut-Kisten, wo sie dann diesen Verkehr, diesen Carrier-Gerät nennt sich das, wo sie das umsetzen von v6 auf v4 und wieder zurück und so. Das sind ganz fiese Night-Messenerien. Da kann man auch wirklich, wie gesagt, dreimal im Jahr findet diese ITF statt, also diese Internet-Ingeniering-Taskforce, die Leute, die das alles besprechen und beschließen. Ich war jetzt mal wieder im, wann war das, März oder April? In der März, April war ich in Paris da, mich auch in die IPv6 Working Groups gesetzt. Da findet auch heute immer noch Haare rauf und statt. Da gibt es viele Leute, die sich darüber Gedanken machen und streiten, was jetzt besser ist. Und da gibt es auch wirklich echt hanebüchende Diskussionen. Ich erinnere mich an eine, die war echt lustig. Da gibt es Leute, die sich wirklich gute Mechanismen dafür ausdenken, sagen so und vier und zwei und sechs. Und wenn wir das machen, dann konfigurieren wir den Router. Und dann stand uns ein Typ von France Telecom auf und meinte, ich verstehe da ein Problem nicht. Wir konfigurieren das einfach so, wie wir das für richtig halten, das ist gut. Dann sagte der, ja, aber nicht jeder, jeder der am Netz dranhängt, lässt euch die Router konfigurieren. Manche Leute haben halt einfach selber einen eigenen Router und wollen den konfigurieren. Da muss doch was für... Bei uns hängen bloß Leute dran mit irgendwelchen Boxen, die wir konfigurieren. Hat er so gesagt, ist vollkommen gelogen, stimmt nicht. Es gibt genügend Leute, die eine Fritz Boxer in Frankreich betreiben. Aber das war so sein Mindset. Ich muss da drüber nicht nachdenken, wie man das am schlauesten macht. Ich mach das so, wie ich das konfiguriere, und so haben die die User zu nehmen. Und wenn das nicht geht, dann ist das deren Problem. So, fertig, zack. So in solchen Mindset. Dann waren große Trauen im Raum und die alle so, hä, hä, hä und so. Also da sind die noch. Ja, da sind die sozusagen auf dieser Ebene, wird darüber noch diskutiert. Also das wird noch ein interessantes Teil.
Aber für diese Transition ist ja eigentlich bei Nerds dieses etwas verpönte Modell mit Provider. Gib mir so meine Plastikbox, die ich euch da hinschraube und die hab ich dann zu nehmen. Wäre für so eine Transition natürlich ganz wertvoll.
Macht denen das Leben leichter. Macht auch deren Hotline das Leben leichter.
Ja, aber macht mir unter Umständlich das Leben leichter, weil die Geräte halt, kennen wir ja alles schon mit hier auch. Wieso? DNS können wir ja mal hijacken und wie du willst einen anderen DNS-Server verwenden und so weiter hast du Spitze. Also die eigenen Business-Interessen stehen dann sozusagen meiner Netzqualität dann doch so sehr entgegen, dass ich das Angebot dann doch nicht so gerne annehmen möchte. Okay, das mit den Tunneln habe ich jetzt verstanden. Vor allem kurz gesagt, diese 6XS scheint eigentlich der entspannteste Weg zu sein. Nein, ich benutze das ja hier auch selber schon. Ich habe mir da mal so zwei...
Ein Wunder, wer dir das verraten hat.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben das auch im letzten CRE schon haben wir das offen diskutiert. Ich habe jetzt 167 ISK verdient mit meinem...
Kannst du dir ein paar schöne Routennetze kaufen und ein paar schöne Reverse DNS Announcements und so. Oder mehrere Tunnel. Macht ja Spaß. Übrigens jetzt mal die Frage, wofür benutzt man das oder wofür kann Otto Normal User das benutzen. Eine der Möglichkeiten ist ja, wenn man diesen Tunnel hat und man kriegt dort eben einen konstanten Präfix, dass man zu Hause konstante Adressen hat. Das kann man zum Beispiel dafür... Und jedes Endgerät hat seine eigene Adresse. Also es gibt ja in dem Sinn kein Nutt mehr in diesem Spielchen. Man hat jetzt noch so ein bisschen so eine Firewall-Thematik. Das heißt, man muss einem Router jetzt auch erlauben, oder seiner Box oder seinem DSL-Router, seiner Fritzbox muss er erlauben, von außen eingehenden Verkehr zuzulassen. Aber das kann man ja machen. Das können die auch schon, kann man so zusammenklicken. Jetzt kann man Folgendes machen. Man nimmt sich einfach zwei solche Tunnel ein für Zuhause, wo man jetzt, wer gerne so Heim-Server betreibt, dort seinen oder seine Server laufen lässt. Und den zweiten Tunnel, den schmeißt man sich auf seinen Laptop. Weil kostet ja nichts. Wenn du genug ISKs verdient hast, holst du den zweiten Tunnel oder den dritten. Und dann betreibst du sozusagen diesen Tunnel-Endpunkt nicht mit deinem Router zentral für dein Netz, sondern von deinem Laptop. Und wenn du dann auf Reisen bist...
Na, dann brauch ich da ein Software, das das kann.
Ja, du kannst du bei Six runterladen. Gibt's fertig, clicky-bunty. Mit Anleitungen, so macht man es unter Mac aus X, L, Y, Y. Das heißt, du hast jetzt sozusagen zu Hause, dein Halbnetz hat konstante Adressen. Und dein Laptop on the road hat auch konstante IPv6-Adressen. Und wenn du dir das jetzt in deiner Firewall auf der Fritzbox entsprechend freischaltest, kannst du sozusagen direkt von unterwegs, egal wo du bist, mit vollem breiten Zugriff auf alle deine Geräte zu Hause zugreifen. Und zwar ohne irgendwelche dünnen DNS-Nut-Tralala-Port-Translations-Quatsch oder sowas, sondern einfach du steckst sozusagen damit. Das ist sozusagen ein VPN, nicht in dem Sinne, da ist kein Krypto im Spiel. Also man möchte dann danach nach Hause immer noch SSHen und Nicht-Helneten und so. Aber man schleppt sozusagen seine Adressen immer schön hinter sich her und kann damit auch entsprechende Spielchen machen, die man so machen will. Wenn man so eine Applikation hat, die gerne mit dem Heim-Server redet oder der Heim-Server auch gerne mit dem unterwegs befindlichen Gerät oder wie immer, da gibt es verschiedene Varianten. Kann man zum Beispiel auch benutzen, um Support zu machen? Du glaubst das gar nicht. Weil kann man nämlich so Leute, wenn man so Anwender hat in seinem Familien- oder Freundeskreis, kann man das so entsprechend etablieren. Es gibt auch andere Mechanismen. Aber es ist einer der simplen Mechanismen, dass man ihm sozusagen so ein implizites V6-VPN mitgibt. Und wenn der dann irgendwelche Sorgen hat, dann esse ich einfach mal frech auf den Laptop drauf. Über V6. Auch das ist übrigens eine Anwendung für interessierte Wesen. Warum will man das überhaupt auch haben? Warum wollen die Nerds das auch haben? Aber sie sind davon, dass es cool ist. Ich habe ja am Anfang erwähnt, ich habe eben auch mal selber Router gebaut, habe auch sehr lange Netze verwaltet, auch Firmen, große Firmennetze und so. Auch alles gemacht. Und die habe ich relativ früh, die habe ich schon in 2002, 2003 mit V6 ausgestattet auch. Und es ist unglaublich entspannt, an einem V4-Netz rumzuoperieren, während man per V6 in dem Router eingeloggt ist.
Auf einmal kann man ja die ganze V4-Konfiguration die ganze Zeit umbiegen.
Du läufst nicht Gefahr, dir den Ast abzusiegen, auf dem du sitzt. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft das schon Leuten passiert ist, die sozusagen irgendeine Kommando in einen Cisco-Router eingeloggt sind. Und während sie Return drückten, so dachten, oh shit. Und das war das letzte Kommando, was sie eingegeben haben, weil danach kamen sie nicht mehr per V4 an den scheiß Router, um das Problem wieder zu fixen. Und mussten sich als Autosetzen hinfahren, an die Konsole gehen oder an den Pushbutton-Monkey bitten, dass er das Ding bootet. So ist es ziemlich cool. Du kannst sozusagen, wenn ich an einem V6-Konfiguration, an Routen oder Interfaces bastel, logge ich mich per V4 in den Router ein. Und wenn ich an dem V4 bastel, logge ich mich über V6 ein. Und habe nie die Gefahr, dass ich mir den Ast absehe. Außer wenn ich meinen V6 nur über den Tunnel habe.
Ja klar.
Klar, dann wenn du den V4 kaputt machst, ist das auch kaputt. Aber wenn du einen Native beides hast, und mein netter ISP, die ich vorhin schon erwähnte, der Firma Internet, in Berlin unter anderem, die anderen aber auch, bieten Native V6 an. Also ohne Tunnelquatsch oder sowas. Und das habe ich einfach seit Jahren beides drauf auf meinem System. Und ich lebe damit sehr gut.
Also IPv4 ausschalten?
Geht.
Kann man da schon mit überleben?
Ja, ich habe im Rahmen eines neuen Projekts, wo ich jetzt hier nicht näher drauf eingehen will, habe ich mal ein Netz generiert, was V6-only ist. Es benimmt sich ein bisschen merkwürdig. Das ist anfangs relativ zäh, weil die Mechanismen, die da sind bei so einem Laptop, so ein Mac aus X oder so einem iPad oder sonst irgendwas, die gehen erst mal davon aus, wenn es Konnektivität hat, hat es auch V4-Konnektivität. Das heißt, es stochert erst mal relativ lange rum, schickt diese DHCP-Request raus und guckt erst mal so. Während das V6 schon komplett da ist und läuft, aber du hast da zum Beispiel bei diesen iOS-Geräten oben diesen komischen Kaffeefilter, dieses WLAN-Symbol oder so was. Das geht ja nicht dann an, wenn er mit einem WLAN verbunden ist, sondern geht erst dann an, wenn er mit einem WLAN verbunden ist und wenn er darauf eine V4-Adresse hat. Egal, ob es nur eine Link-Local-Adresse ist, weil er keine angekriegt hat, aber er muss erst mal eine Adresse drauf haben. In dieser Zeit, wo er sozusagen noch keine V4-Adresse hat, nicht mal eine Link-Local-Adresse, glaubt er einfach nicht daran, dass dieses Interface benutzbar ist. Das heißt, du wählst dich das eine auf diesen WLAN, das dauert eine Minute oder länger, wo er das einfach gar nicht zur Kenntnis nimmt. Obwohl er V6 hat und kann. Aber diese Mechanismen, die entscheiden, ob dieses Interface nutzbar ist, gucken, ob er eine V4-Adresse hat. Und solange da Null drinsteht, machen die nichts. Dann, nach Ablauf einer Zeit, gibt das auf und gibt sich dann selber diese 169254er Link-Local-Adresse. Dann hat es eine Adresse, und dann taucht das auf und dann geht es. Dann kannst du sozusagen auch mit V6 machen. Du kannst natürlich dann derzeit, da ich ja kein Carrier Grade Not, wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, habe, aber du kannst alle Webseiten ansprechen, die V6 auch unterstützen. Du kannst rumgoogeln, Facebooken, lalalala.
Das heißt, man könnte im Prinzip, wenn man jetzt so mit einer Fritzbox daherkommt, konfiguriert man sich seinen 624, äh, Entschuldigung, seinen, äh, 6-Tunnel, seinen 6, 6-Zugang zu 6 und, äh, und schalte aber sozusagen lokal die IPv4-Adressverteilung.
Kannste nicht. Dazu musst du in der Fritzbox-Konfig von Hand rumfingern, sonst macht die das nicht. Aber wenn, ich mach so was mit Cisco-Routern, da kann ich halt einfach sagen, auf dem Interface hier, no IP-Adress gebe ich einfach, da hatte keine IPv4-Adresse. Und da, also wenn man sich so eine Umgebung schafft, wo man das v4 künstlich unterdrückt, wie ich es gesagt habe, stellt man fest, ja, die Geräte sind total verwirrt, weil sie nicht damit rechnen, dass das so ist, aber wenn sie sich damit abgefunden haben, geht das.
Aber kann man nicht den DHCP-Server ausschalten?
Ja, aber dann sucht er halt einen. Was man eigentlich bauen müsste, die Geräte, was man eigentlich tun müsste, man müsste einen DHCP-Server haben, der sagt, ja, hör dich, ich weiß, dass du einen haben willst, aber du kriegst keinen, geh weg. Aber dann macht das Gerät auch nichts weiter, dann sucht es sich einen anderen DHCP-Server. Du musst leider diesen Timeout abwarten, wo er es aufgibt.
Ja gut, aber dann habe ich ihn abgewartet, dann habe ich nur eine IPv6. Die Frage ist, wie viel Internet funktioniert dann noch?
Mehr als man denkt.
Ja, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie viel ich denke. Also Google wird funktionieren, nehme ich mal an.
Mach mal folgendes, mach mal dein Terminal auf, in welchem Betriebssystem auch immer. Und dann tippst du mal ein, wenn du ein System hast, was v6 kann und so. Mach mal ping6, sage ich jetzt mal, heißt das Kommando. www.facebook.com geht, pingt, okay, hamper. Also Facebook würde mit mir reden, www.google.com geht.
Nur weil es pingt heißt es immer nicht, dass da auch ein Webseiter läuft.
Jetzt pass auf, der Brüller, www.apple.com.
Nicht?
www.microsoft.com auch nicht. Wen gibt es denn noch? twitter.com Also man kann suchen? Auch nicht. Man kann suchen, man kann Facebooken.
Aber man kann nicht mehr twitteren?
Aber warte mal, gibt es doch bestimmt www.gmx.de? Auch nicht.
Facebook und Google?
Aber heise.de zum Beispiel? Klar geht. Wen haben wir noch? Sponline. Oh, wenn man es richtig schreiben kann. Auch nicht. Im Rahmen dieses 6-4-Days habe ich es mal ein bisschen rumprobiert. Ich habe mal zwei Dutzend Dinge, die mir spontan einfielen. Und es waren mehr als man dachte. Ich dachte, ich finde bloß drei oder vier. Aber ich habe so ungefähr die Hälfte dieser Dinge, wo man dachte, ah, okay, guck mal, gehen. Und die gehen halt, die gehen dann auch alle. Warum auch nicht?
Also man kann Facebook und Google benutzen. Ich meine, in den meisten Seiten sollte das reichen.
Das reicht auch für viele Leute.
Man kann doch wahrscheinlich nichts anklicken, was Google so ausspuckt.
Ja, kann sein. Aber nochmal, wie gesagt, man kann immer so ein bisschen rumstochen.
Kann man denn bei Google eine Suche so einschränken, dass er einem nur Resultate gibt, die auch über V6 zu erreichen sind?
Ich glaube, das gab es mal. Diese Google hat sich ja nicht von heute auf morgen eingeschaltet, sondern die haben ja mehrere Betas gemacht. Erst eine private Beta und dann zum IPv6-Day letztes Jahr. Und dann konnte man sich dort registrieren. Man kann so ein Google-ID und was weiß ich nicht alles. Und es gab auch einen Mechanismus oder irgendeine Google-Subseite oder sowas, die einem nur Ergebnisse in V6 rausgespuckt hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob es die noch gibt. Ich glaube etwa www.ipv6.google.com oder irgendwie sowas. Aber es gab mal sowas.
Das ist nicht das Google über IPv6. Das ist das IPv6-Google.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn man mal so ein bisschen rumpingt, man sieht ja auch schon, wenn der Ping sagt, kann ja auch passieren, dass zwar eine IPv6-Adresse hat, aber nicht darauf antwortet, auf so ein Ping. Das kann ja sein, dass ein Firewall-Admin da wieder wilde Ideen hat. Aber wenn der Ping schon sagt, ich hab dafür gar keine Adresse für das, was du mir sagst, dann kann es ja gar nicht gehen. Er sagt dann hier so nette Sachen wie Not-Name, No Service Name, Provided und No Note.
Ja, aber Ping sind ja manchmal auch rausgefiltert wiederum.
Ja, aber nee, dann würde der Ping es ja trotzdem probieren. Aber wenn der Ping dir schon sagt, ich finde gar keine Adresse für den Namen, den du mir gegeben hast, finde gar keine V6-Adresse für den Namen, dann kann es ja gar nicht gehen. Also dann sieht man schon, wo die so mitspielen. Muss man mal einfach mal machen, muss man ein bisschen mitspielen, ist was als Hausaufgabe für die Hörer, mal zu gucken, was da so geht. Jetzt machen wir, zum Beispiel, mal www.metaebene.me wartet.
Ja, wird nicht funktionieren.
Das ist bitter.
Mein Provider hat mir aber gerade vor zwei Wochen mitgeteilt, dass sie jetzt auch von ihrem Provider auch IPv6 kriegen. Das wurde nämlich bisher noch nicht bis dorthin durchgebreitet. Also Content sozusagen noch nicht.
Das heißt, du bist nicht schuld, sondern dein Provider ist schuld?
Der Provider meines Providers ist schuld.
Na, er ist aber schuld deines Providers, sich nicht rechtzeitig darum gekümmert zu haben. Weil er ist ja Provider. Das ist ja sein Job. Er soll ja providen.
Ja, jetzt hat er auch providet, nur ich hab das jetzt sozusagen noch nicht in Realität umgesetzt, aber I'm working on it.
Okay.
Aber ich glaub, mein, kannst du das mal mit Meta, Punkt Meta-Ebene...
Ah, hier zum Beispiel vorhin erwähnte Fritzbox wird ja hergestellt von einer Firma namens AVM. Die lassen sich brav pingen. www.avm.de geht. Also wie gesagt, es gibt mehr Leute, als man denkt.
Ja, aber da gehört jetzt auch ein bisschen Wissen dazu, weil jetzt muss ich ja irgendwie auch immer noch gucken, wie kriege ich denn meinen Webserver da drauf, etc.
Aber da kannst du vielleicht gleich noch ein bisschen... Was muss eigentlich eine Applikation dafür tun, um V6 unterstützen zu können?
Genau, das wäre jetzt sozusagen als Ausgangsthema nochmal ganz interessant.
Wir haben ja als Eingang des Ausgangsthemas, hatten wir eben, was machen wir für die User, dass die User an V6 drankommen. Jetzt reden wir darüber. Wenn dein Provider das schon hat, was muss ich jetzt eigentlich als Serverbetreiber, was muss ich jetzt eigentlich dafür tun? Die Antwort ist erschreckend simpel. Wenn man eine Applikation hat, die sich nicht großartig darum schert, wer bei ihr anruft, also mit den IP-Adressen, die dort anklopfen, nicht großartig was macht, dann muss da eigentlich gar nichts mehr machen. Die Schnittstellen über die Libraries, über die Frameworks bis in den Kern und in den Socket hinein sind exakt identisch. Du musst eigentlich als Applikation nur sagen, ja, ich will. Das, was die Nutzdaten angeht. In dem Moment nur, die Unterschiede kommen dann raus, in dem Moment, wo du Metadaten benutzen willst, wo du zum Beispiel sagst, hallo, ich nehme jetzt mal hier eine Verbindung an, ein Socket, eine Connection. Wer ruft denn da jetzt eigentlich an? Dann benutze ich ja Library-Funktionen, die mir so sagen, mit wem rede ich da jetzt eigentlich gerade. Die mussten natürlich angepasst werden, weil vorher kamen da 32 Bit raus und jetzt kommen da plötzlich 128 Bit raus und bei der Gelegenheit hat man dieses Schnittstelle auch gleich so ein bisschen universalisiert.
Aber auch so die Eingabe von Adressen und so, ja, nicht in jedes Feld, wo man eine Domain-Namen oder eine IPv4-Adresse eingeben kann, kann man auch mal eben eine IPv6- Adresse eingeben. Muss ja auch gepasst werden.
Ja, also wie gesagt, dort, wo man die Adressen anfasst, aber du musst jetzt nicht anfangen, das ganze HTTP-Protokoll neu zu implementieren. Das kommt da nach wie vor aus der Steckdose, aus dem Socket wie vorher auch. Da musst du nichts dran machen. In dem Moment, wo du mit IP-Adressen anfasst, musst du natürlich was machen. Da gibt's allerdings schon fertige Libraries dafür. Also es wird ja sehr viel in dieser komischen Kaffeesprache programmiert, da in diesem Java. Die ganzen Frameworks können das alles schonen. Ja, da darfst du halt nur nicht anfangen, schlau zu sein. Das heißt, du musst jetzt nicht hingehen und sagen, ne, der User hat was eingegeben, wo nicht drei Punkte drin sind. Das kann keine IP-Adresse sein. Er hat jetzt was eingegeben, da sind Doppelpunkte drin, statt Punkte. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Wenn du das weiter an das Framework durchgibst, mach das einfach the right thing. Da musst du gar nicht großartig dran basteln. Da darfst du halt nur nicht schlauer sein. Du darfst auch nicht versuchen, Applikationen zu bauen, die statt einem Eingabefeld, wo tipp mal hier eine IP-Adresse ein, so vier Felderln haben. Wo man dann so maximal drei Ziffern eintippen kann mit einem Punkt dazwischen. Also wer so einen Blödsinn macht, hat natürlich verloren. Aber diese ganzen Frameworks und so weiter können, und zwar nicht erst seit gestern, das können die alle schon seit Jahren. Also wer so was macht und sich da nicht künstlich in den Fuß schießt, hat diese Umstellung relativ einfach im Griff. Wir haben natürlich jetzt einen Punkt ganz weggelassen, wir sind schon relativ eingestiegen. Vielleicht solltet ihr nochmal ganz kurz was zu sagen zu diesen Adressnotationen, wer hat es am Anfang mal gesagt. IPv4-Adressen, wer sie überhaupt jemand zu Gesicht bekommt, ist ja bekanntes Spiel, das sind halt vier Ziffernblöcke mit Zahlen von 0 bis 255 getrennt durch drei Punkte. Hat jeder schon mal gesehen, 1.2.3.4. Das ist eine valide IP-Adresse, IPv4-Adresse. IPv6-Adressen sehen auf Anhieb erst mal komplexer aus. Vor allen Dingen eine komplette Adresse ist teilweise echt furchterregend. Darf ich einfach mal eine vorlesen, dann verrate ich deinen Präfix. Na, ich ändere irgendwas an deinem Präfix, ja? Nee, ich lese meine Link-Local-Adresse vor. Also meine Link-Local-Adresse hier ist fe80.5ab0.35ff.fef2.4147%er0. 805AB0FFFEF24147%R0. BN0.
Ein feuchter Nerdtraum.
Ein feuchter Nerdtraum, ganz fürchterlich. Feuchterlich. Feuchterlich, muss aber so nicht sein. Was man macht, ist erstmal die Zahl, diese 128 Bit werden hexadezimal dargestellt, nicht dezimal wie im IPv4. Man teilt die auf in 8 Gruppen A16 Bits, die man durch Doppelpunkte trennt. Also vorher waren es 4 Gruppen A8 Bit durch Punkte getrennt. Jetzt hat man 8 Gruppen A16 Bit in hexadezimal durch Doppelpunkte getrennt. Klingt immer noch fies. Dann sind wir bei dem Punkt, den ich vorhin sagte, User mögen gerne die Nullen. Man hat Vereinfachungen eingeführt. Man kann zum Beispiel sagen, wenn man größere Stellen mit Nullen drin hat, dann kann man die einfach durch Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt abkürzen. D.h. dort, wo man Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt einsetzt, werden so viele Nullen reingefüllt, wie nötig sind. Das klingt jetzt sehr vage, macht aber Sinn, wenn ich dazu sage, dass man diese Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt-Verkürzung nur einmal benutzen darf. D.h. er guckt also wie viel ist links, wie viel ist rechts. Dadurch kommt man auf sehr kurze Adressen. Ich kann ja durchaus die Webseite, meinen Test-Server habe ich z.B., kann ja jeder mal draufklicken, wenn er Spaß hat und V6-Konaktivität hat. Der hat die einfach zu merken, eine IP-Adresse, eine V6-Adresse 2001, also ist ein europäisches System, Doppelpunkt 1560, aha, ich bin bei Internet-Netkunde, Doppelpunkt 42, das ist so mein Präfix, Doppelpunkt Doppelpunkt 42. Das ist relativ easy. Das kann sich jeder merken. Manchmal ist es sogar noch einfacher, wenn man sich einmal seinen Präfix gemerkt hat. Es ist dann noch einfacher, sich die IP-Adressen zu merken. Also es klingt jetzt nicht länger als 192, 148, 108, 92, 42 oder so was. Das ist...
Ich hab jetzt aber kein HTTP-Cyber drauf oder sowas.
Nimm mal den mit 61 hinten. 2001, 1560, Doppelpunkt 42, Doppelpunkt Doppelpunkt 61. Tippst du jetzt einen in deinen Browser oder was? Weil dein Browser oben glaubt, das wär ein Google-Search-Begriff. Mach mal die IP-Adresse in Ecke klammern. Dann weiß er nämlich, dass das eine IPv6-Adresse ist. Das ist so ein Test-Respon da drauf. Da siehst du, ich bin der, du bist der. Das sind unsere IP-Adressen. Und du kommst hier unverschlüsselt an und lauter so Zeugs. Gut, aber wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nur die textuelle Notation. Dann gibt es ja noch Leute, die sich darauf verstreift haben, zu sagen, okay, Hexa, die sind meine Zahlen, haben Buchstaben drin, die schreibt man bitte schön klein. Muss man nicht, aber für eine Null lässt man weg und so weiter.
Wo kriegt denn eigentlich so ein V6-Only dann seinen DNS-Server irgendwie her?
Über V6? DNS-Server kann er lernen über die Router-Advertisement. Oder der Router kann auch sagen, hallo, ich bin hier Router für so komplexe Sachen wie DNS, frag doch bitte einen DHCP-Server. Es gibt also nach wie vor einen DHCP-V6, auch im V6. Es hat dort nicht mehr so diese zentrale Rolle für IP-Adressvergabe, wie sie im V4 hat. Aber es hat nach wie vor dieselbe Rolle, wie hier dein Host, unser Domain ist so und so, der NTP-Server, die IP-Adresse und folgende Name-Server, sprichst du bitte an, lalalala. Ist also mehr so wirklich so ein... Oder dein SIP-Server, dein Gateway oder... Ja, sozusagen so die Rand-Konfiguration, was gehört hier noch dazu. Wobei aber DHCP auch eine Rolle spielt, glaube ich, aber weniger bei den Interanwendern. DHCPv6 hat einen super geilen Delegation-Mechanismus. Das, was ich dir vorhin erzählt habe, dass Adressen von einer zentralen Root-Instanz an RIPE vergeben werden, von denen an ISPs und von denen weiter und so fort. Diesen Mechanismus hat man in DHCPv6 verewigt. Dafür wird kein v6 heutzutage benutzt, aber DHCP kann Prefix Delegation machen. Das heißt, man kann per DHCPv6 jemanden fragen, ich brauch nicht nur eine IP-Adresse, ich brauch ein ganzes Netz. Kannst du mir nicht mal ein Netz geben? Und der kann es selber auch weiterreichen. Bei mehreren Hierarchiestufen kann man sagen, ich hätte gerne Netz. Und der kann sagen, ja, schön, aber davon verteile ich jetzt ein Unternetz wieder weiter an denen. Das heißt, du kannst darüber automatische Netz-Hierarchie-Verteilstufen machen. Das funktioniert sogar erstaunlicherweise. Und der letzte Router, der dann am Ende dieser Kette ist, macht ganz normal über Router-Advertisement diese Präfixe. Aber die Frage steht ja auch vielleicht im Raum, wenn man mehrere Router hat, woher kriegt eigentlich mein Router seinen Präfix? Entweder konfiguriert man den von Hand hin, aber manchmal kriegt er den ja auch zugeteilt. Kriegt es im Falle von DSL und wenn das mit PPPoE passiert, kriegt er den über IPv6-CP mitgeteilt. Da kriegt er so ein paar Sachen. Aber wenn er jetzt selber noch weiter Netze vergeben will oder weitere Präfixe braucht, dann holt er sich die per DHCPv6 von seinem Provider und verteilt sie dann selber wieder weiter. Unter anderem auch an Unterrouter, die sie dann wieder weiter verteilen können. Das ist sozusagen der feuchte Traum eines Admins für ein Firmennetz in der Größe von Siemens oder so. Dass du das alles schön etabliert hast und nimmst deinen Stecker, dein Kabel, dein Ethernet-Kabel, steckst es bei Provider A rein. Plötzlich macht es bap, bap, bap, bap, bap, bap. Durch deine ganze Organisation durch, kriegen alle Leute plötzlich IP-Adressen. Jetzt nimmst du dein zweites Kabel, steckst es bei Provider B rein und tatatatatata. Geht das wieder durch. Das kannst du bauen. Das funktioniert sogar. Das macht dein Homerouter nicht. Der macht solche DHCP-Privates-Delegation-Nummer nicht. Aber das geht. Mit so Cisco-Boxen oder anderen Julepads, so geht das.
Die Zeit wird kommen. Wir werden irgendwann, werden wir das noch erleben?
Dass du mehrere Router zu Hause hast?
Nein, dass ich so ein V6-only-Netzwerk habe. Und dann, wenn man, wenn dann so einer, weißt du, dann klickt man irgendwas an. Und dann so was, wie? Der hat noch keinen V6 und so.
Ja.
Der Server ist ja nur, oh mein Gott, irgendwie.
Ja, also ich hab das schon. Für die Leute jetzt schon so. Ja, manchmal, manchmal schon. Weil ich hab in meiner gesamten, ich hab in meiner gesamten Umgebung privat zu Hause und in der Firma hab ich überall schon seit Jahren V6.
Ja gut, aber dann Twitter...
Mir fällt's halt immer wieder auf, wenn ich irgendwo hingehe und so meine Stande... Ach so, stimmt, du kannst ja gar nicht. Du musst ja anders machen. Eine Sache muss ich noch kurz dir und den Hörern noch zeigen. Geh mal auf www.kame.net. kame.net. Was hab ich schon vor Jahren schon Leute auf irgendwelchen Veranstaltungen gesehen, die plötzlich aufsprangen und schrien, the turtle is dancing, the turtle is dancing. Das waren halt einfach diese Webseite, da ist eine Schildkröte drauf dargestellt. Und wenn man die, wenn man V6-Konnektivität hat, dann bewegt sich diese Schildkröte. Das ist ein animated GIF. Und wenn man nur per V4 kommt, dann steht die einfach still. Das Ding ist in Japan. Das sind die Leute, die diesen Kami-Stack haben, der übrigens auch heute noch Grundlage ist des IPv6-Stacks in Mac aus X zum Beispiel oder in NetBSD. Und das war echt toll. Du hast Leute gesehen, erwachsene Leute, die irgendwie ewig rumgebastelt haben, ihre Router zu konfigurieren und vielleicht hier noch in Tunneln und da war Debugged und dann immer wieder getestet und plötzlich tanzte diese Schildkröte. Und dann diese, yeah, the turtle is dancing, the turtle is dancing. Das ist echt was für Nerds. Aber kann man, wie gesagt, wenn man zu Hause rumgebastelt hat, sollte man schon aus diesen Gründen einfach mal www.cami.net mal aufrufen und mal gucken, ob die Turtle sich da bewegt. Wenn man lame ist, kann man zum Beispiel einfach www.ripe.net aufrufen. Unsere Freunde von der Adressvergabe und dann oben rechts auf der Webseite gucken, da steht, den Your IP-Adress ist. Und wenn die schön lang ist und schöne viele Doppelpunkte drin hat, dann sollte man sich freuen.
Gibt es da dann welche anderen Vorteile, die man jetzt hat, wenn man V6 hat, außer jetzt von so ein paar nerdy Servern, die aus Prinzip nur unter V6 betrieben werden?
Als normaler Anwender hast du keine, hast du keine, du merkst es, eigentlich solltest du auch nicht merken. Tippst oben deine Webseite ein, deine Google Search Bar und dann passiert irgendwie was und dann interessiert dich das eigentlich nicht. Als normaler Anwender hast du nichts davon. Du wirst was davon haben, wenn es jetzt immer mehr Appliances gibt, also Geräte, also die berühmte Glühbirne oder die Kühlschränke, die sowas können. Und da gibt es eben erstaunlich viele davon. Und dann hast du auch erst den Vorteil davon, wenn du willst, dass du diese Dinger von deinem iPhone aus Hause erreichst oder von unterwegs erreichst oder wie auch immer. Also wenn du sozusagen, wenn du diese Vorteile, dass du mehrere Geräte eindeutig identifizieren kannst und zugreifen kannst und la la la auch wirklich ausschöpfen kannst. Wer durchaus was davon hat, sind wie gesagt industrielle Leute. Wir haben vorhin diesen RFC 1918-Adressraum erwähnt, der jetzt im IPv4 benutzt wird für private Netze. Der ist unglaublich ausgeknutscht. Bei so einer riesen Telekom, wie Telekom oder Wodafone durch die Tür gehst, die haben wirklich jede verdammte Bit, was davon gibt, irgendwo doppelt und dreifach benutzt. Es ist unglaublich, was es dort für Kloppereien gibt, wenn du innerhalb einer solchen Firma ein Projekt machen willst, wo du einen Server hinstellen musst. Dann machst du riesen Projekte für 100.000 oder Millionen Euro. Und dann schickst du da an so einen Admin so eine Mail und sagst so Hallo, wir machen jetzt hier ein tolles neues Projekt und hier müssen wir 5 Server aufstellen, gib mir mal IP-Adressen. Und der so 5, müssen das wirklich 5 sein? Reichen dir nicht auch 4? Und diese Diskussion, die du denn dort hast, ist unglaublich.
Obwohl es sowas wie das Zehnernetz gibt.
Ja, aber wie gesagt eine Strukturgeschichte. Und Delegation Here und ausgeknaut. Die Vodafonis machen ja oder die Telekons machen das Zehnernetz ja schon mit ihren scheiß Endkunden voll. Deswegen benutzen diese Adressen schon doppelt. Also es gibt schon, du kannst als Telekom-Kunde oder als Vodafone-Kunde im UMTS eine IP-Adresse benutzen, die die nochmal in ihrer eigenen Infrastruktur vielleicht ganz anders benutzen. Das ist wirklich hanebüchen. Und allein diese Reibereien, diese Kloppereien dazu ist fürchterlich. Es gibt heute für industrielle Anwender keinerlei Grund, V6 nicht zu benutzen. Es ist weder weniger secure, noch weniger performant als V4 oder sowas. Und es nimmt dir einen unglaublichen Set von Kopfschmerzen weg, wenn du einfach dein Netz machst und alles, was du neu machst, einfach mit V6 machst.
Gerade, wenn man jetzt so Embedded-Systeme, Hausautomation, Fernsteuerungssachen.
Und du musst dich noch nicht einmal hinsetzen und Gigabyte große Excel-Sheets pflegen, um zu überlegen, wem du jetzt welche Adresse geteilt hast. Weil die teilen sich die Adresse selber zu. Die geben die sich selber. Du nimmst einfach deine V6-fähige Gübirne und schraubst sie rein. Und tschüss. Fertig. Die meldet sich dann irgendwo. Die sucht sich ihren Router. Und wenn sie cool ist, macht sie ein Bonjour-Announcement, dass sie sagt, hallo, ich stelle den Dienst Licht zur Verfügung. Auf TCP-Port 4711. Und bin ein Modell so und so. Kann sich alles autoconfigurieren. Ich sage den Leuten wirklich nur, schmeißt diese paranoiden Admins raus, die wirklich jede Bit unter Kontrolle haben wollen. Weil das klappt auch nicht. Wer das schon ein paar Jahre macht, stellt fest, dass die einem mehr Aga bereiten als alle anderen. Nutzt diese Autokonfiguration, macht euer Netz von außen schön dicht. Jetzt werden wieder so Leute wie Fefe mich anspringen, wenn die den überhaupt hören und sagen, Perimeter Security. Aber das wären einfach so viele Devices, inzwischen kannst du die nicht mehr sinnvoll verwalten, ohne dir selber einen Fuß zu schießen, wenn du anfängst, jedes Ding einzeln zu befummeln. Mit IP-Adressen und so weiter und so fort. Ich habe das in meinem letzten Job, habe ich das übrigens auch als elaboriertes Thema ausgeknuspert und gemacht und getan. Und habe denen gesagt, so bauen wir größere Server-Systeme mit Dutzenden von Servern, wo kein Admin mehr hingehen muss oder kein Installateur und hier von Handadressen einhämmern muss in die Maschinen. Und etc. Host-Dateien kopieren oder und so einen anderen Scheiß, was die da halt machen. Das kann man halt machen. Also für diese Anwender ist das ein echter Segen. Der Home-Anwender zu Hause mit seiner Facebook-Seite merkt davon nichts, soll er auch nicht, bis er irgendwann mal die berühmte Glückwünsche hat. Aber industrielle Anwender können nicht nur seit heute, sondern auch schon seit gestern. Weil denen ist ja wieder egal, ob es im Internet funktioniert. Die wollen ja nur die Technik benutzen im privaten Netz. Die wollen ja gar nicht jeden Server, den sie da in ihrem Netz haben, am Internet dran haben. Aber die sollen diese Technik benutzen und sich damit endlich befreien von dieser Last, dieser quälenden Last, mit diesem Adress zu teilen. Also wirklich riesengroße Projekte gehabt bei großen Telcos, wo so ein System erweitert werden sollte. Wir haben Server und dann haben wir den Adressraum vollgemacht und dann kamen viele Nutzer und der User, der Marketing fand das toll, sagt, wir kaufen eine Erweiterung. Haben wir gesagt, verkaufen wir euch. Und wann könnt ihr die denn installieren? Die User warten, die User trommeln. Ja, machen wir mal 14 Tage, hauen wir neue Server rein. Alles super toll. Und dann sitzt du da und wartest 4, 5 Monate darauf, dass dir irgendeinen fucking Admin einen neuen IP-Adressrange gibt. Oder du kannst den alten nicht aufbohren, weil du kannst ihn nicht ändern, weil der Adressraum hinter deinem ist schon vergeben an irgendwas anderes. Wirklich unglaublich. Und das hast du alles mit v6 nicht mehr. Du hast so viel Adressraum. Wenn du einmal ein Netz eingerichtet hast, kannst du sämtliche Rechner dieser Welt und für die nächsten 4.000 Jahre alle in die selbe Netz reinstellen oder auch nicht. Dieses Thema ist einfach vorbei. Und das ist wirklich für die Leute ein Segen, wenn sie den als solchen erkennen würden.
Ja, Clemens, ich glaube, das Thema ist jetzt auch vorbei. Jetzt haben wir auch hier eine Podcast-Rekorde. Dieses Kanal ist wieder gerissen.
Ich habe mir echt vorgenommen, unter Andreas zu bleiben. Aber Mist.
Da hast du total gefehlt in der Hinsicht. Trotz an den Themen. Und, weiß nicht, gibt es noch irgendwas?
Haben wir noch was vergessen?
Unter Garantie haben wir was vergessen. Aber ich meine, diese Sendung soll ja mal ein Einstieg sein. Und ich glaube, über den Einstieg sind wir schon deutlich hinaus.
Wir sind teilweise sehr tief eingetaucht, wenn ich jetzt mal retrospective...
Das ist ja ja auch kein Fehler, ne?
Ja, gehört ja dazu. Okay.
Das ist das, was intensives Gespräch über ein Thema bedeutet. Trotz alledem, Anmerkungen, Kommentare, etc. gern gesehen. Und ja, wir sehen uns dann demnächst in einem anderen Addressrange. Demnächst auf IPv6. Ich werde dann mal zusehen, dass ich hier meine Server zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung auch schon entsprechend gepimpt bekommen habe. Alles klar, das war's. Tschüss, vielen Dank, bis bald. Das war CRE 197.